tim ferriss presents
ego is the enemy
written by ryan holliday narrated by
ryan holiday
[Music]
do not believe that he who seeks to
comfort you lives untroubled among the
simple and quiet words that sometimes do
you could
his life has much difficulty and sadness
and remains far behind yours
worried otherwise he never would have
been able to find those words
the words of rainier maria rilke
the painful prologue
this is not a book about me but since
this is a book about ego i'm going to
address a question that i'd be a
hypocrite not to have thought about
who the hell am i to write it
my story is not particularly important
for the lessons that follow but i want
to tell it briefly here at the beginning
in order to provide some context
for i have experienced ego at each of
its stages in my short life aspiration
success failure and back again and back
again
when i was 19 years old sensing some
astounding and life-changing
opportunities i dropped out of college
mentors vied for my attention groomed me
as their protege
seen as going places i was the kid
success came quickly
after i became the youngest executive at
a beverly hills talent management agency
i helped sign and work with a number of
huge rock bands i advised on books that
went on to sell millions of copies and
invent their own literary genres
around the time i turned 21 i came on as
a strategist for american apparel then
one of the hottest fashion brands in the
world soon i was the director of
marketing
by 25 i'd published my first book which
was an immediate and controversial
bestseller with my face prominently on
the cover a studio optioned the rights
to create a television show about my
life
in the next few years i accumulated many
of the trappings of success influence a
platform press resources money even a
little notoriety
later i built a successful company on
the back of those assets where i worked
with well-known well-paying clients and
did the kind of work that got me invited
to speak at conferences and fancy events
with success comes the temptation to
tell oneself a story to round off the
edges to cut out your lucky breaks and
add a certain mythology to it all you
know that arcing narrative of herculean
struggle for greatness against all odds
sleeping on the floor being disowned by
my parents suffering from my ambition
it's the type of storytelling in which
eventually your talent becomes your
identity and your accomplishments become
your worth
but a story like this is never honest or
helpful in my retelling to you just now
i left a lot out
conveniently omitted were the stresses
and temptations the stomach turning
drops and the mistakes all the mistakes
were left on the cutting room floor in
favor of the highlight reel
they are the times i would rather not
discuss a public evisceration by someone
i looked up to which so crushed me at
the time that i was later taken to the
emergency room the day i lost my nerve
walked into my boss's office and told
him i couldn't cut it it was going back
to school and meant it the ephemeral
nature of best sellerdom and how short
it actually was a week
the book signing that one person showed
up at the company i founded tearing
itself to pieces and having to rebuild
it twice
these are just some of the moments that
get nicely edited out
this fuller picture itself is still only
a fraction of a life but at least it
hits more of the important notes at
least the important ones for this book
ambition achievement and adversity
i'm not someone who believes in
epiphanies there is no one moment that
changes a person there are many
during a period of about six months in
2014
it seemed those moments were all
happening in succession first american
apparel where i did much of my best work
teetered on the edge of bankruptcy
hundreds of millions of dollars in debt
a shell of its former self
its founder who i deeply admired since i
was a young man was unceremoniously
fired by his own hand-picked board of
directors and down to sleeping on a
friend's couch
then the talent agency where i made my
bones was in similar shape
sued preemptorly by clients to whom it
owed a lot of money
another mentor of mine seemingly
unraveled around the same time taking
our relationship with him
these were the people i had shaped my
life around the people i looked up to
and trained under their stability
financially emotionally psychologically
was not just something i took for
granted it was central to my existence
and self-worth
and yet there they were imploding right
in front of me one right after another
the wheels were coming off or so it felt
to go from wanting to be like someone
your whole life to realizing you never
want to be like him is a kind of
whiplash that you can't prepare for
nor was i exempt from this dissolution
myself
just when i could least afford it
problems i had neglected in my own life
began to emerge
despite my successes i found myself back
in the city i had started in stressed
and overworked having handed much of my
hard-earned freedom away because i
couldn't say no to money and the thrill
of a good crisis
i was wound so tight that the slightest
disruption sent me into a sputtering
inconsolable rage
my work which had always come easy
became labored my faith in myself and
other people collapsed my quality of
life did too
i remember arriving at my house one day
after weeks on the road and having an
intense panic attack because the wi-fi
wasn't working if i don't send these
emails if i don't send these emails if i
don't send these emails if i don't send
these emails
you think you're doing what you're
supposed to society rewards you for it
and then you watch your future wife walk
out the door because you aren't the
person you used to be
how does something like this happen
can you really go from feeling like
you're standing on the shoulders of
giants one day and then next you're
prying yourself out of the rubble of
multiple implosions
trying to pick up the pieces from the
ruins
one benefit however was that it forced
me to come to terms with the fact that i
was a workaholic
not an o he just works too much kind of
way or in the just relax and play it off
since but more if he doesn't start going
to meetings and get clean he will die an
early death
i realize that the same drive and
compulsion that had made me successful
so early came with a price as it had for
so many others it wasn't so much the
amount of work but the outsized role it
had taken in my sense of self
i was trapped so terribly inside my own
head that i was a prisoner to my own
thoughts
the result was a sort of treadmill of
pain and frustration and i needed to
figure out why unless i wanted to break
in an equally tragic fashion
for a long time as a researcher and
writer i have studied history and
business
like anything that evolves people seen
over long enough timeline universal
issues begin to emerge
these are the topics i had long been
fascinated with foremost among them was
ego
i was not unfamiliar with ego and its
effects in fact i had been researching
this book for nearly a year before the
events i have just recounted for you but
my painful experiences in this period
brought the notions i was studying and
to focus in ways that i could never have
previously understood it allowed me to
see the ill effects of ego played out
not just in myself or across the pages
of history but in friends and clients
and colleagues some at the highest
levels of many industries
ego has cost the people i admire
hundreds of millions of dollars and like
sisyphus rolled them back from their
goals just as they've achieved them
i have now at least peeked over that
precipice myself
a few months after my own realization i
had the phrase ego is the enemy tattooed
on my right forearm
where the words came from i don't know
probably from a book i read long long
ago
but they were immediately a source of
great solace and direction
on my left arm of similarly muddled
attribution it says the obstacle is the
way
it's these two phases that i look at now
every single day and use them to guide
the decisions in my life
i can't help but see them when i swim
when i meditate when i write when i get
out of the shower in the morning and
both prepare me admonish me to choose
the right course in essentially any
situation i might face
i wrote this book not because i have
attained some wisdom that i feel
qualified to preach but because it's the
book i wish existed at critical turning
points in my own life
when i like everyone else was called to
answer the most critical questions a
person can ask themselves
who do i want to be and what path will i
take in latin cuvad vecte sectabor
and because i found these questions to
be timeless and universal except for
this note i've tried to rely on
philosophy and historical examples in
this book instead of my personal life
while the history books are filled with
tales of obsessive visionary geniuses
who remade the world in their image with
sheer almost irrational force
i found that if you go looking you'll
find that history is also made by
individuals who fought their egos at
every turn who has skewed the spotlight
and put their higher goals above their
desires for recognition
engaging with and retelling these
stories has been my method of learning
and absorbing them
like my other books this one is deeply
influenced by stoic philosophy and
indeed all the great classical thinkers
i borrow heavily from them all in my
writing just as i have leaned on them my
entire life
if there is anything here that helps you
in this book it is because of them and
not me
the orator demosthenes once said that
virtue begins with understanding and is
fulfilled by courage
we must begin by seeing ourselves and
the world in a new way for the first
time then we must fight to be different
and fight to stay different that's the
hard part
i'm not saying that you should repress
or crush every ounce of ego in your life
or that doing so is even possible
these are just reminders moral stories
to encourage are better impulses
in aristotle's famous ethics he uses the
analogy of a warped piece of wood to
describe human nature
in order to eliminate warping or
curvature a skilled woodworker slowly
applies pressure in the opposite
direction
essentially bending it straight
of course a couple thousand years later
kant snorted
out of the crooked timber of humanity
nothing can be made straight
well we might not ever be straight but
we can strive for straighter
it's always nice to be made to feel
special or empowered or inspired but
that's not the aim of this book
instead i have tried to arrange these
pages so that you might end in the same
place that i did when i finished writing
it that is you'll think less of yourself
i hope you will be less invested in the
story you tell about your own
specialness and as a result you will be
liberated to accomplish the world
changing work you've set out to achieve
[Music]
introduction
the first principle is that you must not
fool yourself and you are the easiest
person to fool
richard feynman
maybe you're young and brimming with
ambition
maybe you're young and you're struggling
maybe you've made that first couple
million signed your first deal been
selected to some elite group or maybe
you've already accomplished enough to
last a lifetime maybe you're stunned to
find out how empty it is at the top
maybe you're charged with leading others
through a crisis maybe you just got
fired
maybe you just hit rock bottom
wherever you are whatever you're doing
your worst enemy already lives inside
you your ego
not me you think
no one would ever call me an egomaniac
perhaps you've always thought of
yourself as a pretty balanced person but
for people with ambitions talents drives
and potential to fulfill ego comes with
the territory
precisely what makes us so promising as
thinkers doers creatives and
entrepreneurs what drives us to the top
of those fields makes us vulnerable to
this darker side of the psyche
now this is not a book about ego in the
freudian sense
freud was fond of explaining the ego by
way of analogy our ego was a rider on a
horse with our unconscious drives
representing the animal while the ego
tried to direct them
modern psychologists on the other hand
used the word egotist to refer to
someone dangerously focused on
themselves and with disregard for anyone
else all of these definitions are true
enough but of little value outside a
clinical setting
the ego we see most commonly goes by a
more casual definition an unhealthy
belief in our own importance
arrogance self-centered ambition
that's the definition this book will use
it's that petulant child inside every
person the one that chooses getting his
or her way over anything or anyone else
the need to be better than more than
recognized for far past any reasonable
utility that's ego
it's the sense of superiority and
certainty that exceeds the bounds of
confidence and talent
it's when the notion of ourselves and
the world grows so inflated that it
begins to distort the reality that
surrounds us
when as the football coach bill walsh
explained self-confidence becomes
arrogance assertiveness becomes
obstinacy and self-assurance becomes
reckless abandon
this is the ego as the writer cyril
connolly warned that sucks us down like
the law of gravity
in this way ego is the enemy of what you
want and of what you have of mastering a
craft of real creative insight of
working well with others of building
loyalty and support of longevity of
repeating and retaining your success it
repulses advantages and opportunities it
is a magnet for enemies and errors it is
sela and charybdis
most of us aren't egomaniacs but ego is
there at the root of almost every
conceivable problem and obstacle from
why we can't win to why we need to win
all the time and at the expense of
others
from why we don't seem to have what we
want to why having what we want doesn't
seem to make us feel any better
we don't usually see it this way we
think that something else is to blame
for our problems
most often other people
we are as the poet lucretius put it a
few thousand years ago the proverbial
sick man ignorant of the cause of his
malady especially for successful people
who can't see what ego prevents them
from doing because all they can see is
what they've already done
with every ambition and goal we have big
or small ego is there undermining us on
the very journey we've put everything
into pursuing
the pioneering ceo harold genon compared
egoism to alcoholism
he said the egotist does not stumble
about knocking things off his desk he
does not stammer or drool
no instead he becomes more and more
arrogant and some people not knowing
what is underneath such an attitude
mistake his arrogance for a sense of
power and self-confidence
you could say that they start to mistake
that about themselves too
not realizing the disease they've
contracted or that they're killing
themselves with it
if ego was the voice that tells us we're
better than we really are
we can say ego inhibits true success by
preventing a direct and honest
connection to the world around us
one of the early members of alcoholics
anonymous defined ego as a conscious
separation from
from what
everything
the ways this separation manifests
itself negatively are immense
we can't work with other people if we
put up walls we can't improve the world
if we don't understand it or ourselves
we can't take or receive feedback if we
are incapable of or uninterested in
hearing from outside sources we can't
recognize opportunities or create them
if instead of seeing what is in front of
us we live inside our own fantasy
without an accurate accounting of our
own abilities compared to others
what we have is not confidence but
delusion
how are we supposed to reach motivate or
lead other people if we can't relate to
their needs because we've lost touch
with our own
the performance artist marina abramovic
puts it directly if you start believing
in your own greatness
it is the death of your creativity
just one thing keeps ego around comfort
pursuing great work whether it is in
sports or art or business is often
terrifying
ego sues that fear it's a salve to that
insecurity
replacing the rational and aware parts
of our psyche with bluster and
self-absorption ego tells us what we
want to hear when we want to hear it
but it is a short-term fix with a
long-term consequence
ego was always there now it's emboldened
now more than ever our culture fans the
flames of ego
it's never been easier to talk to puff
ourselves up we can brag about our goals
to millions of our fans or followers
things only rock stars or cult leaders
used to have
we can follow and interact with our
idols on twitter we can read books and
sites and watch ted talks drink from a
fire hose of inspiration and validation
like never before there's an app for
that
we can name ourselves ceo of our exists
only on paper company we can announce
big news on social media and let the
congratulations roll in
we can publish articles about ourselves
in outlets that used to be sources of
objective journalism
some of us do this more than others but
it's only a matter of degree
besides the changes in technology we're
told to believe in our own uniqueness
above all else we're told to think big
live big to be memorable and dare
greatly
we think that success requires a bold
vision or some sweeping plan
after all that's what the founders of
this company or that championship team
supposedly had but did they
did they really
we see risk taking swagger and
successful people in the media and eager
for our own success try to reverse
engineer the right attitude the right
pose
we intuit a causal relationship that
isn't there we assume the symptoms of
success are the same as success itself
and in our naivete confuse the byproduct
with the cause
sure ego has worked for some many of
history's most famous men and women were
notoriously egotistical
but so were many of its greatest
failures
far more of them in fact but here we are
with a culture that urges us to roll the
dice to make the gamble ignoring the
stakes
wherever you go ego is too
at any given time in life people find
themselves in one of three stages
we are aspiring to something trying to
make a dent in the universe we have
achieved success perhaps a little
perhaps a lot or we have failed recently
or continually
most of us are in these stages in a
fluid sense we're aspiring until we
succeed we succeed until we fail or
until we aspire to more and after we
fail we can begin to aspire or succeed
again
ego is the enemy every step along this
way
in a sense ego is the enemy of building
of maintaining
and of recovering
when things come fast and easy this
might be fine but in times of change of
difficulty
and therefore the three parts that this
book is organized into
aspire success
failure
the aim of that structure is simple to
help you suppress ego early before bad
habits take hold to replace the
temptations of ego with humility and
discipline when we experience success
and to cultivate strength and fortitude
so that when fate turns against you
you're not wrecked by failure
in short it will help us to be humble in
our aspirations
gracious in our success
resilient in our failures
that is not to say you are not unique
and that you don't have something
amazing to contribute in your short time
on this planet
this is not to say that there is not
room to push past creative boundaries to
invent to feel inspired or to aim for
truly ambitious change or innovation
on the contrary in order to properly do
these things and take these risks we
need balance
as the quaker william penn observed
buildings that lie so exposed to the
weather need a good foundation
so what now
this audio book that you're listening to
is based around one optimistic
assumption that your ego is not some
power you're forced to satiate at every
turn it can be managed it can be
directed
in this book we will look at individuals
like william tecumseh sherman catherine
graham jackie robinson eleanor roosevelt
bill walsh benjamin franklin belisarius
angela merkel and george c marshall
could they have accomplished what they
accomplished saving faltering companies
advancing the art of war integrating
baseball revolutionizing football
offense standing up to tyranny bravely
bearing misfortune if ego had left them
ungrounded or self-absorbed
it was their sense of reality and
awareness one that the author and
strategist robert greene once said that
we must take to like a spider in its web
that was at the core of their great art
great writing great design great
business great marketing and great
leadership
what we find when we study these
individuals is that they were grounded
circumspect and unflinchingly real
not that any of them were holy without
ego but they knew how to suppress it
channel it subsume it when it counted
they were great yet humble
wait but so and so had a huge ego and
was successful but what about steve jobs
what about kanye west
we can seek to rationalize the worst
behavior by pointing to outliers
but no one is truly successful because
they are delusional self-absorbed or
disconnected
even if these traits are correlated or
associated with certain well-known
individuals so are a few others
addiction abuse of themselves and others
depression mania
in fact what we see when we study these
people is that they did their best work
in the moments when they fought back
against these impulses disorders and
flaws
only when free of ego and baggage can
anyone perform to their utmost
for this reason we're also going to look
at individuals like howard hughes the
persian king xerxes john delorean
alexander the great and at the many
cautionary tales of others who lost
their grip on reality and in the process
made it clear what a gamble ego can be
we'll look at the costly lessons they
learned and at the price they paid in
misery and self-destruction
we'll look at how often even the most
successful people can vacillate between
humility and ego and the problems this
causes
when we remove ego we're left with what
is real
what replaces ego is humility yes but
rock hard humility and confidence
whereas ego is artificial this type of
confidence can hold weight
ego was stolen confidence is earned
ego is self-anointed its swagger is
artifice
one is girding yourself and the other
gaslighting it's the difference between
potent and poisonous
as you'll hear in the pages that follow
that self-confidence took an unassuming
and underestimated general and turned
him into america's foremost warrior and
strategist during the civil war
ego took a different general from the
heights of power and influence after
that same war and drove him to
destitution and ignominy
one took a quiet sober german scientist
and made her not just a new kind of
leader but a force for peace
the other took two different but equally
brilliant and bold engineering minds of
the 20th century and built them up in a
whirlwind of hype and celebrity before
dashing their hopes against the rocks of
failure bankruptcy scandal and insanity
one guided one of the worst teams in nfl
history to the super bowl in three
seasons and then on to be one of the
most dominant dynasties in the game
meanwhile countless other coaches
politicians entrepreneurs and writers
have overcome similar odds only to
succumb to the more inevitable
probability of handing the top spot
right back to someone else
some learn humility some choose ego
some are prepared for the vicissitudes
of fate both positive and negative
others are not
which will you choose who will you be
you're listening to this book because
you sense that you'll need to answer
this question eventually consciously or
not
well here we are let's get to it
[Music]
part one
aspire
here we are setting out to do something
we have a goal a calling a new beginning
every great journey begins here
yet far too many of us never reach our
intended destination
ego more often than not is the culprit
we build ourselves up with fantastical
stories we pretend we have it all
figured out we let our star burn bright
and hot only to fizzle out and we have
no idea why
these are the symptoms of ego for which
humility and reality are the cure
to whatever you aspire ego
is your enemy
he is a bold surgeon they say whose hand
does not tremble when he performs an
operation upon his own person
and he is often equally bold who does
not hesitate to pull off the mysterious
veil of self-delusion which covers from
his view the deformities of his own
conduct
adam smith
sometime around the year 374 bc
i socrates one of the most well-known
teachers in rhetoricians in athens
wrote a letter to a young man named
demonicus
i socrates had been a friend of the
boy's recently deceased father and
wanted to pass on to him some advice on
how to follow his father's example
the advice ranged from practical to
moral
all communicated in what as socrates
described as noble maxims
they were as he put it precepts for the
years to come
like many of us demonicus was ambitious
which is why i socrates wrote to him
because the path of ambition can be
dangerous
i socrates began by informing the young
man that no adornment so becomes you as
modesty justice and self-control for
these are the virtues by which as all
men are agreed the character of the
young is held in restraint
practice self-control he said warning
demonicus not to fall under the sway of
temper pleasure and pain
and of horror flatterers as you would
deceivers for both if trusted injure
those who trust them
he wanted him to be affable in your
relations with those who approach you
and never haughty for the pride of the
arrogant even slaves can hardly endure
and be slow in deliberation but be
prompt to carry out your resolves
and the best thing which we have in
ourselves is good judgment
constantly train your intellect he told
him for the greatest thing in the
smallest compass is a sound mind in a
human body
some of his advice might sound familiar
because it made its way over the next
two thousand years to william
shakespeare who often warned about ego
run amok
in fact in hamlet using this very letter
as his model shakespeare puts
isocrates's words in the mouth of his
character polonius in his speech to his
son laertes
the speech if you happen to have heard
it wraps up with this little verse this
above all to thine own self be true and
it must follow as the night the day
thou canst not then be false to any man
farewell my blessing sees in this in
thee
as it happened shakespeare's words also
made their way to a young united states
military officer named william tecumseh
sherman who would go on to become
perhaps this country's greatest general
and strategic thinker
he may never have heard of isocrates but
he loved the play and often quoted this
very speech
like demonicus
sherman's father died when he was very
young
like demonicus he was taken under the
wing of a wise older man in this case
thomas ewing a soon-to-be u.s senator
and friend of sherman's father who
adopted the young boy and raised him as
his own
what's interesting about sherman is that
despite his connected father almost no
one would have predicted much more than
regional accomplishments least of all
that he would one day need to take the
unprecedented step of refusing the
presidency of the united states
unlike a napoleon who bursts upon the
scene from nowhere and disappears in
failure just as quickly
sherman's ascent was a slow and gradual
one
he spent his early years at west point
and then in the army
for his first few years in service
sherman traversed nearly the entire
united states on horseback slowly
learning with each posting
as the rumblings of civil war broke out
sherman made his way east to volunteer
his services and he was shortly put to
use at the battle of bull run
a rather disastrous union defeat
benefiting from a dire shortage of
leadership sherman was promoted to
brigadier general and was summoned to
meet with president lincoln and his top
military advisor
on several occasions sherman freely
strategized and planned with the
president but at the end of his trip he
made one strange request he'd accept his
new promotion
only with the assurance that he'd not
have to assume superior command
would lincoln give him his word on that
with every other general asking for as
much rank and power as possible lincoln
happily agreed
at this point in time sherman felt more
comfortable as a number two
he felt he had an honest appreciation
for his own abilities and that this role
best suited him
imagine that an ambitious person turning
down a chance to advance in
responsibilities because he actually
wanted to be ready for them is that
really so crazy
not that sherman was always the perfect
model of restraint and order
early in the war tasked with defending
the state of kentucky with insufficient
troops his mania and tendency to doubt
himself combined in a wicked way
ranting and raving about being
undersupplied unable to get out of his
own head
paranoid about enemy movements he broke
form and spoke injudiciously to several
newspaper reporters
in the ensuing controversy he was
temporarily recalled from his command
it took weeks of rest for him to recover
it was one of a few nearly catastrophic
moments in his otherwise steadily
ascendant career
it was after this brief stumble having
learned from it that sherman truly made
his mark
for instance during the siege at fort
donelson sherman technically held a
senior rank to general ulysses s grant
while the rest of lincoln's generals
fought amongst themselves for personal
power and recognition sherman waved his
rank
choosing to cheerfully support and
reinforce grant instead of issuing
orders
this is your show sherman told them in a
note accompanying a shipment of supplies
call on me for any assistance i can
provide
together they won one of the union's
first victories in the war
building on his success sherman began to
advocate for his famous march to the sea
a strategically bold and audacious plan
not born out of some creative genius
but rather relying on the exact
topography he'd scouted and studied as a
young officer
in what had then seemed like a pointless
backwater outpost
but where sherman had once been cautious
he was now confident
but unlike so many others who possess
great ambition he earned this opinion
as he carved a path from chattanooga to
atlanta and then atlanta to the sea he
avoided traditional battle after
traditional battle any student of
military history can see how the exact
same invasion driven by ego instead of a
strong sense of purpose would have had a
far different ending
his realism allowed him to see a path
through the south that others thought
impossible his entire theory of maneuver
warfare rested on deliberately avoiding
frontal assaults or shows of strength in
the form of pitched battles and ignoring
criticism designed to bait a reaction he
paid no notice and stuck to his plan
by the end of the war sherman was one of
the most famous men in america yet he
sought no public office and had no taste
for politics and wished simply to do his
job and then eventually retire
dismissing the incessant praise and
attention endemic to such success he
wrote as a warning to his friend grant
be natural in yourself and this
glittering flattery will be as the
passing breeze of the sea on a warm
summer day
one of sherman's biographers summarized
the man in his unique accomplishments in
a remarkable passage
it is why he serves as our model in this
phase of our ascent
he wrote among men who rise to fame and
leadership two types are recognizable
those who are born with a belief in
themselves and those in whom it is a
slow growth dependent on actual
achievement
to the men of the last type their own
success is a constant surprise and its
fruits the more delicious
yet to be tested cautiously with a
haunting sense of doubt whether it is
not all a dream
in that doubt lies true modesty not the
sham of insincere self-deprecation
but the modesty of moderation in the
greek sense it is poise not pose
one must ask
if your belief in yourself is not
dependent on actual achievement then
what is it dependent on
the answer too often when we are just
setting out is nothing ego
and this is why we so often see
precipitous rises followed by calamitous
falls
so which type of person will you be
like all of us sherman had to balance
talent and ambition and intensity
especially when he was young his victory
in this struggle was largely why he was
able to manage the life-altering success
that eventually came his way
this probably all sounds strange
where i socrates and shakespeare wished
us to be self-contained
self-motivated and ruled by principle
most of us have been trained to do the
opposite
our cultural values almost tried to make
us dependent on validation entitled and
ruled by our emotions
for a generation parents and teachers
have focused on building up everyone's
self-esteem
from there the themes of our gurus and
public figures have almost exclusively
aimed at inspiring encouraging and
assuring us that we can do whatever we
set our minds to
in reality this makes us weak
yes you with all your talent and promise
as a boy wonder or girl who's going
places
we take it for granted that you have
promise it's why you've landed in the
prestigious university you now attend
why you secured the funding you have for
your business why you've been hired or
promoted why whatever opportunity you
now have has fallen in your lap
as irving berlin put it talent is only
the starting point
the question is will you be able to make
the most of it or will you be your own
worst enemy will you snuff out the flame
that is just getting going
what we see in sherman was a man deeply
tied and connected to reality he was a
man who came from nothing and
accomplished great things without ever
feeling like he was in some way entitled
to the honors he received
in fact he regularly and consistently
deferred to others
and was more than happy to contribute to
a winning team
even if it meant less credit or fame for
himself
it's sad to think that generations of
young boys learned about pickett's
glorious cavalry charge a confederate
charge that failed
but the model of sherman as a quiet
unglamorous realist is forgotten or
worse vilified
one might say that the ability to
evaluate one's own ability is the most
important skill of all
without it improvement is impossible and
certainly ego makes it difficult every
step of the way it is certainly more
pleasurable to focus on our talents and
strengths but where does that get us
arrogance and self-absorption inhibit
growth
so does fantasy and vision
in this phase you must practice seeing
yourself with a little distance
cultivating the ability to get out of
your own head
detachment is a sort of natural ego
antidote it's easy to be emotionally
invested and infatuated with your own
work
any and every narcissist can do that
what is rare is not raw talent skill or
even confidence but humility diligence
and self-awareness
for your work to have truth in it it
must come from truth
if you want to be more than a flash in
the pan you must be prepared to focus on
the long term
we will learn that though we think big
we must act and live small in order to
accomplish what we seek
because we'll be action and education
focused and forego validation and status
our ambition will not be grandiose but
iterative
one foot in front of the other
learning and growing and putting in the
time
with their aggression intensity
self-absorption and endless
self-promotion our competitors don't
realize how they jeopardize their own
efforts to say nothing of their sanity
we will challenge the myth of the
self-assured genius for whom doubt and
introspection is foreign as well as
challenge the myth of the pained
tortured artist who must sacrifice his
health for his work
where they are both divorced from
reality and divorced from other people
we will be deeply connected aware
learning from it all
facts are better than dreams as
churchill put it
although we share with many others a
vision for greatness we understand that
our path towards it is very different
from theirs
following sherman and i socrates we will
understand that ego is our enemy on that
journey
so that when we do achieve our success
it will not sink us but make us stronger
[Music]
talk talk talk
those who know do not speak
those who speak do not know
lao tzu
in his famous 1934 campaign for the
governorship of california
the author and activist upton sinclair
took an unusual step
before the election he published a short
book titled i
governor of california and how i ended
poverty in which he outlined in the past
tense the brilliant policies he had
enacted as governor
the office he had not yet won
it was an untraditional move from an
untraditional campaign
intended to leverage sinclair's best
asset
as an author he knew he could
communicate with the public in a way
that others couldn't
now sinclair's campaign was always a
long shot and hardly in good shape when
they published the book
but observers at the time noticed
immediately the effect it had not on the
voters but on sinclair himself
as carrie mcwilliams later wrote about
his friend's gubernatorial bid as it
went south upton not only realized that
he would be defeated but seems somehow
to have lost interest in the campaign in
that vivid imagination of his he had
already acted out the part of i governor
of california
so why bother to enact it in real life
the book was a best-seller the campaign
of failure
sinclair lost by something like a
quarter of a million votes a margin of
more than 10 percentage points
he was utterly decimated in what was
probably the first modern election
it's clear what happened his talk got
out ahead of his campaign and the will
to bridge the gap collapsed
most politicians don't write books like
that but they get ahead of themselves
just the same it's a temptation that
exists for everyone for talk and hype to
replace action
the empty text box what's on your mind
facebook asks
compose a new tweet twitter beckons
tumblr linkedin our inbox our iphones
the comments section on the bottom of
the article you just read
blank spaces begging to be filled in
with thoughts with photos with stories
with what we are going to do with what
things should or could be like
what we hope will happen
technology asking prodding you
soliciting talk
almost universally the kind of
performance we give on social media is
positive it's more let me tell you how
well things are going look how great i
am it's rarely the truth i'm scared i'm
struggling i don't know
at the beginning of any path we're
excited and nervous
so we seek to comfort ourselves
externally instead of inwardly
there's a weak side to each of us that
like a trade union isn't exactly
malicious but at the end of the day
still wants to get as much public credit
and attention as it can for doing the
least
that side we call ego
the writer and former gawker blogger
emily gould a real-life hannah horvath
if there ever was one
realized this during her two-year
struggle to get a novel published
though she had a six-figure book deal
she was stuck
why
she was too busy spending a lot of time
on the internet that's why
as she said
in fact i can't really remember anything
else i did in 2010 i tumbled i tweeted
and i scrolled this didn't earn me any
money but it felt like work
i justified my habits to myself in
various ways i was building my brand
blogging was a creative act even
curating by reblogging someone else's
post was a creative act if you squinted
it was the only creative thing i was
doing
in other words she did what a lot of us
do when we're scared or overwhelmed by a
project she did everything but focus on
it
the actual novel she was supposed to be
working on stalled completely for a year
it's easier to talk about writing to do
the exciting things related to art and
creativity in literature than to commit
the act itself she's not the only one
someone recently published a book called
working on my novel filled with social
media posts from writers who are clearly
not working on their novels
writing like so many creative acts is
hard
sitting there staring mad at yourself
mad at the material because it doesn't
seem good enough and you don't seem good
enough
in fact many valuable endeavors we
undertake are painfully difficult
whether it's coding a new startup or
mastering a craft but talking talking is
always easy we seem to think that
silence is a sign of weakness that being
ignored is tantamount to death and for
the ego this is true so we talk talk
talk as though our life depends on it
in actuality silence is strength
particularly early on in any journey
as the philosopher and as it happens a
hater of newspapers in their chatter
kierkegaard warned mere gossip
anticipates real talk
and to express what is still in thought
weakens action by forestalling it
and that is what is so insidious about
talk
anyone can talk about him or herself
even a child knows how to gossip or
chatter
most people are decent at hype and sales
so what is scarce and rare silence
the ability to deliberately keep
yourself out of the conversation and
subsist without its validation
silence is the respite of the confident
and the strong
sherman had a good rule he tried to
observe
he said never give reasons for what you
think or do until you must
maybe after a while a better reason will
pop into your head
the baseball and football great beau
jackson decided he had two things he
wanted to accomplish as an athlete at
auburn he would win the heisman trophy
and be taken first in the nfl draft
do you know who he told
nobody but his girlfriend
strategic flexibility is not the only
benefit of silence while others chatter
it is also psychology the poet he see
odd had this in mind when he said a
man's best treasure is a thrifty tongue
talk depletes us
talking and doing fight for the same
resources
research shows that while goal
visualization is important after a
certain point our mind begins to confuse
it with actual progress
the same goes for verbalization
even talking aloud to ourselves while we
work through difficult problems has been
shown to significantly decrease insight
and breakthroughs
after spending so much time thinking
explaining and talking about a task we
start to feel like we've gotten closer
to achieving it or worse when things get
tough we feel like we can toss the whole
project aside because we've given it our
best try although of course we haven't
the more difficult the task the more
uncertain the outcome the more costly
talk will be and the further we run from
actual accountability
it saps us of the energy desperately
needed to conquer what stephen
pressfield calls the resistance
the hurdle that stands between us and
creative expression
success requires a full 100 of our
effort and talk flitters part of that
effort away before we can use it
a lot of us succumb to this temptation
particularly when we feel overwhelmed or
stressed or have a lot of work to do
in our building phase resistance will be
a constant source of discomfort talking
listening to ourselves talk performing
for an audience is almost like therapy i
just spent four hours talking about this
doesn't that count for something
the answer is no
doing great work is a struggle it's
draining it's demoralizing it's
frightening not always but it can feel
that way when we're in the middle of it
we talk to fill the void and the
uncertainty
void marlon brando a quiet actor if
there ever was one once said is
terrifying to most people
it's almost as if we're assaulted by
silence or confronted by it particularly
if we've allowed our ego to lie to us
over the years
which is so damaging for one reason the
greatest work and art comes from
wrestling with the void
facing it instead of scrambling to make
it go away
the question is when faced with a
particular challenge whether it is
researching in a new field starting a
business producing a film securing a
mentor advancing an important cause
do you seek the respite of talk or do
you face the struggle head on
think about it a voice of a generation
doesn't call itself that in fact when
you think about it you realize just how
little these voices seem to talk it's a
song it's a speech it's a book the
volume of work may be light but what's
inside it is concentrated and impactful
they work quietly in the corner they
turn their inner turmoil into product
and eventually to stillness
they ignore the impulse to seek
recognition before they act they don't
talk much or mind the feeling that
others out there in public and enjoying
the limelight are somehow getting the
better end of the deal they are not
they are too busy working to do anything
else and when they do talk it's earned
the only relationship between work and
chatter is that one kills the other
let the others slap each other on the
back while you're back in the lab or the
gym or pounding the pavement
plug that hole
that one right in the middle of your
face that can drain you of your vital
life force watch what happens
watch how much better you get
[Music]
to be
or to do
in this formative period the soul is
unsoiled by warfare with the world
it lies like a block of pure uncut parry
and marble ready to be fashioned into
what
orison sweat martin
one of the most influential strategists
and practitioners in modern warfare is
someone most people have never heard of
his name was john boyd
he was a truly great fighter pilot but
an even better teacher and thinker
after flying in korea he became the lead
instructor at the elite fighter weapons
school at nellis air force base
he was known as 42nd boyd meaning that
he could defeat any opponent from any
position in less than 40 seconds
a few years later he was quietly
summoned to the pentagon where his real
work began
in one sense the fact that the average
person might not have heard of john boyd
is not unexpected he never published any
books and wrote only one academic paper
only a few videos of him survive and he
was rarely if ever quoted in the media
despite nearly 30 years of impeccable
service
boyd wasn't promoted above the rank of
colonel
on the other hand his theories
transformed maneuver warfare in almost
every branch of the armed forces not
just in his own lifetime but even more
so after
the f-15 and f-16 fighter jets which
reinvented modern military aircraft were
his pet projects
his primary influence was as an advisor
through legendary briefings he taught
and instructed nearly every major
military thinker in a generation
his input on war plans for operation
desert shield came in a series of direct
meetings with the secretary of defense
not through public or official policy
input
his primary means of affecting change
was through the collection of pupils who
he mentored protected taught and
inspired
there are no military bases named after
him no battleships he retired assuming
that he'd be forgotten and without much
more than a small apartment and a
pension to his name he almost certainly
had more enemies than friends
this unusual path
what if it were deliberate what if it
made him more influential
how crazy would that be
in fact boyd was simply living out the
exact lesson he tried to teach each
promising young acolyte who came under
his wing
who he sensed had the potential to be
something to be something different
the rising stars he taught probably have
a lot in common with us
the speech boyd gave to a protege in
1973 makes this clear
sensing what he knew to be a critical
inflection point in the life of the
young officer
boyd called him in for a meeting
like many high achievers the soldier was
insecure and impressionable he wanted to
be promoted and he wanted to do well he
was a leaf that could be blown in any
direction and boyd knew it
so he heard a speech that day that boyd
would give again and again until it
became a tradition and a rite of passage
for a generation of transformative
military leaders
what he said was tiger
one day you will come to a fork in the
road
and you're going to have to make a
decision about which direction you want
to go
using his hands to illustrate boyd
marked off these two directions
if you go that way you can be somebody
you will have to make compromises and
you will have to turn your back on your
friends
but you will be a member of the club and
you will get promoted and you will get
good assignments
then boyd paused to make the alternative
clear
or he said you can go that way
and you can do something something for
your country and for your air force and
for yourself
if you decide you want to do something
you may not get promoted and you may not
get the good assignments and you
certainly will not be a favorite of your
superiors
but you won't have to compromise
yourself you will be true to your
friends and to yourself and your work
might make a difference
to be somebody or to do something
in life there is often a roll call
that's when you will have to make a
decision
and then boyd concluded with words that
would guide that young man and many of
his peers for the rest of their lives
to be or to do he said
which way will you go
whatever we seek to do in life reality
soon intrudes on our youthful idealism
this reality comes in many names and
many forms incentives commitments
recognition and politics
in every case they can quickly redirect
us from doing to being from earning to
pretending
ego aids in that deception every step of
the way it's why boyd wanted young
people to see that if we are not careful
we can very easily find ourselves
corrupted by the very occupation we wish
to serve
how do you prevent derailment
well often we fall in love with an image
of what success looks like
in boyd's world the number of stars on
your shoulder or the nature of your
appointment or its location could easily
be confused as a proxy for real
accomplishment
for other people it's their job title
the business school they went to the
number of assistants they have the
location of their parking space the
grants they earn their access to the ceo
the size of their paycheck or the number
of fans that they have
appearances are deceiving though
having authority is not the same as
being an authority
having the right and being right are not
the same either
being promoted doesn't necessarily mean
you're doing good work
and it doesn't mean you are worthy of
promotion they call it failing upward in
such bureaucracies
impressing people is utterly different
from being truly impressive
so who are you with which side will you
choose
this is the roll call that life puts
before us
boyd had another exercise visiting with
or speaking to groups of air force
officers he would write on the
chalkboard in big letters the words duty
honor
and country
then he would cross out those words and
replace them with three others pride
power greed
his point was that many of the systems
and structures in the military the ones
that soldiers navigate in order to get
ahead can corrupt the very values they
set out to serve
there's a quip from the historian will
durant that a nation is born stoic and
dies epicurean
that's the sad truth boyd was
illustrating how positive virtues turn
sour
how many times have we seen this played
out in our own short lives in sports in
relationships or projects or people that
we care deeply about
this is what the ego does it crosses out
what matters and replaces it with what
doesn't
a lot of people want to change the world
and it's good that they do you want to
be the best at what you do nobody wants
to just be an empty suit but in
practical terms
which of the three words boyd wrote on
that chalkboard are going to get you
there
which are you practicing now what's
fueling you
the choice that boyd puts in front of us
comes down to purpose
what is your purpose what are you here
to do
because purpose helps you answer the
question to be or to do quite easily
if what matters is you your reputation
your inclusion your personal ease of
life your path is clear tell people what
they want to hear seek attention over
the quiet but important work say yes to
promotions and generally follow the
track that talented people take in the
industry or field you've chosen pay your
dues check the boxes put in your time
and leave things essentially as they are
chase your fame your salary your title
and enjoy them as they come
a man is worked upon by what he works on
frederick douglass once said
he would know he'd been a slave and he
saw what it did to everyone involved
including the slaveholders themselves
once a free man he saw that the choices
people made about their careers and
their lives had the same effect what you
choose to do with your time and what you
choose to do for money works on you the
egocentric path requires as boy new many
compromises
if your purpose is something larger than
you to accomplish something to prove
something to yourself then suddenly
everything becomes both easier and more
difficult
easier in the sense that you now know
what it is you need to do and what is
important to you
the other choices wash away as they
aren't really choices at all they're
distractions
it's about the doing not the recognition
easier in the sense that you don't need
to compromise
harder because each opportunity no
matter how gratifying or rewarding must
be evaluated along strict guidelines
does this help me do what i have set out
to do does this allow me to do what i
need to do
am i being selfish or selfless
in this course it is not who do i want
to be in life but what is it that i want
to accomplish in life
setting aside selfish interest that asks
what calling does it serve what
principles govern my choices
do i want to be like everyone else or do
i want to do something different
in other words it's harder because
everything can seem like a compromise
although it's never too late the earlier
you ask yourself these questions the
better
boyd undeniably changed and improved his
field in a way that almost no other
theorists in sun tzu or von klauswitz he
was known as genghis john for the way he
never let obstacles or opponents stop
him from what he needed to do his
choices were not without their costs he
was also known as the ghetto colonel
because of his frugal lifestyle
he died with a drawer full of thousands
of dollars and uncashed expense checks
from private contractors which he
equated with bribes
that he never advanced above colonel was
not his doing he was repeatedly held
back for promotions he was forgotten by
history as a punishment for the work he
did
think about this the next time you start
to feel entitled the next time you
conflate fame in the american dream
think about how you might measure up to
a great man like that
think about this the next time you face
that choice do i need this or is it
really about ego
are you ready to make the right decision
or do the prizes still glitter off in
the distance to be or to do
life is a constant roll call
[Music]
become a student
let no man's ghost come back to say my
training let me down
sign in the new york fire department
training academy
in april and the early 1980s a single
day became one guitarist nightmare and
became another's dream and dream job
without notice members of the
underground metal band metallica
assembled before a planned recording
session in a decrepit warehouse in new
york and informed their guitarist dave
mustain he was being thrown out of the
group
with few words they handed him a bus
ticket back to san francisco
that same day a decent young guitarist
kirk hammett barely in his 20s and a
member of a band called exodus was given
the job
thrown right into a new life he
performed his first show with the band a
few days later
one would assume that this was the
moment hamet had been waiting for his
whole life
indeed it was
though only known in small circles at
the time metallica was a band that
seemed destined to go places
their music had already begun to push
the boundaries of the genre of thrash
metal and colt stardom had already begun
within a few short years it would be one
of the biggest bands in the world
eventually selling more than 100 million
albums
it was around this time that kurt came
to what must have been a humbling
realization that despite his years of
playing and being invited to join
metallica he wasn't as good as he'd like
to be
at his home in san francisco he looked
for a guitar teacher in other words
despite joining his dream group and
quite literally turning professional
kirk insisted that he needed more
instruction
that he was still a student
the teacher he sought had a reputation
for being a teacher's teacher and for
working with musical prodigies like
steve vibe
joe satriani the man hammett chose as
his instructor would himself go on to be
known as one of the best guitar players
of all time and sell more than 10
million records of his unique virtuosic
music
teaching outside of a small music shop
in berkeley satriani's playing style
made him an unusual choice for hammett
but that was the point kirk wanted to
learn what he didn't know to firm up his
understanding of the fundamentals so
that he might continue exploring this
new genre of music that he now had a
chance to pursue satriani makes it clear
where hammett was lacking it wasn't
talent certainly
he said the main thing with kirk was he
was a really good guitar player when he
walked in the door he was already
playing lead guitar he was already
shredding he had a great right hand he
knew most of his chords he just didn't
learn how to play an environment where
he learned all the names and how to
connect everything together
that didn't mean that their sessions
were some sort of fun study group in
fact satriani explained that what
separated hamet from the others was his
willingness to endure the type of
instructions that they wouldn't
he said he was a good student many of
his friends and contemporaries would
storm out complaining thinking i was too
harsh of a teacher
satriani's system was clear that there
would be weekly lessons that these
lessons must be learned and if they
weren't that hammett was wasting
everyone's time and didn't bother to
come back
so for the next two years kirk did as
satriani required returning every week
for objective feedback judgment and
drilling and technique and musical
theory for the instrument he would soon
be playing in front of thousands then
tens of thousands than literally
hundreds of thousands of people
even after that two-year study period he
would bring to satriani licks and rifts
he'd been working on with the band and
learned to pare down this instinct for
more and hone his ability to do more
with fewer notes and to focus on feeling
those notes and expressing them
accordingly
each time he improved as a player and as
an artist
the power of being a student is not just
that it is an extended period of
instruction
it also places the ego and ambition in
someone else's hands
there's a sort of ego ceiling imposed
one knows that he is not better than the
master he apprentices under not even
close
you defer to them you subsume yourself
you cannot fake or [ __ ] them and
education can't be hacked there are no
shortcuts besides hacking it every
single day if you don't they drop you
we don't like thinking that someone is
better than us or that we have a lot
left to learn we want to be done
we want to be ready
we are busy and overburdened for this
reason updating your appraisal of your
talents in a downward direction is one
of the most difficult things to do in
life but it is almost always a component
of mastery
the pretense of knowledge is our most
dangerous vice because it prevents us
from getting any better
studious self-assessment is the antidote
the result no matter what your musical
taste happened to be was that hammett
would become one of the great metal
guitarists in the world taking thrash
metal from an underground movement into
a thriving global musical genre
not only that but from those lessons
satriani honed his own technique and
became much better himself both the
student and the teacher would go on to
fill stadiums and remake the musical
landscape
the mixed martial arts pioneer and
multi-title champion frank shamrock has
a system he trains fighters in that he
calls plus minus and equal
each fighter to become great he said
needs to have someone better that they
can learn from someone lesser who they
can teach and someone equal that they
can challenge themselves against
the purpose of shamrock's formula is
simple to get real and continuous
feedback about what they know and what
they don't know from every angle
it purges out the ego that puffs us up
the fear that makes us doubt ourselves
and any laziness that might make us want
to coast
as shamrock observed false ideas about
yourself destroy you
for me i always stay a student that's
what martial arts are about and you have
to use that humility as a tool you put
yourself beneath someone you trust
this begins by accepting that others
know more than you and that you can
benefit from their knowledge and then
seeking them out and knocking down the
illusions you have about yourself
the need for a student mindset doesn't
stop with fighting or music
a scientist must know the core
principles of science and the
discoveries occurring on the cutting
edge
a philosopher must know deeply and also
know how little they know as socrates
did
a writer must be versed in the canon and
read and be challenged by her
contemporaries too
a historian must know ancient and modern
history as well as their specialty
professional athletes have teams of
coaches and even powerful politicians
have advisors and mentors
why
to become great and to stay great they
must all know what came before them what
is going on now and what comes next they
must internalize the fundamentals of
their domain and what surrounds them
without ossifying or becoming stuck in
time they must always be learning
we must all become our own teachers
tutors and critics
think about what hammett could have done
and what we might have done in his
position were we to suddenly find
ourselves a rock star or a soon to be
rock star in our chosen field the
temptation is to think i've made it i've
arrived they've tossed the other guy
because he's not as good as i am they
chose me because i have what it takes
had he done that we'd probably never
have heard of him or the band there are
after all plenty of forgotten metal
groups from the 1980s
a true student is like a sponge
absorbing what goes on around him
filtering it latching on to what he can
hold a student is self-critical and
self-motivated always trying to improve
his understanding so he can move on to
the next topic or the next challenge
a real student is also his own teacher
and his own critic there is no room for
ego there
take fighting as an example again where
self-awareness is particularly crucial
because opponents are constantly looking
to match strength against weakness
if a fighter is not capable of learning
and practicing every day if he is not
relentlessly looking for areas of
improvement examining his own
shortcomings and finding new techniques
to borrow from peers and opponents he
will be broken down and destroyed
it is not all that different for the
rest of us are we not fighting for or
against something do you think that you
are the only one who hopes to achieve
your goal you can't possibly believe
you're the only one reaching for that
brass ring
it tends to surprise people how humble
aspiring great seem to have been what do
you mean they weren't aggressive
entitled aware of their own greatness or
their destiny
the reality is that though they were
confident the act of being an internal
student kept these men and women humble
it is impossible to learn that which one
thinks one already knows epictetus says
you can't learn if you think you already
know
you will not find the answers if you are
too conceited and self-assured to ask
the questions you cannot get better if
you are convinced you are the best
the art of taking feedback is such a
crucial skill in life
particularly harsh and critical feedback
we not only need to take this harsh
feedback but actively solicit it
labor to seek out the negative precisely
when our friends and family and brain
are telling us we're doing great
the ego avoids such feedback at all
costs however who wants to remand
themselves to remedial training
it thinks it already knows how and who
we are
that is it thinks we are spectacular
perfect genius truly innovative it
dislikes reality and prefers its own
assessment
ego doesn't allow for proper incubation
either to become what we ultimately hope
to become often takes long periods of
obscurity
of sitting and wrestling with some topic
or paradox
humility is what keeps us there
concerned that we don't know enough that
we must continue to study
ego rushes to the end
rationalizes that patience is for losers
wrongly seeing it as a weakness and
assumes that we're good enough to give
our talents a go in the world
as we sit down to proof our work as we
make our first elevator pitch prepare to
open our first shop as we stare out into
the dress rehearsal audience ego is the
enemy giving us wicked feedback
disconnected from reality it's defensive
precisely when we cannot afford to be
defensive it blocks us from improving by
telling us that we don't need to improve
then we wonder why we don't get the
results we want why others are better
and why their success is more lasting
today books are cheaper than ever
courses are free access to teachers is
no longer a barrier technology has done
away with that there is no excuse for
not getting your education and because
the information we have before us is so
vast there is no excuse for ever ending
that process either
our teachers in life are not only those
that we pay as hamet paid satriani nor
are they necessarily part of some
training dojo like it is for shamrock
many of the best teachers are free they
volunteer because like you they were
once young and had the same goals as you
many don't even know that they are
teaching they are simply exemplars or
even historical figures whose lessons
survive in books and essays
but ego makes us so hard-headed and
hostile to feedback that it drives them
away or puts them beyond our reach it's
why the old proverb says when the
student is ready the teacher appears
[Music]
don't be passionate
you seem to want that
anime which spurs and excites most young
men to please to shine to excel
without that desire and the pains
necessary to be considerable
depend upon it you never can be so
lord chesterfield
passion it's all about passion
find your passion live passionately
inspire the world with your passion
people go to burning man to find passion
to be around passion to rekindle their
passion
same goes for ted and the now enormous
south by southwest and a thousand other
events retreats and summits
all fueled by what they claim to be
life's most important force
here's what those same people haven't
told you your passion may be the very
thing holding you back from power or
influence or accomplishments because
just as often we fail with no because of
passion
early on in her ascendant political
career a visitor once spoke of eleanor
roosevelt's passionate interest in a
piece of social legislation
the person had meant it as a compliment
but eleanor's response is illustrative
yes she did support the cause she said
but i hardly think the word passionate
applies to me
as a genteel accomplished patient woman
born while the embers of the quiet
victorian virtues were still warm
roosevelt was above passion she had
purpose she had direction she wasn't
driven by passion but by reason
george w bush dick cheney and donald
rumsfeld on the other hand were
passionate about iraq
christopher mccandless was bursting with
passion as he headed into the wild
so was robert falcon scott as he set out
to explore the arctic bitten as he was
with the pole mania as were many
climbers of the tragic 1996 everest
climb momentarily struck with what
psychologists now call goal idiocy
the inventor and the investors of the
segway believe that they had a
world-changing innovation on their hands
and put everything into evangelizing it
that all these talented smart
individuals were fervent believers in
what they sought to do was without
dispute it's also clear that they were
also unprepared and incapable of
grasping the objections and real
concerns of everyone else around them
the same is true for countless
entrepreneurs authors chefs business
owners politicians and designers that
you've never heard of and never will
hear of because they sunk their own
ships before they'd hardly left the
harbor
like every other dilettante they had
passion and lacked something else
to be clear i'm not talking about caring
i'm talking about passion of a different
sort unbridled enthusiasm our
willingness to pounce on what's in front
of us with the full measure of our zeal
the bundle of energy that our teachers
and gurus have assured us is our most
important asset
it is that burning unquenchable desire
to start or to achieve some vague
ambitious and distant goal
this seemingly innocuous motivation is
so far from the right track it hurts
remember zealot is just a nice way to
say crazy person
a young basketball player named louis
alcindor jr who won three national
championships with john wooden at ucla
used one word to describe the style of
his famous coach
dispassionate as in
not passionate
wooden wasn't about rah-rah speeches or
inspiration
he saw those extra emotions as a burden
instead his philosophy was about being
in control and doing her job and never
being quote passion slave
the player who learned that lesson from
wooden would later change his name to
one you remember kareem abdul-jabbar
no one would describe eleanor roosevelt
or john wooden or his notoriously quiet
player kareem as apathetic
they wouldn't have said that they were
frenetic or zealous either
roosevelt one of the most powerful and
influential female activists in history
and certainly america's most important
first lady was known primarily for her
grace her poise and her sense of
direction
wooden won 10 titles in 12 years
including seven in a row because he
developed a system for winning and
worked with his players to follow it
neither of them were driven by
excitement nor were they bodies in
constant motion instead it took them
years to become the person they became
known as it was a process of
accumulation
in our endeavors we will face complex
problems
often in situations we've never faced
before
opportunities are not usually deep
virgin pools that require courage and
boldness to dive into
but instead are obscured and dusted over
blocked by various forms of resistance
what is really called for in these
circumstances is clarity deliberateness
and methodological determination but too
often we proceed like this
a flash of inspiration i want to do the
best and biggest blank ever be the
youngest blank the only one to ever
blank
the firstest with the mostest
the advice okay well here's what you
need to do step by step to accomplish it
the reality we hear what we want to hear
we do what we feel like doing and
despite being incredibly busy and
working very hard we accomplish very
little
or worse find ourselves in a mess we
never anticipated
because we only seem to hear about the
passion of successful people we forget
that failure shared the same trait
we don't conceive of the consequences
until we look at their trajectory with
the segway the inventor and investors
wrongly assumed a demand much greater
than ever existed with the run-up to the
war in iraq its proponents ignored
objections and negative feedback because
they conflicted with what they so deeply
needed to believe
the tragic end to the into the wild
story is the result of youthful naivete
and a lack of preparation with robert
falcon scott it was overconfidence in
zeal without consideration of the
possible dangers
we imagine napoleon was brimming with
passion as he contemplated the invasion
of russia and only finally became free
of it as he limped home with a fraction
of the men he'd so confidently left with
in many more examples we see the same
mistakes over investing under investing
acting before someone is really ready
breaking things that require delicacy
not so much malice as the drunkenness of
passion
passion typically masks a weakness its
breathlessness and impetuousness and
franticness are poor substitutes for
discipline for mastery for strength and
purpose and perseverance
you need to be able to spot this in
others and in yourself because while the
origins of passion may be earnest and
good its effects are comical and then
monstrous
passion is seen in those who can tell
you in great detail who they intend to
become and what their success will be
like they might even be able to tell you
specifically when they intend to achieve
it and describe to you legitimate and
sincere worries they have about the
burdens of such accomplishments
they can tell you all the things they're
going to do or have even begun but they
cannot show you their progress
because there rarely is any
how can someone be busy and not
accomplish something well that's the
passion paradox
if the definition of insanity is trying
the same thing over and over and
expecting different results then passion
is a form of mental retardation
deliberately blunting our most critical
cognitive functions
the waste is often appalling in
retrospect the best years of our life
burned out like a pair of spinning tires
against the asphalt
dogs god bless them are passionate as
numerous squirrels birds boxes blankets
and toys can tell you they do not
accomplish most of what they set out to
do
a dog has an advantage in all this a
graciously short-term memory that keeps
obey the creeping sense of futility and
impotence
reality for us humans on the other hand
has no reason to be sensitive to the
illusions we operate under eventually it
will intrude
what humans require in our ascent is
purpose and realism
purpose you could say is like passion
with boundaries realism is detachment
and perspective
when we are young or when our cause is
young we feel so intensely passion like
our hormones run strongest in youth that
it seems wrong to take it slow
this is just our impatience this is our
inability to see that burning ourselves
out or blowing ourselves up isn't going
to hurry the journey along
passion is about i'm so passionate about
blank
purpose is two and four
i must do blank i was put here to
accomplish blank i'm willing to endure
blank for the sake of this
actually purpose de-emphasizes the i
purpose is about pursuing something
outside yourself as opposed to
pleasuring yourself
more than purpose we also need realism
where do we start where do we go first
what do we do right now how are we sure
that what we are doing is moving us
forward
what are we benchmarking ourselves
against
great passions are maladies without hope
as gertier once said
which is why a deliberate purposeful
person operates on a different level
beyond the sway or the sickness they
hire professionals and use them they ask
questions they ask what could go wrong
they ask for examples they plan for
contingencies
then they are off to the races usually
they get started with small steps
complete them and look for feedback on
how the next set can be better they lock
in gains and then they get better as
they go often leveraging those gains to
grow exponentially rather than
arithmetically
is an iterative approach less exciting
than manifestos epiphanies flying across
the country to surprise someone or
sending 4 000 words stream of
consciousness emails in the middle of
the night of course
is it less glamorous and bold than going
all in and maxing out your credit cards
because you believe in yourself
absolutely
same goes for the spreadsheets the
meetings the trips the phone calls
software tools and internal systems and
every how-to article ever written about
them in the routines of famous people
passion is form over function purpose is
function function function
the critical work that you want to do
will require your deliberation and
consideration
not passion not naivete
it would be far better if you were
intimidated by what lies ahead humbled
by its magnitude and determined to see
it through regardless leave passion for
the amateurs
make it about what you feel you must do
and say
not what you care about and wish to be
remember taliran's epigram for diplomats
sir tu patro desel
above all not too much zeal
then you will do great things
then you will stop being your old good
intentioned but ineffective self
[Music]
follow the canvas strategy
great men have almost always shown
themselves as ready to obey as they
afterwards proved able to command
lord mayon
in the roman system of art and science
there existed a concept for which we
have only a partial analog successful
businessmen politicians or rich playboys
would subsidize a number of writers
thinkers artists and performers
more than just being paid to produce
works of art these artists performed a
number of tasks in exchange for
protection food and gifts
one of the roles was that of an anthem
bulo literally meaning one who clears
the path
and anthem bulo proceeded in front of
his patron anywhere they traveled in
rome
making way communicating messages and
generally making the patrons life easier
the famous epigramist marshall fulfilled
this role for many years serving for a
time under the patron mela a wealthy
businessman and brother of the stoic
philosopher and political advisor seneca
born without a rich family marshall also
served under another businessman named
petulius
as a young writer he spent most of his
day traveling from the home of one rich
patron to another providing services
paying his respects and receiving small
token payments and favors in return
here's the problem like most of us with
our internships and entry-level
positions
or later on publishers or bosses or
clients
marshall absolutely hated every minute
of it he seemed to believe that this
system somehow made him a slave
aspiring to live like some country
squire like the patrons he serviced
marshall wanted money in a state that
was all his own
there he dreamed he could finally
produce his works in peace and
independence
as a result his writing often drags with
a hatred and bitterness about rome's
upper crust from which he believed he
was cruelly shunned to decide
for all his impotent rage what marshall
couldn't see was that it was his unique
position as an outsider to society that
gave him such a fascinating insight into
roman culture that it survives to this
day
instead of being pained by such a system
what if he'd been able to come to terms
with it what if gasp
he could have appreciated the
opportunities it offered
nope it seemed to eat him up inside
instead
it's a common attitude that transcends
generations and societies the angry
underappreciated genius is forced to do
stuff she doesn't like for people she
doesn't respect as she makes her way in
the world
how dare they force me to grovel like
this the injustice the waste
we see it in recent lawsuits in which
interns sue their employers for pay we
see it in kids more willing to live at
home with their parents than submit to
something they're over qualified for
we see it in an inability to meet anyone
else on their terms and unwillingness to
take a step back in order to potentially
take several steps forward
i will not let them get one over on me
i'd rather we both have nothing instead
it's worth taking a look at the supposed
indignities of serving someone else
because in reality not only is the
apprentice model responsible for some of
the greatest art in the history of the
world
everyone from michelangelo to leonardo
da vinci to benjamin franklin has been
forced to navigate such a system
but if you're going to be the big deal
you think you're going to be isn't this
a rather trivial imposition
when someone first gets a job or joins a
new organization he's often given this
advice make other people look good and
you will do well
keep your head down they say and serve
your boss
naturally this is not what the kid who
has chosen over all the other kids for
the position wants to hear
it's not what a harvard grad expects
after all they got that degree precisely
to avoid this supposed indignity
let's flip it around so it doesn't seem
so demeaning it's not about kissing ass
it's not about making someone look good
it's about providing the support so that
others can be good
the better wording for this advice is
then
find canvases for other people to paint
on
be an antembuulo
clear the path for people above you and
you will eventually create a path for
yourself
when you're just starting out we can be
sure of a few fundamental realities
one you're not nearly as good or as
important as you think you are
two you have an attitude that needs to
be readjusted
three most of what you think you know or
most of what you learn in books or in
school is out of date or wrong
there's one fabulous way to work all of
that out of your system
attach yourself to people and
organizations who are already successful
and subsume your identity into theirs
and move both forward simultaneously
it's certainly more glamorous to pursue
your own glory though hardly as
effective
obeisance is the way forward
that's the other side of this attitude
it reduces your ego at a critical time
in your career letting you absorb
everything you can without the
obstructions that block others vision
and progress
no one is endorsing sycophancy instead
it's about seeing what goes on from the
inside and looking for opportunities for
someone other than yourself
remember that anthem bulow means
clearing the path finding the direction
someone already intended to head and
helping them pack
freeing them up to focus on their
strengths
in fact making things better rather than
simply looking as if you are
many people know of benjamin franklin's
famous letters written under names like
silence dogwood what a clever young
prodigy they think and miss the most
impressive part entirely franklin wrote
those letters submitted them by sliding
them under the print shop door and
received absolutely no credit for them
until much later in his life in fact it
was his brother the owner who profited
from their immense popularity regularly
running them on the front page of his
newspaper franklin was playing the long
game though learning how public opinion
worked generating awareness of what he
believed in crafting his style and tone
and wit it's a strategy he used time and
again over in his career once even
publishing in his competitor's paper in
order to undermine a third competitor
for franklin saw the constant benefit in
making other people look good and
letting them take credit for your ideas
bill belichick the four-time super bowl
winning head coach of the new england
patriots made his way up the ranks of
the nfl by loving and mastering the one
part of the job the coaches disliked at
the time
analyzing film his first job in
professional football for the baltimore
colts was one he volunteered to take
without pay and his insights which
provided ammunition and critical
strategies for the game were attributed
exclusively to the more senior coaches
he thrived on what was considered grunt
work asked for it and strove to become
the best at precisely what others
thought they were too good for
he was like a sponge taking it all in
listening to everything one coach said
you gave him an assignment and he
disappeared into a room and you didn't
see him again until it was done and then
he wanted to do more said another
as you can guess belichick started
getting paid very soon
before that as a young high school
player he was so knowledgeable at the
game that he functioned as sort of an
assistant coach even while playing the
game
belichick's father himself an assistant
football coach for navy taught him a
critical lesson in football politics
that if he wanted to give his coach
feedback or question and decision he
needed to do it in private and
self-effacingly so as not to offend his
superior
he learned how to be a rising star
without threatening or alienating anyone
in other words he'd master the canvas
strategy
you can see how easily entitlement and a
sense of superiority the trappings of
ego would have made the accomplishments
of either of these men impossible
franklin never would have been published
if he'd prioritize credit over creative
expression
indeed when his brother found out he
literally beat him out of jealousy and
anger
belichick would have pissed off his
coach and then probably been benched if
he'd one-upped him in public
he certainly wouldn't have taken his
first job for free and he wouldn't have
sat through thousands of hours of film
if he cared about status greatness comes
from humble beginnings it comes from
grunt work
it means that you're the least important
person in the room and to change that
with results
there is an old saying say little do
much
what we really have to do is update and
apply a version of that to our early
approach
be lesser do more
imagine if for every person you met you
thought of some way to help them
something you could do for them
and you looked at it in a way that
entirely benefited them and not you
the cumulative effect this would have
over time would be profound you would
learn a great deal by solving diverse
problems you develop a reputation for
being indispensable you'd have countless
new relationships you'd have an enormous
bank of favors to call upon down the
road
that's what the canvas strategy is about
helping yourself by helping others
making a concerted effort to trade your
short-term gratification for a longer
term payoff
whereas everyone else wants to get
credit and be respected
you could forget credit you can forget
it so hard that you're glad when others
get it instead of you that was your aim
after all
let others take their credit on credit
while you defer and earn interest on the
principle
the strategy part of it is the hardest
it's easy to be bitter like marshall
to hate even the thought of subservience
to despise those who have more means
more experience more status than you
to tell yourself that every second not
spent doing your work or working on
yourself is a waste of your gift to
insist i will not be demeaned like this
once we fight this emotional and
egotistical impulse the canvas strategy
is easy the iterations are endless
maybe it's coming up with ideas to hand
over to your boss
find people thinkers up and comers to
introduce them to each other cross wires
to create new sparks
find what nobody else wants to do and do
it find inefficiency and waste and
redundancies
identify leaks and patches to free up
resources for new areas
produce more than everyone else and give
your ideas away
in other words discover opportunities to
promote their creativity find outlets
and people for collaboration and
eliminate distractions that hinder their
progress and focus
it's a rewarding and infinitely scalable
power strategy consider each one an
investment in relationships and in your
own development
the canvas strategy is there for you at
any time there is no expiration date on
it either it's one of the few that age
does not limit on either side young or
old you can start at any time before you
have a job before you're hired and while
you're doing something else or if you're
starting something new or find yourself
inside an organization without strong
allies or support
you may even find that there's no reason
to ever stop doing it even once you've
graduated to heading your own projects
let it become natural and permanent let
others apply it to you while you're too
busy applying it to those above you
because if you pick up this mantle once
you'll see what most people's egos
prevent them from appreciating the
person who clears the path ultimately
controls its direction
just as the canvas shapes the painting
[Music]
restrain yourself
i have observed that those who have
accomplished the greatest results or
those who keep under the body are those
who never grow excited or lose
self-control but are always calm
self-possessed patient and polite
booker t washington
people who knew jackie robinson as a
young man probably wouldn't have
predicted that they'd one day see him
become the first black player in major
league baseball
not that he wasn't talented or that the
idea of eventually integrating white
baseball was inconceivable
it's that he wasn't exactly known for
his restraint and poise
as a teenager robinson ran with a small
gang of friends who regularly found
themselves in trouble with local police
he challenged a fellow student to a
fight at a junior college picnic for
using a slur in a basketball game he
surreptitiously struck a hard-fouling
white opponent with the ball so
forcefully that the kid bled everywhere
he was arrested more than once for
arguing with and challenging police who
he felt had treated him unfairly
before he started at ucla he spent the
night in jail and had a gun drawn on him
by an officer for nearly fighting a
white man who'd insulted his friends
and in addition to rumors of inciting
protests against racism jackie robinson
effectively ended his career as a
military officer at camp hood in 1944
when a bus driver attempted to force him
to sit in the back in spite of laws that
forbade segregation on base buses
by arguing and cursing at the driver and
then directly challenging his commanding
officer after the fracas
jackie set in motion a series of events
that eventually led to his court-martial
despite being acquitted he was
discharged shortly afterward
it's not just understandable and human
that he did this it was probably the
right thing to do
why should he let anyone else treat him
that way
no one should have to stand for that
except sometimes they do
are there not goals so important that
we'd put up with anything to achieve
them
when branch ricky the manager and owner
of the brooklyn dodgers scouted jackie
to potentially become the first black
player in baseball he had one question
do you have the guts
i'm looking ricky told him for a
ballplayer with the guts not to fight
back
in fact in their famous meeting ricky
play-acted the abuse robinson was likely
to experience if he accepted ricky's
challenge
a hotel clerk refusing him a room a rude
waiter in a restaurant an opponent
shouting slurs
this robinson assured him he was ready
to handle
there were plenty of players rick could
have gone with he needed one who
wouldn't let his ego block him from
seeing the bigger picture
as he started in baseball's farm system
then in the pros robinson faced more
than just slights from service staff or
reticent players
there was an aggressive coordinated
campaign to libel
boo provoke freeze out attack maim or
even kill
in his career he was hit by more than 72
pitches nearly had his achilles tendon
taken out by players who aimed their
spikes at him and that says nothing of
the calls he was cheated out of and the
breaks of the game that didn't go his
way
yet jackie robinson held to this
unwritten pact with ricky never giving
in to explosive anger
however deserved
in fact in nine years in the league he
never hit another player with his fist
athletes seemed spoiled and hot-headed
to us today but we have no concept of
what the leagues were like then
in 1956 ted williams one of the most
revered and respected players in the
history of the game was once caught
spitting at his fans
as a white player he could not only get
away with this he later told reporters
i'm not a bit sorry for what i did i was
right and i'd spit again at the same
people who booed me today
nobody's gonna stop me from spitting
for a black player this behavior would
have been not only unthinkable but
short-sighted beyond comprehension
robinson had no such freedom it would
have ended not only his career but set
back his grand experiment for a
generation
jackie's path called for him to put
aside his ego and in some respects his
basic sense of fairness and rights as a
human being
early in his career the manager of the
philadelphia phillies ben chapman was
particularly brutal in his taunting
during the game
they're waiting for you in the jungles
black boy healed over and over we don't
want you here [ __ ] he said
not only did jackie not respond despite
as he later wrote wanting to grab one of
those white sons of [ __ ] and smash
his teeth in with my despised black fist
a month later he agreed to take a
friendly photo with chapman to help save
the man's job
the thought of touching posing was such
an [ __ ] even 60 years removed almost
turns the stomach
robinson called it one of the most
difficult things he ever did but he was
willing to because it was part of a
larger plan he understood that certain
forces were trying to bait him to ruin
him
knowing what he wanted and needed to do
in baseball it was clear what he would
have to tolerate in order to do it he
shouldn't have had to but he did
our own path whatever we aspire to will
in some ways be defined by the amount of
nonsense we're willing to deal with our
humiliations will pale in comparison to
robinsons but it will still be hard it
will still be tough to keep our
self-control
the fighter boss rootin sometimes writes
the letter r on both his hands before
fights for the word rusta which means
relax in dutch
getting angry getting emotional losing
restraint is a recipe for failure in the
ring you cannot as john steinbeck once
wrote to his editor
lose temper as a refuge from despair
your egos will do you no favors here
whether you're struggling with a
publisher with critics with enemies or
capricious boss
it doesn't matter that they don't
understand or that you know better it's
too early for that it's too soon
oh you went to college that doesn't mean
the world is yours by right but it was
the ivy league well people are still
going to treat you poorly and they'll
still yell at you you have a million
dollars or a wall full of awards that
doesn't mean anything in the new field
you're trying to tackle
it doesn't matter how talented you are
how great your connections are or how
much money you have
when you want to do something something
big and important and meaningful you
will be subjected to treatment ranging
from indifference to outright sabotage
count on it
in this scenario ego is the exact
opposite of what is needed who can
afford to be jerked around by impulses
or believe that you're god's gift to
humanity are too important to put up
with anything you don't like
those who have subdued their ego
understand that it doesn't degrade you
when others treat you poorly it degrades
them
up ahead there will be slights
dismissals little [ __ ] use one-sided
compromises you'll get yelled at you'll
have to work behind the scenes to
salvage what should have been easy
all of this will make you angry
this will make you want to fight back
this will make you want to say i am
better than this i deserve more
of course you'll want to throw it in
other people's faces
worse you'll want to get in other
people's faces people who don't deserve
the respect recognition or rewards they
are getting
in fact these people will often get
perks instead of you
when someone doesn't reckon you with the
seriousness that you'd like the impulse
is to correct them as we all wish to say
do you know who i am
you want to remind them of what they've
forgotten your ego screams for you to
indulge it
instead you must do nothing
take it eat it until you're sick
endure it quietly brush it off and work
harder play the game ignore the noise
for the love of god do not let it
distract you
restraint is a difficult skill but a
critical one you will often be tempted
you will probably even be overcome
no one is perfect with it but try we
must
is a timeless fact of life that the up
and coming must endure the abuses of the
entrenched
robinson was 28 when he started playing
with the dodgers and he'd already paid
plenty of dues in life as both a black
man and a soldier
still he was forced to do it again
it's a sad fact of life that new talents
are regularly missed and even when
recognized often unappreciated
the reasons always vary but it's part of
the journey
but you're not able to change the system
until after you've made it in the
meantime you have to find some way to
make it suit your purposes
even if those purposes are just extra
time to develop properly to learn from
others on their dime to build your base
and establish yourself
as robinson succeeded after he proved
himself as the rookie of the year and as
an mvp and as his spot on the dodgers
was certain he began to more clearly
assert himself and his boundaries as a
player and as a man
having carved out his space he felt that
he could argue with empires he could
throw a shoulder if he needed to make a
player back off or to send a message
no matter how confident or famous
robinson became he never spent on fans
he never did anything that undermined
his legacy
a class act from opening day until the
end jackie robinson was not without
passion
he had a temper and frustrations like
all of us do
but he learned early that the tightrope
he walked would tolerate only restraint
and had no forgiveness for ego
honestly
not many paths do
[Music]
get out of your own head
a person who thinks all the time has
nothing to think about except thoughts
so he loses touch with reality and lives
in a world of illusions
alan watts
it is holden caulfield the self-absorbed
boy walking the streets of manhattan
struggling to adjust to the world
it is a young arturo bandini in los
angeles alienating every person he meets
as he tries to become a famous writer
is the blue blood binks bowling in 1950s
uptown new orleans trying to escape the
everydayness of life
these fictional characters all had
something in common
they couldn't get out of their own heads
and jd salinger's the catcher in the rye
holden can't stay in school is petrified
of growing up and wants desperately to
get away from it all and john fonte's
ask the dust part of a series known as
the bandini quartet this young writer
doesn't experience the life he is living
he sees it all across a page in a
typewriter
wondering if nearly every second of his
life is a poem a play a story a news
article with him as its main character
and walker percy's the moviegoer his
protagonist binks is addicted to
watching movies
preferring an idealized version of life
on the screen to his own uncomfortable
enway
it's always dangerous to psychoanalyze a
writer based on his work but these are
famously autobiographical novels when we
look at the writers lives the facts are
clear jd salinger really did suffer from
a sort of self-obsession and immaturity
that made the world too much for him to
bear
driving him from human contact and
paralyzing his genius
john fonte struggled to reconcile his
enormous ego and insecurity with
relative obscurity for most of his
career eventually abandoning his novels
for the golf course and hollywood bars
only near death blind with diabetes was
he finally able to get serious again
the moviegoer walker percy's first book
came only after he'd conquered his
almost teenage indolence and existential
crisis which lasted alarmingly into his
40s
how much better could these writers have
been had they managed to get through
these troubles earlier
how much easier would their lives have
been
it's an urgent question they pushed on
to their readers with their cautionary
characters
because sadly this trait
the inability to get out of one's head
is not restricted to fiction
2 400 years ago plato spoke of the type
of people who are guilty of feasting on
their own thoughts
it was apparently common enough even
then to find people who instead of
finding out how something they desire
might actually come about
they pass that over so as to avoid
tiring deliberations about what's
possible
they assume that what they desire is
available and proceed to arrange the
rest taking pleasure in thinking through
everything they'll do when they have
what they want
thereby making their lazy souls even
lazier
feel people preferring to live in
passionate fiction than an actual
reality the civil war general george
mcclellan is the perfect example of this
archetype he was chosen to command the
union forces because he checked all of
the boxes of what a great general should
be
west point grad proven in battle a
student of history of regal baron loved
by his men
why did he turn out to be quite possibly
the worst union general even in a
crowded field of incompetent and
self-absorbed leaders
because he could never get out of his
own head he was in love with his vision
of himself as the head of a grand army
he could prepare an army for battle like
a professional
but when it came to lead one into battle
when rubber needed to meet the road
troubles arose
he became laughably convinced that the
enemy was growing larger and larger it
wasn't at one point he actually had a
three times advantage
but he was convinced of constant threats
and intrigues from his political allies
there weren't any
he was convinced that the only way to
win the war was with the perfect plan
and a single decisive campaign he was
wrong he was so convinced of all of it
that he froze and basically did nothing
for months at a time
mcclellan was constantly thinking about
himself and how wonderful he was doing
congratulating himself for victories not
yet won and more often for horrible
defeats he had saved the cause from
when anyone including his superiors
questioned this comforting fiction he
reacted like a petulant delusional
vainglorious and selfish ass
by itself that's insufferable but it
meant another thing his personality made
it almost impossible to do what he
needed to do most
win battles
a historian who fought under mcclellan
and antietam later summed it up his
egotism is simply colossal there is no
other word for it
we tend to think that ego equals
confidence which is what we need to be
in charge
in fact it can have the opposite effect
in mcclellan's case it deprived him of
the ability to lead it robbed him of the
ability to think that he even needed to
act
and repeated opportunities he missed
would have been laughable weren't not
for the thousands and thousands of lives
they cost
the situation was made worse by the fact
that two pious quiet southerners
lee and stonewall jackson with a
penchant for taking the initiative were
able to embarrass him with inferior
numbers and inferior resources which is
what happens when leaders get stuck in
their own head can happen to us too
the novelist anne lamott describes that
eco story well
if you're not careful she warns young
writers
station kfkd
k [ __ ]
will play in your head 24 hours a day
non-stop in stereo
as she put it out of the right speaker
in your inner ear will come an endless
stream of self-aggrandizement
the recitation of one's specialness of
how much more open and gifted and
brilliant and knowing and misunderstood
and humble one is
out of the left speaker will be the rap
songs of self-loathing the lists of all
the things one doesn't do well of all
the mistakes one has made today and over
an entire lifetime the doubt the
assertion that everything one touches
turns to [ __ ]
that one doesn't do relationships well
that one is in every way a fraud and
capable of selfless love that one had no
talent or insight and on and on and on
anyone particularly the ambitious can
fall prey to this narration good and bad
it is natural for any young ambitious
person or simply someone whose ambition
is young to get excited and swept up by
their thoughts and feelings especially
in a world that tells us to keep and
promote a personal brand we're required
to tell stories in order to sell our
work and our talents and after enough
time we forget where the line is that
separates our fictions from reality
ultimately this disability will paralyze
us
or it will become a wall between us and
the information we need to do our jobs
which is largely why mcclellan
continually fell for flawed intelligence
reports he ought to have known were
wrong the idea that his task was
relatively straightforward that he just
needed to get started was almost too
easy and too obvious to someone who had
thought so much about it all
he's not that different from the rest of
us
we are all full of anxieties doubts
impotence pain and sometimes a little
tinge of crazy we're like teenagers in
this regard
as the psychologist david elkind has
famously researched
adolescence is marked by a phenomenon
known as the imaginary audience
consider a 13 year old so embarrassed
that he misses a week of class positive
that the entire school is thinking and
murmuring about some tiny incident that
in truth hardly anyone noticed
or a teenage girl who spends three hours
in front of the mirror each morning as
if she's about to go on stage
they do this because they are convinced
that their every move is being watched
with wrapped attention by the rest of
the world
even as adults were susceptible to this
fantasy during a harmless walk down the
street
we plug in some headphones and all of a
sudden there's a soundtrack we flip up
our jacket collar and consider briefly
how cool we must look
we replay that successful meeting that
we're heading toward in our head
the crowds part as we pass were fearless
warriors on our way to the top
it's the opening credits montage it's a
scene in a novel it feels good so much
better than those feelings of doubt and
fear and normalness
and so we stay stuck inside our own
heads instead of participating in the
world around us
that's ego baby
what successful people do is curb such
flights of fancy they ignore the
temptations that might make them feel
important or skew their perspective
general george c marshall essentially
the opposite of mcclellan even though
they briefly held the same position a
few generations apart
refused to keep a diary during world war
ii despite the requests of historians
and friends
he worried that it would turn his quiet
reflective time into a sort of
performance and self-deception
that he might second-guess difficult
decisions out of concern for his
reputation and future readers and warp
his thinking based on how they would
look
all of us are susceptible to these
obsessions of the mind whether we run a
technology startup or we are working our
way up the ranks of the corporate
hierarchy or fallen madly in love the
more creative we are the easier it is to
lose the thread that guides us
our imagination in many senses an asset
is dangerous when it runs wild
we have to reign our perceptions in
otherwise lost in the excitement how can
we accurately predict the future or
interpret events
how can we stay hungry and aware how can
we appreciate the present moment how can
we be creative within the realm of
practicality
living clearly and presently takes
courage
don't live in the haze of the abstract
live with the tangible and real
even if especially if it's uncomfortable
be part of what's going on around you
feast on it adjust for it
there's no one to perform for
there's just work to be done and lessons
to be learned and all that is around us
[Music]
the danger of early pride
a proud man is always looking down on
things and people and of course as long
as you are looking down you cannot see
something that is above you c s lewis
at 18 a rather triumphant benjamin
franklin returned to visit boston the
city he'd run away from seven months
before
full of pride and self-satisfaction he
had a new suit a watch and a pocketful
of coins that he spread out and showed
to everyone he ran into including his
older brother whom he particularly hoped
to impress
all posturing by a boy who was not much
more than an employee in a print shop in
philadelphia
in meeting with cotton mather one of the
town's most respected figures in a
former adversary franklin quickly
illustrated just how ridiculously
inflated his young ego had become
chatting with mather as they walked down
a hallway mather suddenly admonished him
stoop stoop
too caught up in his performance
franklin walked right into a low ceiling
beam
mather's response was perfect
let this be a caution to you not always
to hold your head so high he said riley
stoop young man stoop as you go through
this world and you will miss many hard
thumps
christians believe that pride is a sin
because it is a lie it convinces people
that they are better than they are that
they are better than god made them
pride leads to arrogance and then away
from humility and connection with their
fellow man
you don't have to be christian to see
the wisdom in this
you need only to care about your career
to understand that pride even in real
accomplishments is a distraction and a
deluder
whom the gods wish to destroy cyril
connolly famously said they first call
promising twenty five hundred years
before that the poet teognus wrote his
friend the first thing chronos which
gods bestow on one they would annihilate
is pride
yet we pick up this mantle on purpose
pride blunts the very instrument we need
to own in order to succeed
our mind
our ability to learn to adapt to be
flexible to build relationships all of
this is told by pride
most dangerously this tends to happen
either early in life or in the process
when we're flushed with beginners
conceit
only later do you realize that a bump on
the head was the least of what was
risked
pride takes a minor accomplishment and
makes it feel like a major one
it smiles at our cleverness and genius
as though what we've exhibited was
merely a hint of what ought to come
from the start it drives a wedge between
the possessor and reality subtly and not
so subtly changing her perceptions of
what something is and what something
isn't
it is these strong opinions only loosely
secured by fact or accomplishment that
send us careening towards delusion or
worse
pride and ego say
i am an entrepreneur because i struck
out on my own i am going to win because
i'm currently in the lead i am a writer
because i publish something
i am rich because i made some money i am
special because i was chosen i am
important because i think i should be
at one time or another we all indulge
this sort of gratifying label-making
yet every culture seems to produce words
of caution against it don't count your
chickens before they hatch don't cook
the sauce before catching the fish the
way to cook a rabbit is to first catch a
rabbit
game slaughtered by words cannot be
skinned punching above your weight is
how you get injured pride goeth before
the fall
let's call that attitude what it is
fraud
if you're doing the work and putting in
the time you won't need to cheat you
won't need to overcompensate
pride is a masterful encroacher
john d rockefeller as a young man
practiced a nightly conversation with
himself
because you have got a start he'd say
aloud or write in his diary you think
you're quite a merchant look out or you
will lose your head go steady
early in his career he'd had some
success
he'd gotten a good job he was saving
money he had a few investments
considering his father had been a
drunken swindler this was no small feat
rockefeller was on the right track
understandably a sort of
self-satisfaction with his
accomplishments and trajectory he was
heading in began to seep in
in a moment of frustration he once
shouted at a bank officer who refused to
lend him money
someday he said i'll be the richest man
in the world
let's count rockefeller as maybe the
only man in the world to say that and
then go on to become the richest man in
the world
but for every one of him there are a
dozen more delusional [ __ ] who said
the exact same thing and genuinely
believed it and then came nowhere close
in part because their pride worked
against them and made other people hate
them too
all this was why rockefeller knew he
needed to reign himself in and to
privately manage his ego
night after night he asked himself
are you going to be a fool are you going
to let this money puff you up however
small it was
keep your eyes open he admonished
himself don't lose your balance
as he later reflected i had a horror of
the danger of arrogance what a pitiful
thing it is when a man lets a little
temporary success spoil him warp his
judgment and he forgets what he is
it creates a sort of myopic onanistic
obsession that warps perspective reality
truth and the world around us
the childlike little prince in saint
xupery's famous story
makes the same observation lamenting
that vain men never hear anything but
praise
that's exactly why we can't afford to
have it as our translator receiving
feedback maintaining hunger and charting
a proper course in life pride dulls
these senses
or in other cases it tunes up other
negative parts of ourselves sensitivity
a persecution complex the ability to
make everything about us
as the famous conqueror and warrior
genghis khan groomed his sons and
generals to succeed him later in life he
repeatedly warned them if you can't
swallow your pride you can't lead he
told them that pride would be harder to
subdue than a wild lion he liked the
analogy of a mountain he would say even
the tallest mountains have animals that
when they stand on it are higher than
the mountain
we tend to be on guard against
negativity against the people who are
discouraging us from pursuing our
callings or doubting the visions we have
for ourselves
this is certainly an obstacle to beware
of though dealing with it is rather
simple what we cultivate less is how to
protect ourselves against the validation
and gratification that will quickly come
our way if we show promise
what we don't protect ourselves against
are people and things that make us feel
good or rather too good we must prepare
for pride and kill it early or it will
kill what we aspire to
we must be on guard against that wild
self-confidence and self-obsession
as flannery o'connor once said the first
product of self-knowledge is humility
this is how we fight the ego
by really knowing ourselves
the question to ask when you feel pride
is this
what am i missing right now that a more
humble person might see
what am i avoiding or running from with
my bluster franticness or embellishments
it is far better to ask and answer these
questions now with the stakes still low
than it will be later
it's worth saying just because you're
quiet doesn't mean that you are without
pride privately thinking that you are
better than others is still pride and
it's still dangerous
that on which you so pride yourself will
be your ruin montane had inscribed on
the beam of his ceiling it's a quote
from the playwright menander and it ends
with
you who think yourself to be someone
we are still striving and it is the
strivers who should be our peers not the
proud and accomplished without this
understanding pride takes our
self-conception and puts it at odds with
the reality of our station which is that
we still have so far to go and that
there is still so much to be done
after hitting his head and hearing from
mather franklin spent a lifetime
battling against his pride because he
wanted to do much and understood that
pride would make it harder which is why
despite what would be dizzying
accomplishments in any era wealth fame
power franklin never had to experience
most of what he called misfortunes
brought upon by people by carrying their
heads too high
at the end it isn't about deferring your
pride because you don't deserve it yet
it isn't don't boast about what hasn't
happened yet it's more directly don't
boast there's nothing in it for you
[Music]
work work work
the best plan is only good intentions
unless it degenerates into work
peter drucker
the painter edward degas though best
known for his beautiful impressionistic
paintings of dancers toyed briefly with
poetry as a brilliant and creative mind
the potential for great poems was all
there he could see beauty he could find
inspiration yet there are no great degap
poems there is one famous conversation
that might explain why
the poet stefan mahlerme about his
trouble writing
i can't manage to say what i want and
yet i'm full of ideas he said
mahler may's response cuts to the bone
it's not with ideas my dear daga that
one makes verse it's with words
or rather with work
the distinction between a professional
and a dilettante occurs right there
when you accept that having an idea is
not enough that you must work until you
are able to recreate your experience
effectively in words on the page
as the philosopher and writer paul
valerie explained in 1938
a poet's function is not to experience
the poetic state
that is a private affair
his function is to create it in others
that is his job is to produce work
to be both a craftsman and an artist to
cultivate a product of labor in industry
instead of just a product of the mind
it is here where abstraction meets the
road and the real where we trade
thinking and talking for working
you can't build a reputation on what
you're going to do with how henry ford
put it
the sculptor nina holton hit the same
note in a landmark study on creativity
that germ of an idea she said does not
make a sculpture which stands up it just
sits there so the next stage of course
is the hard work
the investor and serial entrepreneur ben
horowitz put it more bluntly
he said the hard thing isn't setting a
big hairy audacious goal the hard thing
is laying people off when you miss the
big goal
the hard thing isn't dreaming big the
hard thing is waking up in the middle of
the night in a cold sweat when the dream
turns into a nightmare
sure you get it you know that all things
require work and that that work might be
quite difficult
but do you really understand do you have
any idea just how much work there is
going to be not work until you get your
big break not work until you make a name
for yourself but work work work forever
and ever
is it ten thousand hours or twenty
thousand hours to mastery the answer is
that it doesn't matter there is no end
zone to think of a number is to live in
a conditional future
we're simply talking about a lot of
hours
that to get where we want to go isn't
about brilliance but continual effort
while that's not a terribly sexy idea it
should be an encouraging one because it
means that it's all within reach for all
of us provided that we have the
constitution and the humbleness to be
patient and the fortitude to put in the
work
by this point you probably understand
why the ego would bristle at this idea
within reach it complains that means
you're saying i don't have it now
exactly right you don't no one does
our ego wants the ideas and the fact
that we aspire to do something about
them to be enough once the hours we
spend planning and attending conferences
or chatting with impressed friends to
count towards the tally that success
seems to require it wants to be paid
well for its time it wants to do the fun
stuff the stuff that gets attention
credit or glory
that's the reality where we decide to
put our energy decides what we'll
ultimately accomplish as a young man
bill clinton began a collection of note
cards upon which he would write names
and phone numbers of friends and
acquaintances who might be of service
when he eventually entered politics
each night before he ever had a reason
to he would flip through the box make
phone calls write letters or add
notations about their interactions
over the years this collection grew to
ten thousand cards before it was
eventually digitized
it's what put him in the oval office and
continues to return dividends
or think of darwin working for decades
on his theory of evolution refraining
from publishing it because it wasn't yet
perfect hardly anyone knew what he was
working on
no one said hey charles it's okay that
you're taking so long because what
you're working on is just so important
they didn't know he couldn't have known
he just knew that it wasn't done yet and
that it could be better and that that
was enough to keep him going
so do we sit down alone and struggle
with our work
work that may or may not go anywhere
that may be discouraging or painful
do we love work
making a living to do work not the other
way around
do we love practice the way great
athletes do
or do we chase short-term attention and
validation whether that's indulging in
the endless search for ideas or simply
the distraction of talk and chatter
fock see focus do it if you're going to
do it
there's another apt latin expression
motrium superbot opus
the workmanship was better than the
material the material we've been given
genetically emotionally and financially
that's where we begin we don't control
that we do control what we make of that
material and whether we squander it
as a young basketball player bill
bradley would remind himself when you
are not practicing remember someone
somewhere is practicing and when you
meet him he will win
the bible says something similar in its
own way
blessed are those servants whom the
master finds awake when he comes
you can lie to yourself saying that you
put in the time or pretend that you're
working but eventually someone will show
up you will be tested and quite possibly
found out
since bradley went on to be an
all-american a rhodes scholar then a
two-time champion with the new york
knicks and a u.s senator you get the
sense that this sort of dedication will
take you places
so we must have it because there is no
triumph without toil
wouldn't it be great if work was as
simple as opening a vein and letting the
genius pour out or if you could walk
into that meeting and spit brilliance
off the top of your head you could walk
up to the canvas hurl your paint at it
and modern art emerges right
that's the fantasy rather that is the
lie
back to another popular old trope
fake it till you make it it's no
surprise that such an idea has found
increasing relevance in our noxiously
[ __ ] nerf world
when it is difficult to tell a real
producer from an adept self-promoter of
course some people will roll the dice
and manage to play the confidence game
make it so you don't have to fake it
that's the key
can you imagine a doctor trying to get
by with anything less or a quarterback
or a bull rider more to the point would
you want them to
so why would you try it otherwise
every time you sit down to work remind
yourself i am delaying gratification by
doing this i am passing the marshmallow
test
i am earning what my ambition burns for
i am making an investment in myself
instead of in my ego give yourself a
little credit for this choice but not so
much because you've got to get back to
the task at hand
practicing working improving
work is finding ourselves alone at the
track when the weather kept everyone
else indoors
work is pushing through the pain in the
crappy first drafts and prototypes
it is ignoring whatever plaudits others
are getting and more importantly
ignoring whatever plaudits you may be
getting
because there is work to be done
work doesn't want to be good it is made
so despite the headwind there is another
old expression you know a work been by
the chips they leave it's true to judge
your progress properly just take a look
at the
[Music]
floor for everything that comes next ego
is the enemy
tis a common proof that lowliness is
young ambition's ladder shakespeare
we know where we want to end up success
we want to matter
wealth and recognition and reputation
are nice too we want it all
the problem is we're not sure that
humility can get us there we are
petrified as the reverend dr sam wells
put it that if we are humble we will end
up subjugated trodden on embarrassed and
irrelevant
midway through his career if you'd asked
our model sherman how he felt he
probably would have described himself in
almost exactly those terms
he had not made much money he had won no
great battles he had not seen his name
in lights or headlines
he might have at that moment before the
civil war
begun to question the path he'd chosen
and whether those who follow it finished
last
this is the kind of thinking that
creates the falsity and bargain that
turns most clean ambition into shameless
addiction
in the early stages ego can be
temporarily adaptive craziness can pass
for audaciousness delusions can pass for
confidence
ignorance for courage
but it's just kicking the cost down the
road
because no one ever said reflecting on
the whole of someone's life
man that monstrous ego sure was worth it
the internal debate about confidence
calls to mind a well-known concept from
the radio pioneer ira glass which could
be called the taste talent gap
he said quote all of us who do creative
work we get into it because we have good
taste
but it's like there's a gap that for the
first couple years you're making stuff
what you're making isn't so good it's
really not that great it's trying to be
good it has ambition to be good but it's
not quite that good but your taste the
thing that got you into the game your
taste is still killer and your taste is
good enough that you can tell that what
you're making is kind of a
disappointment to you
it is in precisely this gap that ego can
seem comforting who wants to look at
themselves and their work and find that
it does not measure up
and so here we might bluster our way
through
cover up hard truths with sheer force of
personality and drive and passion
or we can face our shortcomings honestly
and put the time in
we can let this humble us see clearly
where we are talented and where we need
to improve and then put in the work to
bridge that gap
and we can set upon positive habits that
will last a lifetime
if ego was tempting in sherman's time in
this era we are like lance armstrong
training for the 1999 tour de france we
are barry bonds debating whether to walk
into the balco clinic we flirt with
arrogance and deceit and in the process
grossly overstate the importance of
winning at all cost
everyone is juicing the ego says to us
you should too
there's no way to beat them without it
we think
of course what is truly ambitious is to
face life and proceed with quiet
confidence in spite of the distractions
let others grasp at crutches it will be
a lonely fight to be real to say i'm not
going to take the edge off to say i'm
going to be myself the best version of
that self i am in this for the long game
no matter how brutal it might be to do
not be
for sherman it was precisely his choice
that prepared him for the time his
country and history most needed him and
allowed him to navigate the massive
responsibilities that shortly came his
way
in this quiet crucible he'd forged a
personality that was ambitious but
patient
innovative without being brash
brave without being dangerous he was a
real leader
you have a chance to do this yourself to
play a different game to be utterly
audacious in your aims
because what comes next is going to test
you in ways that you cannot begin to
understand
for ego is a wicked sister of success
and you're about to experience what that
means
[Music]
part two
success
here we are at the top of the mountain
we worked hard to climb
or at least the summit is in sight
we now face new temptations and problems
we breathe thinner air in an unforgiving
environment
why is success so ephemeral ego shortens
it whether a collapse is dramatic or a
slow erosion it's always possible and
often unnecessary we stop learning we
stop listening we lose our grasp on what
matters
we become victims of ourselves in the
competition
sobriety open-mindedness organization
and purpose these are the great
stabilizers they balance out the ego and
pride that comes with achievement and
recognition
to whatever success you have achieved
ego is the enemy
two different characters are presented
to our emulation the one of proud
ambition and ostentatious avidity the
other of humble modesty and equitable
justice
two different models two different
pictures are held out to us according to
which we may fashion our own character
and behavior
the one more gaudy and glittering in its
coloring
the other more correct and more
exquisitely beautiful in its outline
adam smith
at a business meeting in january 1924
howard hughes senior a successful
inventor and tool magmate
stood up convulsed and died from a
sudden heart attack at the age of 54.
his son a quiet reserved and sheltered
boy of just 18
inherited three-fourths of the private
company which held patents and leases
critical to oil drilling worth nearly 1
million dollars
various family members were bequeathed
the remaining shares
in a move of almost incomprehensible
foresight the young hughes who many saw
as a spoiled little boy made the
decision to buy out his relatives and
control the entire company himself
against their objections and still
legally considered a minor hughes
leveraged his personal assets in nearly
all the company's funds to purchase the
stock and in doing so consolidated
ownership of a business that would
create billions of dollars of cash
profit over the next century
it was a bold move for a young man with
essentially zero experience in business
and it was with similar boldness that
over his career he would create one of
the most embarrassing wasteful and
dishonest business track records in
history
in retrospect his years at the helm of
the hughes empire resemble a deranged
crime spree more than a capitalistic
enterprise
one cannot argue whether hughes was
gifted visionary or brilliant he just
was
literally a mechanical genius he was
also one of the best and bravest pilots
in the pioneer days of aviation
and as a businessman and a filmmaker he
had the ability to predict wide sweeping
changes that came to transform not just
the industries he was involved in but in
america itself
yet after filtering out his acumen from
the legend glamour and self-promotion at
which he was so adept only one image
remains an egomaniac who evaporated
hundreds of millions of dollars of his
own wealth and met a miserable pathetic
end
not by accident not because he was beset
by unforeseen circumstances or
competition but almost exclusively due
to his own actions
a quick rundown of his feats if you can
call them that provides a stark
perspective
after purchasing control of his father's
tool company from his family hughes
abandoned it almost immediately except
to repeatedly siphon off its cash
he left houston and never stepped foot
in the company's headquarters again
he moved to los angeles where he decided
to become a film producer and celebrity
trading stocks from his bedside he lost
more than eight million dollars in the
market leading up to the depression
his most well-known movie hell's angels
took three years to make lost 1.5
million dollars on a budget of 4.2
million dollars and nearly bankrupted
the tool company in the process
then not having learned a lesson the
first time hughes lost another four
million dollars on chrysler stock in the
early 1930s
he then put all this aside to enter the
aviation business creating a defense
contractor called the hughes aircraft
company
despite some astounding personal
achievements as an inventor hughes
company was a total failure
his two contracts during world war ii
worth over 40 million dollars were
massive failures at the expense of the
american taxpayer and himself
the most notable the spruce goose which
hughes called the hercules and which was
one of the biggest planes ever made took
more than five years to develop cost
roughly 20 million dollars and flew just
a single time for barely a mile only 70
feet above the water
at his insistence and expense it then
sat in an air-conditioned hangar in long
beach for decades at the cost of one
million dollars a year
deciding to double down on the film
business hughes purchased the movie
studio rko and produced losses of over
22 million dollars and went from 2 000
employees to fewer than 500 as he ran it
into the ground over the next several
years tiring of these businesses as he
had of the tool company he forsook
defense contracting and handed it off to
executives to run where it slowly began
to thrive because of his absence
it would make sense to stop here to
avoid belaboring the issue but that
would risk skipping hughes's egregious
tax fraud the plane crashes and fatal
car accidents the millions he wasted on
private investigators lawyers contracts
for starlets he refused to let act
property he never lived in
the fact that the only thing that ever
got him to behave responsibly was the
threat of public exposure to paranoia
racism and bullying the failed marriages
the drug addiction and dozens of other
ventures and businesses that he
mismanaged
that we have made a hero out of howard
hughes a young joan didion wrote tells
us something interesting about ourselves
she's absolutely right for howard hughes
despite his reputation was quite
possibly one of the worst businessmen of
the 20th century
usually a bad businessman fails and
ceases to be in business anymore making
it hard to see what truly caused his
failures
but thanks the steady chain of profits
from his father's company which he found
too boring to interfere with hughes was
able to stay afloat allowing us to see
the damage that his ego repeatedly
wrought to himself as a person to the
people around him to what he wanted to
accomplish
there's a scene from howard's slow
descent into madness that bears
illustrating
his biographers have him sitting naked
in his favorite white chair
unwashed unkempt working around the
clock to battle lawyers investigations
investors in an attempt to save his
empire and hide his shameful secrets
one minute he would dictate some
irrational multi-page memo about kleenex
food preparation
or how employees should not speak to him
directly and then he would turn around
and seize upon a genuinely brilliant
strategy to outrun his creditors and
enemies it was as if they observed his
mind and his business were split in two
parts
it was as if they wrote ibm had
deliberately established a pair of
subsidiaries one to produce computers
and profits the other to manufacture
edsels and losses
if someone was looking for a flesh and
blood metaphor for ego and destruction
it would be hard to do better than this
image of a man working furiously with
one hand toward a goal and with the
other working equally hard to undermine
it
howard hughes like all of us was not
completely crazy or completely sane
his ego fueled and exacerbated by
physical injuries mostly from plane and
car crashes for which he was at fault
and various addictions led him into a
darkness that we can scarcely comprehend
there were brief moments of lucidity
when the sharp mind of hughes broke
through
times when he made some of his best
moves but as he progressed through life
these moments became increasingly rare
eventually ego killed howard hughes as
much as the mania and trauma did if they
were ever separate to begin with
you can only see this if you want to see
it it's more attractive and exciting to
see the rebel billionaire the eccentric
the world renown and the fame and think
oh how i want that you do not howard
hughes like so many wealthy people died
in an asylum of his own making he felt
little joy he enjoyed almost nothing of
what he had most importantly he wasted
he wasted so much talent so much bravery
and so much energy
without virtue and training aristotle
observed it is hard to bear the results
of good fortune suitably we can learn
from hughes because he was so publicly
and visibly unable to bear his
birthright properly his endless taste
for the spotlight no matter how
unflattering gives us an opportunity to
see our own tendencies our own struggles
with success and luck refracted back
through his tumultuous life
his enormous ego and its destructive
path through hollywood through the
defense industry through wall street
through the aviation industry gives us a
look inside someone who is repeatedly
failed by the impulses we all have
of course he's far from the only person
in history to follow such an arc will
you follow his trajectory
sometimes ego is suppressed on the
ascent sometimes an idea is so powerful
or timing is so perfect or one is born
into wealth or power that it can
temporarily support or even compensate
for a massive ego
as success arrives like it does for a
team that has just won a championship
ego begins to toy with our minds and
weaken the will that made us win in the
first place
we know that empires always fall so we
must think about why and why they always
seem to collapse from within
harold genon was the ceo who more or
less invented the concept of the modern
international conglomerate through a
series of acquisitions mergers and
takeovers more than 350 in all he took a
small company called itt from one
million dollars in revenue in 1959 to
nearly 17 billion
in 1977 the year he retired
some claimed that gina himself was an
egotist
in any case he spoke candidly about the
effects that ego had in his industry and
warned executives against it
the worst disease which can afflict
business executives in their work is not
as popularly supposed alcoholism it's
egotism
jeanine famously said
in the mad men era of corporate america
there was a major drinking problem but
ego has the same roots insecurity fear a
dislike for brutal objectivity
as he said whether in middle management
or top management unbridled personal
egotism blinds a man to the realities
around him
more and more he comes to live in a
world of his own imagination
and because he sincerely believes he can
do no wrong he becomes a menace to the
men and women who have to work under his
direction
here we have accomplished something
after we give ourselves proper credit
ego wants us to think i'm special i'm
better the rules don't apply to me
man is pushed by drives viktor frankl
observed but he is pulled by values
ruled by or ruling which are you
without the right values success is
brief if we wish to do more than flash
if we wish to last then it is time to
understand how to battle this new form
of ego and what values and principles
are required in order to beat it
success is intoxicating yet to sustain
it requires sobriety
we cannot keep learning if we think we
already know everything
we cannot buy into myths we make
ourselves or the noise or chatter of the
outside world we must understand that we
are a small part of an interconnected
universe
on top of all this we have to build an
organization and a system around what we
do one that is about the work and not
about us
the verdict on hughes is in
ego wrecked him
a similar judgment awaits us all at some
point
over the course of your own career you
will face the choices that he did that
all people do
whether you built your empire from
nothing or inherited it whether your
wealth is financial or merely a
cultivated talent
entropy is seeking to destroy it as you
listen to this
can you handle success or will it be the
worst thing that ever happened to you
[Music]
always stay a student
every man i meet is my master in some
point and in that i learn of him ralph
waldo emerson
the legend of genghis khan has echoed
through history a barbarian conqueror
fueled by bloodlust terrorizing the
civilized world
we have him and his mongol horde
traveling across asia and europe
insatiable stopping at nothing to
plunder rape and kill not just the
people who stood in their way but the
cultures they had built
then not unlike his nomadic band of
warriors this terrible cloud simply
disappeared from history because the
mongols built nothing that could last
like all reactionary emotional
assessments this could not be more wrong
for not only was genghis khan one of the
greatest military minds who ever lived
he was a perpetual student whose
stunning victories were often the result
of his ability to absorb the best
technologies practices and innovations
from each new culture his empire touched
in fact if there is one theme in his
reign and in the several centuries of
dynastic rule that followed it's this
appropriation
under genghis khan's direction the
mongols were as ruthless about stealing
and absorbing the best of each culture
they encountered as they were about the
conquest itself
though there were essentially no
technological inventions no beautiful
buildings or even great mongol art with
each battle and enemy their culture
learned and absorbed something new
genghis khan was not born a genius
instead as one biographer put it his was
a persistent cycle of pragmatic learning
experimental adaptation and constant
revision driven by his uniquely
disciplined and focused will
he was the greatest conqueror of the
world ever knew because he was more open
to learning than any other conqueror has
ever been
khan's first powerful victories came
from the reorganization of his military
units
splitting his soldiers into groups of
ten this he stole from the neighboring
turkic tribes and unknowingly converted
the mongols to the decimal system
soon enough their expanding empire
brought them into contact with another
technology that they'd never experienced
before
walled cities
in the tanget raids khan first learned
the ins and outs of war against
fortified cities and the strategies
critical to laying siege and quickly
became an expert
later with help from chinese engineers
he taught his soldiers how to build
siege machines that could knock down
city walls
in his campaigns against the jerkid
khan learned the importance of winning
the hearts and minds
by working with the scholars and royal
family of the lands he conquered khan
was able to hold on and manage these
territories in ways that most empires
could not
afterwards in every country or city he
held khan would call for the smartest
astrologers scribes doctors thinkers and
advisors
anyone who could aid his troops and
their efforts
his troops traveled with interrogators
and translators for precisely this
purpose
it was a habit that would survive his
death while the mongols seemed dedicated
almost solely to the art of war they put
to good use every craftsman merchant
scholar entertainer cook and skilled
worker they came in contact with
the mongol empire was remarkable for its
religious freedoms and most of all for
its love of ideas and convergence of
cultures
it brought lemons to china for the first
time and chinese noodles to the west it
spread persian carpets german mining
technology french metalworking and islam
the canon which revolutionized warfare
was said to be the resulting fusion of
chinese gunpowder
muslim flamethrowers and european metal
work it was mongol openness to learning
and new ideas that brought them together
as we first succeed we will find
ourselves in new situations facing new
problems
the freshly promoted soldier must learn
the art of politics the salesman how to
manage the founder how to delegate the
writer how to edit others the comedian
how to act the chef turned restaurateur
how to run the other side of the house
this is not a harmless conceit
the physicist john wheeler who helped
develop the hydrogen bomb once observed
that as our island of knowledge grows so
does the shore of our ignorance
in other words each victory and
advancement that made khan smarter also
bumped him against new situations he'd
never encountered before
it takes a special kind of humility to
grasp that you know less even as you
know and grasp more and more
it's worth remembering socrates wisdom
lay in the fact that he knew that he
knew next to nothing
with accomplishment comes a growing
pressure to pretend that we know more
than we do
to pretend we already know everything
knowledge puffs up
that's the worry and the risk thinking
that we're set and secure when in
reality understanding and mastery is a
fluid continual process
the nine-time grammy and pulitzer
prize-winning jazz musician wynton
marsalis once advised a promising young
musician on the mindset required in the
lifelong study of music he said
humility engenders learning because it
beats back the arrogance that puts
blinders on
it leaves you open for truths to reveal
themselves you don't stand in your own
way
do you know how you can tell when
someone is truly humble
i believe there's one simple test
because they consistently observe and
listen the humble improve they don't
assume i know the way
no matter what you've done up to this
point you better still be a student
if you're not still learning you're
already dying
it's not enough only to be a student at
the beginning it's a position that one
has to assume for life
learn from everyone and everything
from the people you beat from the people
who beat you from the people who you
dislike
even from your supposed enemies at every
step in every juncture in life there is
the opportunity to learn and even if the
lesson is purely remedial we must not
let ego block us from hearing it again
too often convinced of our own
intelligence we stay in a comfort zone
that ensures that we will never feel
stupid and are never challenged to learn
or reconsider what we know
it obscures from view various weaknesses
in our understanding until eventually
it's too late to change course
this is where the silent toll is taken
each of us faces a threat as we pursue
our craft like sirens on the rocks ego
sings a soothing validating song which
can lead to a wreck the second we let
the ego tell us we've graduated learning
grinds to a halt that's why frank
shamrock said always stay a student as
in it never ends
the solution is as straightforward as it
is initially uncomfortable pick up a
book on a topic you know next to nothing
about put yourself in rooms where you're
the least knowledgeable person that
uncomfortable feeling that defensiveness
you feel when your most deeply held
assumptions are challenged what about
subjecting yourself to it deliberately
change your mind change your
surroundings
an amateur is defensive the professional
finds learning and even occasionally
being shown up to be enjoyable they like
being challenged and humble and engage
in education as an ongoing and endless
process
most military cultures people in general
seek to impose values and control over
what they encounter
what made the mongols different was
their ability to weigh each situation
objectively and if need be swap out a
previous practice for a new one
all great businesses start this way and
then something happens take the theory
of disruption which posits that at some
point in time every industry will be
disrupted by some trend or innovation
that despite all the resources in the
world the incumbent interests will be
incapable of responding to
why is this why can't businesses change
and adapt
a large part of it is because they've
lost the ability to learn they stopped
being students the second this happens
to you your knowledge becomes fragile
the great manager and business thinker
peter drucker says that it's not enough
simply to want to learn as people
progress they must also understand how
they learn and then set up processes to
facilitate this continual education
otherwise we are dooming ourselves to a
sort of self-imposed ignorance
[Music]
don't tell yourself a story
myth becomes myth not in the living but
in the retelling
david marinus
starting in 1979 football coach and
general manager bill walsh took the
49ers from being the worst team in
football and perhaps all of professional
sports to a super bowl victory in just
three years
it would have been tempting as he
hoisted the lombardi trophy over his
head to tell himself that the quickest
turnaround in nfl history had been his
plan all along
it would have been tempting decades
later when he assembled his memoirs to
assume that narrative as well
it's a sexy story that his takeover his
turnaround and the transformation were
assidiously scheduled
that it all happened exactly as he
wanted
because he was just that good and that
talented
no one would have faulted him if he said
that
yet he refused to indulge in those
fantasies
when people asked walsh whether he had a
timetable for winning the super bowl do
you know what his answer was
the answer was always no
because when you take over a team that
bad such ambitions would have been
utterly delusional
the year before he arrived the 49ers
were 2 and 14.
the organization was demoralized broken
without draft picks and fully ensconced
in a culture of losing
his first season they lost another 14
games he nearly resigned midway through
his second year because he wasn't sure
he could do it
yet 24 months from taking over and a
little over a year from having almost
quit there he was the super bowl
champion genius
how did it happen how is that not part
of the plan
the answer is that when bill walsh took
control he wasn't focused on winning per
se
instead he implemented what he called
his standard of performance
that is
what should be done when
how
at the most basic level and throughout
the organization walsh had only one
timetable and it was all about
instilling these standards
he focused on seemingly trivial details
players could not sit down on the
practice field coaches had to wear a tie
and tuck their shirts in
everyone had to give maximum effort and
commitment
sportsmanship was essential the locker
room must be neat and clean there would
be no smoking no fighting no profanity
quarterbacks were told where and how to
hold the ball linemen were drilled on 30
separate critical drills
passing routes were monitored and graded
down to the inch
practices were scheduled to the minute
it would be a mistake to think this was
about control the standard of
performance was about instilling
excellence
these seemingly simple but exacting
standards mattered more than some grand
vision or power trip
in his eyes if the players take care of
the details the score takes care of
itself the winning would happen
walsh was strong and confident enough to
know that these standards would
eventually contribute to victory he was
also humble enough to know that when
that victory would happen was not
something he could predict
that it happened faster than for any
coach in history
well that was a fortuitous break in the
game it was not because of his grand
vision in fact in his second season a
coach complained to the owner that walsh
was too caught up in minutia and had no
goals to win
walsh fired that coach for tattling
we want so desperately to believe that
those who have great empires set out to
build one why so we can indulge in the
pleasurable planning of ours
so we can take full credit for the good
that happens and the riches and respect
that come our way
narrative is when you look back at an
improbable or unlikely path to your
success and say
i knew it all along instead of i hoped i
worked i got some good breaks or even i
thought this could happen
of course you didn't really know it all
along or if you did it was more faith
than knowledge but who wants to remember
all the times you doubted yourself
crafting stories out of past events is a
very human impulse it's also dangerous
and untrue
writing our own narrative leads to
arrogance it turns our life into a story
and turns us into caricatures while we
still have to live it
as the author tobias wolfe writes in his
novel old school these explanations and
stories get cobbled together later more
or less sincerely and after the stories
have been repeated they put on the badge
of memory and block all other routes of
exploration
bill walsh understood that it was really
the standard of performance the
deceptively small things that was
responsible for the team's
transformation and victory but that's
too boring for newspaper headlines
that's why he ignored it when they
called him the genius
to accept the title in the story
wouldn't have been a harmless personal
gratification
these narratives don't change the past
but they do have the power to negatively
impact our future
his players shortly proved the risks
inherent in letting the story go to
their heads like most of us they wanted
to believe that their unlikely victory
occurred because they were special
in the two seasons after the first super
bowl the team failed terribly partly due
to the dangerous confidence that
accompanies these kinds of victories
losing 12 of the next 22 games
this is what happens when you
prematurely credit yourself with powers
you don't yet have control of
this is what happens when you start to
think about what your rapid achievements
say about you
and begin to slack in the effort and
standards that initially fueled them
only when the team returned
wholeheartedly to the standard of
performance did they win again three
more super bowls and nine conference or
division championships in a decade
only when they stopped with the stories
and focused on the task at hand did they
begin to win like they had before
here's the other part once you win
everyone is gunning for you it's during
your moment at the top that you can
afford eco the least because the stakes
are so much higher the margins for error
are so much smaller
if anything your ability to listen to
hear feedback to improve and grow matter
more now than ever before
facts are better than stories and image
the 20th century financier bernard
baruch had a great line
don't try to buy at the bottom and sell
at the top this can't be done except by
liars
that is people's claims about what
they're doing in the market are rarely
to be trusted
jeff bezos founder of amazon has talked
about this temptation he reminds himself
that there was no aha moment for his
billion dollar behemoth no matter what
he might read in his own press clippings
the founding of a company making money
in the market or the formation of an
idea is messy reducing it to a narrative
retroactively creates a clarity that
never was and never will be there
when we are aspiring we must resist the
impulse to reverse engineer success from
other people's stories when we achieve
our own we must resist the desire to
pretend that everything unfolded exactly
as we planned
there was no grand narrative you should
remember you were there when it happened
a few years ago one of the founders of
google gave a talk in which he said the
way he judges prospective companies and
entrepreneurs is by asking them
if they're going to change the world
which is fine except that's not how
google started
larry page and sergey brin were two
stanford phd's working on their
dissertations it's not how youtube
started its founders weren't trying to
reinvent tv they were trying to share
funny video clips it's not how most true
wealth was created in fact
investor paul graham who invested in
airbnb
reddit dropbox and others working in the
same city as bill walsh a few decades
later
explicitly warned startups against
having bold sweeping visions early on
of course as a capitalist he wants to
fund companies that massively disrupt
industries and change the world
that's where the money is he wants them
to have frighteningly ambitious ideas
but explains the way to do really big
things seems to be to start with
deceptively small things
he's saying you don't make a frontal
attack out of ego instead you start with
a small bet and iteratively scale your
ambitions as you go
his other famous piece of advice keep
your identity small fits well here make
it about the work and the principles
behind it not about a glorious vision
that makes a good headline
napoleon had the words to destiny
engraved in the wedding ring he gave his
wife
destiny was what he'd always believed in
it was how he justified his boldest most
ambitious ideas it was also why he
overreached time and time again until
his real destiny was divorce
exile defeat and infamy
a great destiny seneca reminds us is
great slavery there's real danger in
believing it when people use the word
genius and it's even more dangerous when
we let our hubris tell ourselves we are
one
the same goes for any label that comes
along with a career
are we suddenly a filmmaker writer
investor entrepreneur or executive
because we've accomplished one thing
these labels put you at odds not just
with reality but with the real strategy
that made you successful in the first
place
from that place we might think that
success in the future is just the
natural next part of the story when
really it's rooted in work creativity
persistence and luck
certainly google's alienation from its
own roots confusing vision and potential
with scientific and technological
prowess will cause it to stumble soon
enough in fact the public failures of
projects like google glass and google
plus might be evidence of it already
they are not alone too often artists who
think it was inspiration or pain that
fueled their art create an image around
it instead of hard work and sincere
hustle will eventually find themselves
at the bottom of a bottle or on the
wrong end of a needle
the same goes for us whatever we do
instead of pretending we are living some
great story we must remain focused on
the execution and on executing with
excellence we must shun the false crown
and continue working on what got us here
because that's the only thing that will
keep us
[Music]
here what's important to you
to know what you like is the beginning
of wisdom
and of old age
robert louis stevenson
at the end of the civil war ulysses s
grant and his friend william tecumseh
sherman were two of the most respected
and important men in america
essentially the dual architects of the
union's victory a grateful country with
a snap of its fingers said whatever you
like as long as you live is yours
with this freedom at their disposal
sherman and grant took different paths
sherman whose track we followed earlier
abhorred politics and repeatedly
declined entreaties to run for office
i have all the rank i want he told them
having seemingly mastered his ego he
would later retired in new york city
where he lived in what was by all
appearances happiness and
contentment grant who had expressed
almost no prior interest in politics and
in fact had succeeded as a general
precisely because he didn't know how to
play politics chose instead to pursue
the highest office in the land the
presidency elected by a landslide he
then presided over one of the most
corrupt contentious and least effective
administrations in american history
a genuinely good and loyal individual he
was not cut out for the dirty world of
washington and it made quick work of him
he left office a maligned and
controversial figure after two
exhausting terms almost surprised by how
poorly it had gone
after the presidency grant invested
almost every penny he had to create a
financial brokerage house with a
controversial investor named ferdinand
ward
ward a bernie madoff of his day turned
it into a ponzi scheme and publicly
bankrupted grant
as sherman wrote with sympathy and
understanding of his friend
grant had aimed to rival the
millionaires who would have given their
all to have won any of his battles
grant had accomplished so much but to
him it wasn't enough he couldn't decide
what was important what actually
mattered to him
that's how it seems to go we're never
happy with what we have we want what
others have too we want to have more
than everyone else we start out knowing
what is important to us but once we've
achieved it we lose sight of our
priorities
ego sways us and can ruin us
compelled by a sense of honor to cover
the debts of the firm grant took out a
loan using his priceless war mementos as
collateral
broken in mind spirit and body the last
years of his life found him battling
painful throat cancer and racing to
finish his memoirs so that he might
leave his family with something to live
on he made it
just barely
one shutters to think of the vital
forces drained from this hero who died
at just 63 in agony and defeat
the straightforward honest man who just
couldn't help himself who couldn't
manage to focus and ended up far outside
the bounds of his ample genius
what could he have done with those years
instead how might america have looked
otherwise how much more could he have
done and accomplished
not that he is unique in this regard
all of us regularly say yes unthinkingly
or out of vague attraction or out of
greed or vanity because we can't say no
because we might miss out on something
if we did
we think that yes will let us accomplish
more when in reality it prevents exactly
what we seek
all of us waste precious life doing
things we don't like to prove ourselves
to people we don't respect and to get
things we don't want
why do we do this what should be obvious
by now
ego leads to envy and it rots the bones
of people big and small
ego undermines greatness by deluding its
holder
most of us begin with a clear idea of
what we want in life we know what's
important to us the success we achieve
especially if it comes earlier in
abundance puts us in an unusual place
because now all of a sudden we're in a
new place and have trouble keeping our
bearings
the farther you travel down that path of
accomplishment whatever it may be the
more often you meet other successful
people who make you feel insignificant
it doesn't matter how well you're doing
your ego and their accomplishments make
you feel like nothing just as others
make them feel the same way it's a cycle
that goes on ad infinitum while our
brief time on earth or the small window
of opportunity we have here does not
so we unconsciously pick up the pace to
keep up with others but what if other
people are running for different reasons
what if there is more than one race
going on
that's what sherman was saying about
grant
there's a certain gift of the magi irony
in how badly we chase what will not be
truly pleasurable
at the very least it won't last
if only we could all stop for a second
let's be clear competitiveness is an
important force in life it's what drives
the market and is behind some of
mankind's most impressive
accomplishments
on an individual level however it's
absolutely critical that you know who
you are competing with and why that you
have a clear sense of the space you're
in
only you know the race you're running
that is unless your ego decides that the
only way you have value is if you're
better than have more than
everyone
everywhere
more urgently each one of us has a
unique potential and purpose
that means we're the only ones who can
evaluate and set the terms of our lives
far too often we look at other people
and make their approval the standard we
feel compelled to meet and as a result
squander our very potential and purpose
according to seneca the greek word
eutemia is one we should think of often
it is the sense of our own path and how
to stay on it without getting distracted
by all the others that intersect it
in other words it's not about beating
the other guy it's not about having more
than the others it's about being what
you are and being as good as possible at
it without succumbing to all the things
that draw you away from it
it's about going where you set out to go
about accomplishing the most you're
capable of
in what you choose
that's it no more no less
by the way eutemia means tranquility in
english
it's time to sit down and think about
what's truly important to you and then
take steps to forsake the rest
without this success will not be
pleasurable or nearly as complete as it
could be
or worse it won't last
this is especially true with money
if you don't know how much you need the
default easily becomes more
and so without thinking critical energy
is diverted from a person's calling and
toward filling a bank account
when you combine insecurity and ambition
the plagiarist and disgraced journalist
joe nolaire said when reflecting back on
his fault
you get an inability to say no to things
ego rejects trade-offs why compromise
ego wants it all
ego tells you to cheat even though you
love your spouse because you want what
you have and what you don't have
ego says that sure even though you're
just starting to get the hang of one
thing why not jump right in the middle
of another
eventually you say yes to too much
to something far beyond the pale we're
like captain ahab chasing moby dick for
reasons we don't even understand anymore
maybe your priority actually is money or
maybe it's family or maybe it's
influence or change maybe it's building
an organization that lasts or serves a
purpose
all of these are perfectly fine
motivations
but you do need to know you need to know
what you don't want and what your
choices preclude
because strategies are often mutually
exclusive
one cannot be an opera singer and a teen
pop idol at the same time life requires
trade-offs but ego can't allow it
so why do you do what you do
that's the question you need to answer
stare at it until you can
only then will you understand what
matters and what doesn't only then can
you say no can you opt out of stupid
races that don't matter or even exist
only then is it easy to ignore
successful people because most of the
time they aren't at least relative to
you and often even to themselves
only then can you develop the quiet
confidence seneca talked about
the more you have and do the harder
maintaining fidelity to your purpose
will be but the more critically you will
need to
everyone buys into the myth that if only
they had that usually what someone else
has they would be happy
it may take getting burned a few times
to realize the emptiness of this
illusion
we all occasionally find ourselves in
the middle of some project or obligation
and can't understand why we're there it
will take courage and faith to stop
yourself
find out why you're after what you're
after
ignore those who mess with your pace
let them covet what you have not the
other way around because that's
independence
[Music]
entitlement control and paranoia
one of the symptoms of approaching
nervous breakdown is the belief that
one's work is terribly important
bertrand russell
when xerxes the persian emperor crossed
the hellespont during his invasion of
greece the waters surged up and
destroyed the bridges his engineers had
spent days building
so he threw chains into the river
ordered it to be given 300 lashes and
branded it with hot irons
as his men delivered his punishment they
were ordered to harangue it you salt and
bitter stream your master lays this
punishment upon you for injuring him who
never injured you oh and he cut off the
heads of the men who built the bridges
herodotus the great historian called the
display presumptuous which is probably
an understatement
surely preposterous and delusional are
more appropriate
then again it was part of his
personality
shortly before this xerxes had written a
letter to a nearby mountain in which he
needed to cut a canal
you may be tall and proud he wrote but
don't you dare cause me any trouble
otherwise i'll topple you into the sea
how hilarious is that more important how
pathetic
xerxes delusional threats are
unfortunately not a historical anomaly
with success particularly power comes
some of the greatest and most dangerous
delusions entitlement control and
paranoia
hopefully you won't find yourself so
crazed that you start anthropomorphizing
and inflicting retribution on inanimate
objects that's pure recognizable crazy
and thankfully rare what's more likely
and more common is we begin to
overestimate our own power then we lose
perspective
eventually we can end like xerxes a
monstrous joke
the strongest poison ever known the poet
william blake wrote came from caesar's
laurel crown
success
casts a spell over us
the problem lies in the path that got us
to success in the first place
what we've accomplished often required
feats of raw power and force of will
both entrepreneurship and art require
the creation of something where nothing
existed before
wealth means beating the market and the
odds
athletic champions have proved their
physical superiority over opponents
achieving success involved ignoring the
doubts and reservations of the people
around us
it meant rejecting rejection it required
taking certain risks
we could have given up at any time but
we're here precisely because we didn't
persistence and courage in the face of
ridiculous odds are partially irrational
traits in some cases really irrational
but when it works those tendencies can
feel like they've been vindicated
and why shouldn't they it's human to
think that since it's been done once
that the world was changed in some big
or small way that there's now a magical
power in our possession
we're here because we're bigger stronger
smarter
that we make the reality we inhabit
right before he destroyed his own
billion dollar company ty warner creator
of beanie babies overrode the cautious
objections of one of his employees and
bragged i could put the tie heart on
manure and they'd buy it he was wrong
and the company not only
catastrophically failed he later
narrowly missed going to jail
it doesn't matter if you're a
billionaire a millionaire or just a kid
who snagged a good job early
the complete and utter sense of
certainty that got you here can become a
liability if you're not careful
the demands and dream you had for a
better life
the ambition that fueled your effort
these begin as earnest tribes but left
unchecked become hubris and entitlement
the same goes for the instinct to take
charge now you're addicted to control
driven to prove the doubt is wrong
welcome to the seeds of paranoia
yes there are legitimate stresses and
anguish that come with the
responsibilities of your new life
all the things you're managing the
frustrating mistakes of people who
should know better the endless creep of
obligations
no one prepares us for that which makes
the feelings all the harder to deal with
the promised land was supposed to be
nice not aggravating but you can't let
the walls close in on you you've got to
get yourself and your perceptions under
control
when arthur lee was sent to france and
england to serve as one of america's
diplomats during the revolutionary war
instead of relishing the opportunity to
work with his fellow diplomat silas dean
and elder statesman benjamin franklin he
raged and resented them and suspected
them of disliking him
finally franklin wrote him a letter one
that we've probably all deserved to get
at one point or another
if you don't cure yourself of this
temper franklin advised it will end in
insanity of which it is the symptomatic
forerunner
probably because he was in such command
of his own temper franklin decided that
writing the letter was cathartic enough
he'd never sent it
if you've ever listened to the oval
office tapes of richard nixon you can
hear the same sickness and you wish
someone could have sent him such a
letter
it's a harrowing insight into a man
who's lost his grip not just on what
he's legally allowed to do
on what his job was to serve the people
but on reality itself
he vacillates wildly from supreme
confidence to dread and fear
he talks over his subordinates and
rejects information and feedback that
challenges what he wants to believe
he lives in a bubble in which no one can
say no not even his conscience
there's a letter from general winfield
scott to jefferson davis then the
secretary of war for the united states
davis belligerently pestered scott
repeatedly about some trivial matter
scott ignored it until finally forced to
address it he wrote that he pitied davis
compassion is always due he said to him
to an enraged imbecile who lays about
him in blows which only hurt himself
ego is its own worst enemy
it hurts the ones we love too
our friends and families suffer for it
so do our customers fans and clients
a critic of napoleon nailed it when
remarking he despises the nation whose
applause he seeks
he couldn't help but see the french
people as pieces to be manipulated
people he had to be better than people
who unless they were totally
unconditionally supportive of him were
against him
a smart man or woman must regularly
remind themselves of the limits of their
power and reach
entitlement assumes this is mine i've
earned it
at the same time entitlement nickels and
dimes other people because it can't
conceive of valuing another person's
time as highly as its own
it delivers tirades and pronouncements
that exhaust the people who work for and
with us who have no choice other than to
go along
it overstates our abilities to ourselves
it renders generous judgment of our
prospects and it creates ridiculous
expectations
control says it must be done my way even
little things even inconsequential
things
it can be paralyzing perfectionism or a
million pointless battles fought merely
for the sake of exerting its say
it too exhausts people whose help we
need particularly quiet people who don't
object until we've pushed them to their
breaking point
we fight with the clerk at the airport
the customer service representative on
the telephone the agent who examines our
claim
to what end
in reality we don't control the weather
we don't control the market we don't
control other people and our efforts and
energies in spite of this are pure waste
paranoia thinks i can't trust anyone
i'm in this totally by myself and for
myself
it says i'm surrounded by fools
it says focusing on my work my
obligations myself is not enough
i also have to be orchestrating various
machinations behind the scenes to get
them before they get me to get them back
for the slights i perceive
everyone has had a boss a partner a
parent like this
all that strife anger chaos and conflict
how did it go for them how did it end
he who indulges empty fears earns
himself real fears wrote seneca who was
a political advisor witnessed a
destructive paranoia at the highest
levels
the sad feedback loop is that the
relentless looking out for number one
can encourage other people to undermine
and fight us they see that behavior for
what it is a mask for weakness
insecurity and instability
in its frenzy to protect itself paranoia
creates the persecution it seeks to
avoid making the owner a prisoner of its
own delusions and chaos
is this the freedom you envisioned when
you dreamed of your success
likely not
so stop
[Music]
managing yourself
it is not enough to have great qualities
we should also have the management of
them
in 1953 dwight d eisenhower returned
from his inaugural parade and entered
the white house for the first time as
president late in the evening
as he walked into the executive mansion
his chief usher handed eisenhower two
letters marked confidential and secret
that had been sent to him earlier in the
day
eisenhower's reaction was swift
never bring me a sealed envelope he said
firmly that's what i have a staff for
how snobbish right
had the office really gone to his head
already
not at all
eisenhower recognized the seemingly
insignificant event for what it was a
symptom of a disorganized dysfunctional
organization
not everything needed to run through him
who's to say that the envelope was even
important why hadn't anyone screened it
as president his first priority in
office was organizing the executive
branch into a smooth
functioning and order driven unit
just like his military units had been
not because he didn't want to work
himself but because everyone had a job
and he trusted and empowered them to do
it
as his chief of staff later put it the
president does the most important things
i do the next most important things
the public image of eisenhower is of the
man playing golf
in reality he was not someone who ever
slacked off but the leisure time he did
have was available because he ran a
tight ship
he knew that urgent and important were
not synonyms his job was to set the
priorities to think big picture and then
trust the people beneath him to do the
jobs they were hired for
most of us are not the president or even
president of a company but in moving up
the ladder in life the system and work
habits that got us where we are won't
necessarily keep us there
when we're aspiring our small time we
can be idiosyncratic we can compensate
for disorganization with hard work and a
little luck
that's not going to cut it in the majors
in fact it will sink you if you can't
grow up and organize
we can contrast eisenhower's system in
the white house with the infamous car
company created by john delorean when he
walked away from gm to produce his brand
of futuristic cars
a few decades removed from the company's
spectacular implosion we can be forgiven
for thinking the man was just ahead of
his time
in fact his rise and fall is as timeless
as story as there is
power hungry narcissist undermines his
own vision and loses millions of dollars
of other people's money in the process
delorean was convinced that the culture
of order and discipline at gm had held
brilliant creatives like himself down
when he set out to found his company he
deliberately did everything differently
flouting conventional wisdom and
business practices
the result was not the free willing
creative sanctuary that delorean naively
envisioned it was instead an
overbearingly political dysfunctional
and even corrupt organization
that collapsed under its own weight
eventually resorting to criminality and
fraud and losses of some 250 million
dollars
the delorean failed as both a car and as
a company because it was mismanaged from
top to bottom with an emphasis on the
mismanagement at the top
by the top
that is delorean himself was the problem
compared to eisenhower he worked
constantly with very different results
as one executive put it delorean had the
ability to recognize a good opportunity
but he didn't know how to make it happen
another executive described his
management style as
chasing colored balloons he was
constantly distracted and abandoning one
project for another
he was a genius
sadly that's rarely enough
though probably not on purpose delorean
created a culture in which ego ran free
convinced that continued success was
simply his by right he seemed to bristle
at concepts like discipline organization
or strategic planning
employees were not given enough
direction and that at other times
overwhelmed with trivial instructions
delorean couldn't delegate except to
lackeys whose blind loyalty was prized
over competence or skill
on top of all this he was often late or
preoccupied
executives were allowed to work on
extracurricular activities on the
company dime encouraged specifically to
chase side projects that benefited their
boss at the expense of the company
as ceo delorean often bent the truth to
investors fellow officers and suppliers
and this habit was contagious throughout
the company
like many people driven by a demon
delorean's decisions were motivated by
everything but what would have been
efficient manageable or responsible
instead of improving or fixing gm system
it's as if he threw out order altogether
what ensued was chaos in which no one
ever followed the rules no one was
accountable and very little got done
the only reason it didn't collapse
immediately was that delorean was a
master of public relations
a skill that held the whole story
together until the first faulty cars
came off the assembly line not
surprisingly the cars were terrible they
didn't work cost per unit was massively
over budget they hadn't secured enough
dealers they couldn't deliver cars to
the ones they had
the launch was a disaster delorean motor
company never recovered
it turns out that becoming a great
leader is difficult who knew
delorean couldn't manage himself so he
had trouble managing others and so he
managed to fail both himself and the
dream
management that's the reward for all
your creativity and new ideas becoming
the man
yes in the end we all face becoming the
adult supervision we originally rebelled
against
yet often we react petulantly and prefer
to think now that i'm in charge things
are going to be different
think about eisenhower he was the damn
president the most powerful man in the
world
he could have kicked back and done
things how he liked if he was
disorganized people would have had to
just deal with it there have been plenty
of those presidents before
yet he wasn't
he understood that order and
responsibility were what the country
needed and that this far outweighed his
own concerns
what was so sad about delorean is that
like a lot of talented people his ideas
were on point his car was an exciting
innovation his model could have worked
he had all the assets and the talent it
was his ego and disorganization that
resulted from it that prevented the
ingredients from coming together just as
they do for so many of us
as you become successful in your own
field your responsibilities may begin to
change
days become less and less about doing
and more and more about making decisions
such as the nature of leadership
this transition requires re-evaluating
and updating your identity
it requires a certain humility to put
aside some of the more enjoyable or
satisfying parts of your previous job
it means accepting that others might be
more qualified or specialized in areas
in which you considered yourself
competent or at least their time is
better spent on them than yours
yes it would be more fun to be
constantly involved in every tiny matter
and might make us feel important to be
the person called to put out fires
the little things are endlessly engaging
and often flattering while the big
picture can be hard to discern
it's not always fun but it is the job
if you don't think big picture because
you're too busy playing boss man who
will
of course there is no right system
sometimes systems are better
decentralized sometimes they are better
on a strict hierarchy
every project and goal deserves an
approach fitted perfectly to what needs
to be done
maybe a creative relaxed environment
makes the most sense for what you're
doing maybe you can run your business
remotely maybe it's better for everyone
to see each other face to face
what matters is that you learn how to
manage yourself and others before your
industry eats you alive
micromanagers are egotists who can't
manage others and they quickly get
overloaded so do the charismatic
visionaries who lose interest when it's
time to execute
worse yet are those who surround
themselves with yes men or sick offense
who clean up their messes and create a
bubble in which they can't even see how
disconnected from reality they are
responsibility requires a readjustment
and then increased clarity and purpose
first setting the top level goals and
priorities of the organization in your
life
then enforcing and observing them to
produce results and only results
a fish stinks from the head is the
saying
well you're the head now
[Music]
beware the disease of me
if i am not for myself who will be for
me
if i am only for myself who am i
hillel
there were the great allied generals of
world war ii patton bradley montgomery
eisenhower macarthur zhukov
and then there was george catlett
marshall jr
although all of them served their
countries and fought and led bravely one
stands apart
today we see world war ii as a clear
fight in which good aligns selflessly
against evil
the problem is that victory in the
passage of time have obscured the all
all-too-humanness
of the people who were on the right side
of that fight
that is
we forget the politics the backstabbing
the spotlight coveting the posturing the
greed and the ass covering among the
allies
while the other generals protected their
turf fought with each other and eagerly
aspired to their place in history that
behavior was virtually absent in one man
general george marshall
more impressively marshall quietly
outpaced all of them with the magnitude
of his accomplishments
what was his secret
pat riley the famous coach and manager
who led the los angeles lakers in the
miami heat to multiple championships
says that great teams tend to follow a
trajectory when they start before they
have won a team is innocent
if the conditions are right they come
together they watch out for each other
and work together toward their
collective goal
this stage he calls the innocent climb
after a team starts to win and media
attention begins the simple bonds that
joined the individuals together begin to
fray
players calculate their own importance
chess swell frustrations emerge egos
appear
the innocent climb pat riley says is
almost always followed by the disease of
me
it can strike any winning team in any
year at any moment and it does with
alarming regularity
it's shaq and kobe unable to play
together it's jordan punching steve kerr
horace grant and will perdue his own
team members he punched people on his
own team
it's enron employees plunging california
into darkness for personal profit
it's leaks to the media from a
disgruntled executive hoping to scuttle
a project he dislikes
it's nagging and every other
intimidation tactic
for us it's beginning to think that
we're better that we're special that our
problems and experiences are so
incredibly different from everyone
else's that no one could possibly
understand it's an attitude that has
sunk far better people teams and causes
than ours
with general marshall who began his term
as chief of staff of the us army on the
day germany invaded poland in 1939 and
served through the entire war we see one
of history's few exceptions to this
trend
marshall somehow never caught the
disease of me and in many ways often
shamed it out of the people who did
it begins with this balanced
relationship to rank an obsession for
most people in his line of work
he was not a man who abstained from
every public show of rancor status he
insisted that the president call him
general marshall not george for example
he'd earned it right
but while other generals regularly
lobbied for promotions general macarthur
for example advanced over other officers
in the pre-war years largely due to the
aggressive efforts of his mother
marshall actively discouraged it
when others began to push for marshall
to be chief of staff he asked them to
stop
because it makes me conspicuous in the
army too conspicuous in fact he said
later he discouraged an effort by the
house to pass a bill awarding him the
rank of field marshal
not only because he thought the name
field marshall marshall would sound
ridiculous but because he didn't want to
outrank or hurt his mentor general
pershing who is near death and a
constant source of advice and guidance
can you imagine in all these cases his
sense of honor meant turning down honors
and often letting them go to other
people
like any normal human being he wanted
them only the right way more important
he knew that however nice they would
have been to have he could do without
them while perhaps others could not
ego needs honors in order to be
validated confidence on the other hand
is able to wait and focus on the task at
hand regardless of external recognition
early on in our careers we may be able
to make these sacrifices more easily we
can drop out of a prestigious college to
start our own company or we can tolerate
being looked over once in a while
once we've made it the tendency is to
switch to the mindset of getting what's
mine
now all of a sudden awards and
recognition matter even though they
weren't what got us here we need that
money that title that media attention
not for the team or for the cause but
for ourselves because we've earned it
let's make one thing clear we never earn
the right to be greedy or to pursue our
interests at the expense of everyone
else to think otherwise is not only
egotistical it's counterproductive
marshall was tested on this to the
extreme
a job he trained his whole life for was
up for grabs command of the troops on
d-day essentially the largest
coordinated invasion the world had ever
seen
roosevelt let it be known that it was
marshalls if you wanted it
a general's place in history is assured
by his feats in battle so even though
marshall was needed in washington
roosevelt wanted to give him the
opportunity to take command
marshall would have none of it the
decision is yours mr president he said
my wishes have nothing to do with the
matter
the role and the glory went to
eisenhower instead
it came to be that eisenhower was in
fact the best man for that job he
performed superbly and helped win the
war would anything else have been worth
the trade-off
yet this is what we regularly refuse to
do our ego precludes serving any larger
mission we're part of
what are we going to do
let someone get one over on us
the writer cheryl strayed once told a
young reader you're becoming who you're
going to be and so you might as well not
be an [ __ ]
this is one of the most dangerous
ironies of success it can make us
someone we never wanted to be in the
first place the disease of me can
corrupt the most innocent climb
there was a general who treated marshall
poorly essentially banishing him to some
obscure postings in the middle of his
career
later marshall surpassed him and had his
chance for revenge
except he didn't take it because
whatever the man's flaws marshall saw
that he was still of use and that the
country would be worse off without him
what were the thanks for this quiet
suppression of ego just another job well
done and not much more
the word for that is one we don't use
much anymore magnanimous
it was a good strategy too of course but
mostly marshall was gracious forgiving
and magnanimous because it was right
according to observers as high up as
president truman what separated marshall
from nearly everyone else in the
military and in politics is that quote
never did george marshall think about
himself
there's another story of marshall
sitting for one of the many official
portraits that was required of him
after appearing many times and patiently
honoring the requests marshall was
finally informed by the painter that he
was finished and free to go
marshall stood up and began to leave
don't you want to see the painting the
artist asked no thank you marshall said
respectfully and left
is that to say that managing your image
isn't important of course not
early in your career you'll notice that
you jump on every opportunity to do so
as you become more accomplished you'll
realize that so much of it is a
distraction from your work
time spent with reporters with awards
and with marketing are time away from
what you really care about
who has time to look at a picture of
himself what's the point
as his wife later observed the people
who saw george marshall as simply modest
or quiet missed what was special about
the man
he had the same traits that everyone has
ego self-interest pride dignity ambition
but they were tempered by a sense of
humility and selflessness she said
it doesn't make you a bad person to want
to be remembered to want to make it to
the top to provide for yourself and your
family
after all that's all part of the allure
there is a balance
soccer coach tony adams expresses it
well
play for the name on the front of the
jersey he says and they'll remember the
name on the back
when it comes to marshall the old idea
that selflessness and integrity could be
weakness or hold someone back are
laughably disproven
sure some people might have trouble
telling you much about him but each and
every one of them lives in a world he
was largely responsible for shaping the
credit who cares
[Music]
meditate on the immensity
a monk is a man who is separated from
all and who is in harmony with all
a vagrious ponticus
in 1879 the preservationist and explorer
john muir took his first trip to alaska
as he explored the fjords and rocky
landscape of alaska's now famous glacier
bay a powerful feeling struck him all at
once
he'd always been in love with nature and
here in the unique summer climate of the
far north in this single moment it was
as if the entire world was in sync as if
he could see the entire ecosystem and
the circle of life before him
his pulse began to pick up and as he
said he and the group were warned and
quickened into sympathy with everything
taken back into the heart of nature from
which we all came
thankfully miron noticed and recorded in
his journal the beautiful cohesion of
the world around him which few have ever
matched since
as he said
we feel the life and motion about us
and the universal beauty the tides
marching back and forth with weareless
industry
leaving the beautiful shores
and swaying the purple dulce of the
broad meadows of the sea where the
fishes are fed the wild streams in rose
white with waterfalls
ever in bloom and ever in song
spreading their branches over a thousand
mountains the vast forest is feeding on
the drenching sunbeams
every cell in a whirl of enjoyment
misty flocks of insects stirring all the
air
the wild sheep and the goats on the
grassy ridges above the woods bears in
the berry tangles
mink and beaver and otter far back on
many a river and lake
indians and adventurers pursuing their
lonely ways
birds tending to their young
everywhere everywhere beauty and life
and glad rejoicing action
in this moment he was experiencing what
the stokes would call sympatheia a
connectedness with the cosmos
the french philosopher pierre hedeau has
referred to it as the oceanic feeling
a sense of belonging to something larger
of realizing that human things are an
infinitesimal point in the immensity as
he put it
it is in these moments that we're not
only free but drawn toward important
questions
who am i
what am i doing what is my role in this
world
nothing draws us away from those
questions like material success
when we are always busy stressed put
upon distracted reported to relied on
apart from
when we're wealthy and we're told we're
important or powerful
ego tells us that meaning comes from
activity that being the center of
attention is the only way to matter
when we lack a connection to anything
larger or bigger than us it's like a
piece of our soul is gone
like we've detached ourselves from the
traditions we hail from whatever that
happens to be
a craft a sport a brother or sisterhood
a family
ego blocks us from the beauty and
history in the world it stands in the
way
no wonder we find success empty no
wonder we're exhausted no wonder it
feels like we're on a treadmill
no wonder we lose touch with the energy
that once fueled us
here's an exercise
walk onto an ancient battlefield or a
place of historical significance
look at the statues and you can't help
but see how similar the people look how
little has changed since then
since before and how it will be forever
after here a great man once stood
here another brave woman died
here a cruel rich man lived in this
palatial home
it's the sense that others have been
here before you
generations of them in fact
in those moments we have a sense of the
immensity of the world
ego is impossible because we realize if
only fleetingly what emerson meant when
he said that every man is a quotation
from all his ancestors
they are a part of us we are a part of a
tradition
embrace the power of this position and
learn from it it is an exhilarating
feeling to grasp this like the one that
muir felt in alaska
yes we are small we are also a piece of
this great universe and a process
the astrophysicist neil degrasse tyson
has described this duality well
it's possible to bask in both your
relevance and irrelevance to the cosmos
as he says when i look up in the
universe i know i'm small but i'm also
big
i'm big because i'm connected to the
universe and the universe is connected
to me
we just can't forget which is bigger and
which has been here longer
why do you think that great leaders and
thinkers throughout history have gone
out into the wilderness and come back
with inspiration with a plan with an
experience that puts them on a course
that changes the world
it's because in doing so they found
perspective they understood the larger
picture in a way that wasn't possible in
the bustle of everyday life
silencing the noise around them they
could finally hear the quiet voice they
needed to listen to
creativity is a matter of receptiveness
and recognition
this cannot happen if you're convinced
the world revolves around you
by removing ego even temporarily we can
access what's standing in relief
by widening our perspective more comes
into view
it sat out disconnected from the past
and from the future most of us really
are
we forget that woolly mammoths walked
the earth while the pyramids were being
built we don't realize that cleopatra
lived closer to our time than she did to
the construction of those famous
pyramids that marked her kingdom
when british workers excavated the land
in trafalgar square to build nelson's
column and its famous stone lions in the
ground they found bones of actual lions
who'd roamed that exact spot just a few
thousand years before
someone recently calculated that it
takes but a chain of six individuals who
shook hands with one another across the
centuries to connect barack obama to
george washington
there's a video you can watch on youtube
of a man on a cbs game show i've got a
secret in 1956
in an episode that also happened to
feature a famous actress named lucille
ball his secret he was in ford's theater
when lincoln was assassinated
the english government only recently
paid off debts that incurred as far back
as 1720 from events like the south sea
bubble the napoleonic wars the empire's
abolition of slavery in the irish potato
famine
meaning that in the 21st century there
was still a direct and daily connection
to the 18th and 19th centuries
as our power and talents grow we like to
think that makes us special that we live
in blessed unprecedented times
this is compounded by the fact so many
of the photos we see from even 50 years
ago are still in black and white we seem
to assume that the world was in black
and white
obviously it wasn't their sky was the
same color as ours some places brighter
than ours they bled the same way we did
and their cheeks got flushed just like
ours do
we are just like them and always will be
it's hard to be humble when you're as
great as i am muhammad ali once said
yeah okay
that's why great people have to work
even harder to fight against this
headwind
it's hard to be self-absorbed and
convinced of your own greatness inside
the solitude and quiet of a sensory
deprivation tank
it's hard to be anything but humble
walking alone on a beach late at night
with an endless black ocean crashing
loudly against the ground next to you
we have to actively seek out this cosmic
sympathy
there's the famous blake poem that opens
with
to see a world in a grain of sand
and a heaven in a wild flower
hold infinity in the palm of your hand
and eternity in an hour
that's what we're after here that's the
transcendental experience that makes our
petty ego impossible
feel unprotected against the elements or
forces or surroundings remind yourself
how pointless it is to rage and fight
and try to one-up those around you
go and put yourself in touch with the
infinite and end your conscious
separation from the world
reconcile yourself a bit better with the
realities of life
realize how much came before you and how
only wisps of it remain let the feeling
carry you as long as you can
then when you start to feel better or
bigger then go and do it again
[Music]
maintain your sobriety
the height of cultivation runs to
simplicity
bruce
lee
angela merkel is the antithesis of
nearly every assumption we make about a
head of state especially a german one
she is plain she is modest she cares
little for presentation or flash she
gives no fiery speeches she has no
interest in expansion or domination
mostly she is quiet and reserved
chancellor angela merkel is sober when
far too many leaders are intoxicated
with ego with power with position
this sobriety is precisely what has made
her a wildly popular three-term leader
and paradoxically a powerful sweeping
force for freedom and peace in modern
europe
there's a story about merkel as a young
girl at a swimming lesson
she walked out on the diving board and
stood there thinking about whether she
should jump
minutes ticked by more minutes
finally just as the bell marking the end
of the lesson began to ring she jumped
was she afraid or just cautious
many years later she would remind
europe's leaders during a major crisis
that fear is a bad advisor
as a kid on that diving board she wanted
to use every allotted second to make the
right decision
not driven by recklessness or fear
in most cases we think that people
become successful through sheer energy
and enthusiasm
we almost excuse ego because we think
it's part and parcel of the personality
required to make it big
maybe a bit of that overpoweringness is
what got you where you are but let's ask
is it really sustainable for the next
several decades
can you really outwork and outrun
everyone forever
the answer is no
the ego tells us we're invincible that
we have unlimited force that will never
dissipate
but that can't be what greatness
requires energy without end
merkel is the embodiment of aesop's
fable about the tortoise she is slow and
steady
the historic night the berlin wall fell
she was 35
she had one beer went to bed and showed
up early for work the next day
a few years later she had worked to
become a respected but obscure physicist
only then did she enter politics
in her 50s she became chancellor
it was a diligent plotting path
yet the rest of us want to get to the
top as fast as humanly possible we have
no patience for waiting we're high on
getting high up in the ranks
once we've made it we tend to think that
ego and energy is the only way to stay
there it's not
when russian president vladimir putin
once attempted to intimidate merkel by
letting his large hunting dog barge into
a meeting she is reportedly not a dog
lover she didn't flinch and later joked
about it
as a result he was the one who looked
foolish and insecure
during her rise and especially during
her time in power she has consistently
maintained her equilibrium and
clear-headedness regardless of the
immediate stressors or stimuli
in a similar position we might have
sprung into bold action we might have
gotten angry or drawn a line in the sand
we have to stand up for ourselves right
but do we
so often this is just ego escalating
tension more than dealing with it
merkel is firm clear and patient she's
willing to compromise on everything
except the principle at stake
which far too many people lose sight of
that is sobriety
that is command of oneself
she did not become the most powerful
woman in the western world by accident
more importantly she's maintained her
perch for three terms the same formula
the great philosopher king marcus
aurelius knew this very well
called to politics almost against his
will he served the roman people in
continually higher offices from his
teens until his death
there was almost always pressing
business appeals to hear wars to fight
laws to pass favors to grant
he strove to escape what he called
imperialization the stain of absolute
power that had wrecked previous emperors
to do that he wrote to himself he must
fight to be the person philosophy tried
to make you
this is why one zen philosopher is
supposed to have called out to himself
every day
master
yes sir then he would add become sober
yes sir
he would conclude by saying do not be
deceived by others
yes sir yes sir
today we might add to that don't be
deceived by recognition you have gotten
or the amount of money in your bank
account
we have to fight to stay sober despite
the many different forces swirling
around our ego
the historian shelby foote observed that
power doesn't so much corrupt that's too
simple
it fragments closes options mesmerizes
that's what ego does it clouds the mind
precisely when it needs to be clear
sobriety is a counterbalance a hangover
cure or better a prevention method
other politicians are bold and
charismatic but as merkel supposedly
said you can't solve tasks with charisma
she is rational she analyzes she makes
it about the situation not about herself
as people in power often do
her background in science is helpful
here surely politicians are often vain
obsessing about their image merkel is
too objective for that
she cares about the results and little
else
a german writer observed in a tribute on
her 50th birthday that unpretentiousness
is merkel's main weapon
david halberstram writing about patriots
coach bill belichick observed that the
man was not only in the state business
he had contempt for sizzle you could say
the same about merkel
leaders like belichick and merkel know
that stake is what wins games and moves
nations forward
sizzle on the other hand makes it harder
to make the right decisions how to
interact with others who to promote
which place to run what feedback to
listen to where to come down on an issue
churchill's europe required one type of
leader today's interconnected world
requires its own
because there's so much information to
be sorted through
so much competition so much change
without a clear head all is lost
we're not talking about abstinence from
drugs or alcohol obviously but there
certainly is an element of restraint to
egoless sobriety an elimination of the
unnecessary and the destructive
no more obsessing about your image
treating people beneath you or above you
with contempt
needing first class trappings in the
star treatment
raging fighting preening performing
lording over
condescending and marveling at your own
awesomeness or self-anointed importance
sobriety is the counterweight that must
balance out success
especially if things keep getting better
and better as james basford remarked it
requires a strong constitution to
withstand repeated attacks of prosperity
well that's where we are now
there's an old line about how if you
want to live happy live hidden
it's true
the problem is that means the rest of us
are deprived of really good examples
we're lucky to see someone like merkel
in the public eye because she is the
representative of a very large silent
majority
as hard as it might be to believe from
what we see in the media there are
actually some successful people with
modest apartments like merkel they have
normal private lives with their spouses
her husband skipped her first
inauguration
they lack artifice they wear normal
clothes
most successful people are people you've
never heard of they want it that way
it keeps them sober it helps them do
their jobs
[Music]
for what often comes next ego is the
enemy
the evidence is in and you are the
verdict
and lamont
here you are at the pinnacle
what have you found
just how tough and tricky it is to
manage
you thought it would get easier when you
arrived instead it's even harder a
different animal entirely
what you found is that you must manage
yourself in order to maintain your
success
the philosopher aristotle was not
unfamiliar with the worlds of ego and
power and empire
his most famous pupil was alexander the
great
partially through aristotle's teachings
the young man conquered the entire known
world
alexander was brave and brilliant and
often generous and wise
still it's clear that he ignored
aristotle's most important lesson and
that's partially why he died at age 32
far from home likely killed by his own
men who had finally said enough
it's not that he was wrong to have great
ambitions
alexander just never grasped aristotle's
golden mean
that is the middle ground
aristotle repeatedly speaks of virtue
and excellence as points along a
spectrum
courage for instance lies between
cowardice on one end and recklessness on
the other
generosity which we all admire must stop
short of either profligacy and parsimony
in order to be of any use
where the line this golden mean is can
be difficult to tell but without finding
it we risk dangerous extremes
this is why it is so hard to be
excellent
as aristotle wrote in each case it is
hard work to find the intermediate
for instance not everyone but only one
who knows finds the midpoint in a circle
we can use the golden mean to navigate
our ego and our desire to achieve
endless ambition is easy
anyone can put their foot down hard on
the gas
complacency is easy too it's just a
matter of taking that foot off the gas
we must avoid what the business
strategist jim collins terms the
undisciplined pursuit of more as well as
the complacency that comes with plaudits
to borrow from aristotle again what's
difficult is to apply the right amount
of pressure at the right time
in the right way for the right period of
time in the right car going in the right
direction
if we don't do this the consequences can
be dire
there is a line from napoleon who like
alexander died miserably
he said men of great ambition have
sought happiness
and have found fame
what he means is that behind every goal
is the drive to be happy and fulfilled
but when egotism takes hold we lose
track of our goal and end up somewhere
we never intended
emerson in his famous essay on napoleon
takes pains to point out that just a few
years after his death europe was
essentially exactly as it was before
napoleon began his precipitous rise
all that death that effort that greed
those honors
for what
for basically nothing
napoleon he wrote quickly faded away
just like the smoke from his artillery
howard hughes despite his current
reputation as some kind of bold maverick
was not a happy man no matter how
awesome his life may seem from history
or movies
when he was near death one of his aides
sought to reassure a suffering hughes
what an incredible life you have led the
aide said
hugh shook his head and replied with the
sad emphatic honesty of someone whose
time has clearly come
if you had ever swapped places in life
with me he said
i would be willing to bet that you would
have demanded to swap back before the
passage of the first
week we do not have to follow in those
footsteps
we know what decisions we must make to
avoid that ignominious even pathetic end
protecting our sobriety eschewing greed
and paranoia staying humble retaining
our sense of purpose
connecting to the larger world around us
because even if we manage ourselves well
prosperity holds no guarantees
the world conspires against us in many
ways and the laws of nature say that
everything regresses toward the mean
in sports the schedule gets harder after
a winning season
the bad teams get better draft picks and
the salary cap makes it tough to keep a
team together
in life taxes go up the more you make
the more obligations society voice on
you
the media is harder on those it has
covered before
rumors and gossip are the cost of renown
he's a drunk she's gay he's a hypocrite
she's a [ __ ]
the crowd roots for the underdog and
roots against the winners
these are just the facts of life
who can afford to add denial to all that
instead of letting power make us
delusional and instead of taking what we
have for granted
we'd be better to spend our time
preparing for the shifts of fate that
inevitably occur in life that is
adversity difficulty failure
who knows maybe a downturn is exactly
what's coming next worse maybe you
caused it
just because you did something once
doesn't mean you'll be able to do it
successfully forever
reversals and regressions are as much a
part of the cycle of life as anything
else
but we can manage that too
[Music]
part three
failure
here we are experiencing the trials
endemic to any journey perhaps we failed
perhaps our goal turned out to be harder
to achieve than anticipated
no one is permanently successful and not
everyone finds success on the first
attempt we all deal with setbacks along
the way
ego not only leaves us unprepared for
these circumstances it often contributed
to their occurrence in the first place
the way through the way to rise again
requires a reorientation and increased
self-awareness
we don't need pity our own or anyone
else's we need purpose poise and
patience
to whatever failure and challenges you
will face
ego is the enemy
it is because mankind are disposed to
sympathize more entirely with our joy
than with our sorrow
that we make parade of our riches and
conceal our poverty
nothing is so mortifying as to be
obliged to expose our distress to the
view of the public and to feel that
though our situation is open to the eyes
of all mankind
no mortal conceives for us the half of
what we suffer
adam smith
for the first half of her life catherine
graham saw pretty much everything go
right
her father eugene meyer was a financial
genius who made a fortune in the stock
market her mother was a beautiful as
well as brilliant socialite
as a child catherine had the best of
everything the best schools the best
teachers big houses and servants to wait
on her
in 1933 her father bought the washington
post then a struggling but important
newspaper which he began to turn around
the only child to express any serious
interest in it
catherine inherited the paper when she
was older and handed over the management
to her equally impressive husband
phillip graham
she was not another howard hughes who
squandered her family's fortune
she was not another rich kid who took
the easy road in life because she could
but it was a cushy life no question
about it she had been in her words
content to be the tale of her husband's
and parents kite
then life took a turn
phil graham's behavior became
increasingly erratic he drank heavily he
made reckless business decisions and
bought things they couldn't afford
he began having affairs
he publicly humiliated his wife in front
of nearly everyone they knew
rich people problems right
it turns out that he had suffered a
severe mental breakdown and as catherine
attempted to nurse him back to health
he'd killed himself with a hunting rifle
while she napped in the next room
in 1963 at 46 years old catherine graham
a mother of three with no work
experience
found herself in charge of the
washington post company a vast
corporation with thousands of employees
she was unprepared timid and naive
though tragic these events were not
exactly a cataclysmic failure
graham was still rich still white still
privileged
still it was not what she thought her
life had planned for her
that's the point
failure and adversity are relative and
unique to each of us
almost without exception this is what
life does
it takes our plans and dashes them to
pieces sometimes once sometimes lots of
times
as the financial philosopher and
economist george goodman once observed
it is as if we are at a wonderful ball
where the champagne sparkles in every
glass and soft laughter falls upon the
summer air
we know that at some moment the black
horsemen will come shattering through
the terraced doors
wreaking vengeance and scattering the
survivors
those who leave early are saved but the
ball is so splendid no one wants to
leave while there is still time
so everybody keeps asking what time is
it but none of the clocks have hands
he was speaking of economic crises
although he may as well have been
talking about where all of us find
ourselves not just once in our lifetimes
but often
things are going well perhaps we're
aspiring to some big goal perhaps we're
finally enjoying the fruits of our
labors
at any point fate can intervene
if success is ego intoxication then
failure can be a devastating ego blow
turning slips into falls and little
troubles into great unravelings
but if ego is just a nasty side effect
of great success
it can be fatal during failure
we have many names for these problems
sabotage unfairness adversity trials
tragedy
no matter the label it's a trial
we don't like it and some of us are sunk
by it
others seem to be built to make it
through
in either case it's a trial each person
must endure
this fate is as much written for us as
it was written five thousand years ago
for the young king in gilgamesh
he will face a battle he knows not he
will ride a road he knows not
that's what came to katherine graham
it turned out that taking over the paper
was the first in a series of trying and
wrenching events that lasted for nearly
two decades
thomas paine remarking about george
washington once wrote that there is a
natural firmness in some minds which
cannot be unlocked by trifles but which
when unlocked discovers a cabinet of
fortitude
graham seems to have possessed a similar
cabinet
as she settled into her leadership
position graham found that the paper's
conservative board was a constant
obstacle
they were patronizing and risk-averse
and had held the company back
to succeed she would have to develop her
own compass and not defer to others the
way she always had
it eventually became clear that she
needed a new executive editor
against the board's advice she replaced
the well-liked good old boy with an
unknown young upstart
simple enough
the next turn of the screw wasn't
just as the company was filing to go
public the post received a collection of
stolen government documents that editors
asked graham if they could run despite a
court order preventing their publication
she consulted the company's lawyers she
consulted the board
all advised against it
fearing it could sink the ipo or tie the
company up in lawsuits for years
torn she decided to proceed and publish
them a decision with essentially no
precedent
shortly thereafter the paper's
investigation of a burglary at the
democratic national committee's
headquarters relying on an anonymous
source threatened to put the company
permanently at odds with the white house
and washington's powerful elite
as well as jeopardizing the government
licenses they needed for the tv stations
the post owned
at one point nixon loyalist and the
attorney general of the united states
john mitchell threatened that graham had
so overreached that her tit was going to
be caught in a big fat ringer
another aide bragged that the white
house was now thinking about how to
screw the paper over
put yourself in her shoes the most
powerful office in the world explicitly
strategizing how can we hurt the post
the most
on top of that the post stock price was
less than stellar
the market was poor
in 1974 an investor began aggressively
buying up shares in the company
the board was terrified could mean a
hostile takeover
graham was dispatched to deal with him
the following year the paper's printers
union began a vicious protracted strike
at one point union members wore shirts
that said phil shot the wrong gram
despite or perhaps because of these
tactics she decided to fight the strike
they fought back
at four o'clock one morning came a
frantic call the union had sabotaged
company machinery beaten up an innocent
staffer and then set one of the printing
presses on fire
typically during printing strikes
competitors will help fellow papers out
with their printing but graham's
competitors refused costing the post 300
000
a day in advertising revenue
then a suite of major investors began to
sell their stock positions in the
washington post company ostensibly
having lost their faith in its prospects
graham pushed by the activist investor
she'd met with earlier decided her best
option was to spend an enormous amount
of the company's money to buy back its
own shares on the public markets
a dangerous move that almost no one was
doing at the time
that's a list of exhausting problems to
hear about let alone live through
yet because of graham's perseverance it
shook out better than anyone could have
possibly predicted
the leaked documents that graham
published became known as the pentagon
papers and were one of the most
important stories in the history of
journalism
the paper's watergate reporting which so
incensed the nixon white house changed
american history and took down an entire
administration it also won the paper a
pulitzer prize
the investor others had feared turned
out to be a young warren buffett who
became her business mentor and an
enormous advocate and steward of the
company
his small investments in her family's
company would one day become worth
hundreds of millions of dollars
she prevailed the negotiations with the
union and the strike eventually ended
her main competitor in washington the
one that had refused to come to her aid
the star
suddenly folded and was acquired by the
post
her stock buybacks made contrary not
only to business wisdom but the judgment
of the market made the company billions
of dollars
it turns out that the long hard slog she
endured the mistakes she made the
repeated failures crises and attacks
were all leading somewhere
if you'd invested one dollar in the post
ipo in 1971
it would be worth 89
by the time graham stepped down in 1993
compared to 14 for her industry and five
dollars for the s p 500
it makes her not just one of the most
successful female ceos of her generation
and the first to run a fortune 500
company but one of the best ceos ever
period
for someone born with a silver spoon in
her mouth the first decade and a half
was what you'd call a baptism of fire
graham faced difficulty after difficulty
difficulties that she wasn't really
equipped to handle or so it seemed
there were times when it probably felt
like she should have just sold the damn
thing and enjoyed her massive wealth
graham didn't cause her husband's
suicide but it was left to her to carry
on without him
she didn't ask for watergate in the
pentagon papers but it fell on her to
navigate their incendiary nature
while others went on buying in merger
sprees in the 80s she didn't she doubled
down on herself and her own company
despite the fact that it was treated as
a weakling by wall street
she could have taken the easy way a
hundred times but did not
at any given moment there is a chance of
failure or setbacks
bill walsh says almost always your road
to victory goes through a place called
failure
in order to taste success again we've
got to understand what led to this
moment or these years of difficulty what
went wrong and why
we must deal with the situation in order
to move past it we'll need to accept it
and push through it
graham was alone in most of this she was
blindly feeling her way through the dark
trying to figure out a tough situation
she never expected to be in
she's an example of how you can do
almost everything right
and still find yourself in deep [ __ ]
we think that failure only comes to
egomaniacs who were begging for it nixon
deserve to fail to graham
the reality is that while yes often
people set themselves up to crash good
people fail or other people fail them
all the time too
people who have already been through a
lot find themselves stuck with more
life isn't fair
ego loves this notion the idea that
something is fair or not
psychologists call it narcissistic
injury when we take personally totally
indifferent and objective events
we do that when our sense of self is
fragile and dependent on life going our
way all the time
whether what you're going through is
your fault or your problem doesn't
matter because it's yours to deal with
right now
graham's ego didn't cause her to fail
but if she'd had one it certainly would
have prevented her from succeeding ever
again
you could say that failure always
arrives uninvited but through our ego
far too many of us allow it to stick
around
what did graham need through all this
not swagger not bluster she needed to be
strong
she needed confidence and a willingness
to endure
a sense of right and wrong
purpose
it wasn't about her it was about
preserving her family's legacy
protecting the paper
doing her job
what about you will your ego betray you
when things get difficult
or can you proceed without it
when we face difficulty particularly
public difficulty
doubters scandals losses our friend the
ego will show its true colors
absorbing the negative feedback eco says
i knew you couldn't do it why did you
ever try
it claims this isn't worth it this isn't
fair this is somebody else's problem
why don't you come up with a good excuse
and wash your hands of this
it tells us we shouldn't have to put up
with this it tells us that we're not the
problem
that is it adds self-injury to every
injury you experience
to paraphrase epicurus the
narcissistically inclined live in an
unwalled city
a fragile sense of self is constantly
under threat
illusions and accomplishments are not
defenses
not when you've got the special
sensitive antennae trained to receive
and create the signals that challenge
your precarious balancing act
it is a miserable way to live
the year before walsh took over the
49ers they went 2 and 14.
his first year as head coach and general
manager they went
2 and 14.
can you imagine the disappointment all
the changes all the work that went into
that first year and to end up in the
exact same spot as the incompetent coach
who preceded you
that's how most of us would think and
then we'd probably start blaming other
people walsh said he realized he had to
look for evidence elsewhere that it was
turning around
for him
it was in how the games were being
played the good decisions and the
changes that were being made inside the
organization
two seasons later they won the super
bowl and then several more after that
at rock bottom those victories must have
felt like a long way off which is why
you have to be able to see past and
through
as gerter once observed
the great failing is to see yourself as
more than you are and to value yourself
at less than your true worth
a good metaphor might be the kind of
stock buybacks that katherine graham
made in the late 70s and 80s
stock buybacks are controversial they
usually come from a company that is
stalled or whose growth is decelerating
with buybacks a ceo is making a rather
incredible statement she's saying the
market is wrong it's valuing our company
so incorrectly and clearly has so little
idea where we are heading
that we're going to spend the company's
precious cash on a bet that they are
wrong
too often dishonest or egotistical ceos
buy back companies stock because they're
delusional or because they want to
artificially inflate the stock price
conversely timid or weak ceos wouldn't
even consider betting on themselves
in graham's case she made a value
judgment with buffett's help she could
see objectively that the market didn't
appreciate the true worth of the
company's assets she knew that the
reputational hits the learning curve had
all contributed to a suppressed stock
price which aside from reducing her
personal wealth created a massive
opportunity for the company
over a short period she would buy nearly
40 percent of the company's shares at a
fraction of what they'd later be worth
the stock that katherine graham bought
for approximately 20 a share would less
than a decade later be worth more than
three hundred
what both graham and walsh were doing
was adhering to a set of internal
metrics that allowed them to evaluate
and gauge their progress while everyone
on the outside was too distracted by the
supposed signs failure or weakness
this is what guides us through
difficulty
you might not get into your first choice
college you might not get picked for the
project or you might get passed over for
the promotion
someone might outbid you for the job for
your dream house for the opportunity you
feel everything depends on
this might happen tomorrow it might
happen 25 years from now it could last
for 2 minutes or 10 years we know that
everyone experiences failure and
adversity
that we're all subject to the rules of
gravity and averages
what does that mean it means we'll face
them too
as plutarch finally expressed
the future bears down upon each one of
us with all the hazards of the unknown
the only way out is through
humble and strong people don't have the
same trouble with these troubles that
egotists do
there are fewer complaints and far less
self-immolation
instead there's a stoic even cheerful
resilience
pity isn't necessary
their identity isn't threatened they can
get by without constant validation
this is what we're aspiring to
much more than mere success
what matters is that we can respond to
what life throws at us
and how we make it through
[Music]
a live time or dead time
live without wasted time
the words of a parisian political slogan
malcolm x was a criminal he wasn't
malcolm x at the time they called him
detroit red and he was a criminal
opportunist who did a little bit of
everything he ran numbers he sold drugs
he worked as a pimp then he moved up to
armed robbery he had his own burglary
game which he ruled over with a
combination of intimidation and boldness
exploiting the fact that he did not seem
afraid to kill or die
then finally he was arrested for trying
to fence an expensive watch he'd stolen
he was carrying a gun at the time though
to his credit he made no move to fight
the officers who had trapped him
in his apartment they found jewelry furs
an arsenal of guns and all his burglary
tools
he got 10 years it was february 1946 he
was barely 21 years old
even accounting for the shameful
american racism and whatever systemic
legal injustices existed at the time
malcolm x was guilty he deserved to go
to jail
who knows who else he would have hurt or
killed had he continued his escalating
life of crime
when your actions land you a lengthy
prison sentence rightly tried and
convicted something has gone wrong
you've failed not only yourself but the
basic standards of society and morality
that was the case with malcolm
so there he was in prison a number a
body with roughly a decade to sit in a
cage
he faced what robert greene a man who 60
years later would find his wildly
popular books banned in many federal
prisons calls in a lifetime or dead time
scenario
how would the seven years ultimately
play out
what would malcolm do with his time
according to green there are two types
of time in our lives dead time when
people are passive and waiting and a
live time when people are learning
acting and utilizing every second
every moment of failure every moment or
situation that we did not deliberately
choose or control presents this choice
a lifetime
dead time which will it be
malcolm chose a live time he began to
learn he explored religion he taught
himself to be a reader by checking out a
pencil in the dictionary from the prison
library and not only consumed it from
start to finish but copied it down
longhand from cover to cover
all these words he'd never known existed
before were transferred to his brain
as he said later from then until i left
that prison in every free moment i had
if i was not reading in the library i
was reading in my bunk he read history
he read sociology he read about religion
he read the classics he read
philosophers like kant and spinoza
later a reporter asked malcolm what's
your alma mater
his one-word answer books
prison was his college he transcended
confinement through the pages he
absorbed he reflected that months passed
without his even thinking about being
detained against his will
he had as he said never been so truly
free in his life
most people know what malcolm x did
after he got out of prison but they
don't realize or understand how prison
made that possible
how a mix of acceptance humility and
strength powered the transformation
they also aren't aware of how common
this is in history how many figures took
seemingly terrible situations a prison
sentence an exile a bear market or
depression military conscription even
being sent to a concentration camp
and through their attitude and approach
turned those circumstances into fuel for
their unique greatness
francis scott key wrote the poem that
became the national anthem of the united
states while trapped on a ship during a
prisoner exchange of the war of 1812
victor frankel refined his psychologies
of meaning and suffering during his
ordeal in three nazi concentration camps
not that these opportunities always come
in such serious situations
the author ian fleming was on bed rest
in her doctor's orders forbidden from
using a typewriter they were worried
he'd exert himself by writing another
bond novel so he created chitty chitty
bang bang by hand instead
walt disney made his decision to become
a cartoonist while laid up after
stepping on a rusty nail
yes it would feel better in the moment
to be angry to be aggrieved to be
depressed or heartbroken
when injustice or the capriciousness of
fate are inflicted on someone
the normal reaction is to yell to fight
back to resist
you know the feeling i don't want this i
want blank i want it my way this is
short-sighted
think of what you've been putting off
issues you've declined to deal with
systemic problems that felt too
overwhelming to address
dead time is revived when we use it as
an opportunity to do what we've long
needed to do
as they say this moment is not your life
but it is a moment in your life how will
you use it
malcolm could have doubled down on the
life that brought him to prison
dead time isn't only dead because of
sloth or complacency
he could have spent those years becoming
a better criminal strengthening his
contacts or planning his next score
but it still would have been dead time
he might have felt alive while doing it
even as he was slowly killing himself
as robert greene put it many a serious
thinker has been produced in prisons
where we have nothing to do but think
yet sadly prisons in their literal and
figurative forms have produced far more
degenerates losers and nerdwells
inmates might have had nothing to do but
think it's just that what they chose to
think about made them worse and not
better
that's what so many of us do when we
fail or get ourselves in trouble lacking
the ability to examine ourselves we
reinvest our energy into exactly the
patterns of behavior that caused our
problems to begin with
it comes in many forms
idly dreaming about the future plotting
our revenge finding refuge and
distraction
refusing to consider that our choices
are a reflection of our character
we'd rather do basically anything else
but what if we said this is an
opportunity for me
i am using it for my purposes i will not
let this be dead time for me
the dead time was when we were
controlled by ego now now we can live
who knows what you're currently doing
hopefully it's not a prison term even if
it might feel like it maybe you're
sitting in remedial high school class
maybe you're on hold maybe it's a trial
separation maybe you're making smoothies
while you save up money
maybe you're stuck waiting out a
contract or a tour of duty perhaps this
situation is totally one of your own
making or perhaps it's just bad luck
in life we all get stuck with dead time
its occurrence isn't in our control its
use on the other hand is as booker t
washington famously put it cast down
your bucket where you are
make use of what's around you
don't let stubbornness make a bad
situation worse
[Music]
the effort is enough
what matters to an active man is to do
the right thing
whether the right thing comes to pass
should not bother him
gerta
belisarius is one of the greatest yet
unknown military generals in all of
history his name has been so obscured
and forgotten by history that he makes
the underappreciated general marshall
seem positively famous
at least they named the marshall plan
after george
as rome's highest ranking commander
under the byzantine emperor justinian
belisarius saved western civilization on
at least three occasions as rome
collapsed and the seat of the empire
moved to constantinople belisarius was
the only bright light in a dark time for
christianity
he won brilliant victories at deira
cartage naples sicily and constantinople
with just a handful of bodyguards
against a crowd of tens of thousands
belisarius saved the throne when an
uprising had grown so riotous that the
emperor made plans to abdicate
he reclaimed far-flung territories that
had been lost for years despite being
undermanned and deprived of resources he
recaptured and defended rome for the
first time since the barbarians had
sacked and taken it
all of this before he was 40.
his thanks he was not given public
triumphs instead he was repeatedly
placed under suspicion by the paranoid
emperor he served justinian his
victories and sacrifices were undone
with foolish treaties and bad faith his
personal historian procopius was
corrupted by justinian to tarnish the
man's image and legacy
later he was relieved of command
his only remaining title was the
deliberately humiliating commander of
the royal stable
oh and at the end of his illustrious
career belisarius was stripped of his
wealth and according to the legend
blinded and forced to beg in the streets
to survive historians scholars and
artists have lamented and argued about
this treatment for centuries
like all fair-minded people they're
outraged at the stupidity the
ungratefulness and the injustice that
this great and unusual man was subjected
to
the one person we don't hear complaining
about any of this not at the time not at
the end of his life not even in private
letters belisarius himself
ironically he probably could have taken
the throne on numerous occasions though
it appears he was never even tempted
while the emperor justinian phil prayed
all the vices of absolute power control
paranoia selfishness greed we see hardly
a trace of them in belisarius
in his eyes he was just doing his job
one he believed was his sacred duty
he knew that he did it well he knew that
what he had done was right
that was enough
in life there will be times when we do
everything right perhaps even perfectly
yet the results will somehow be negative
failure disrespect jealousy even a
resounding yawn from the world
depending on what motivates us this
response can be crushing if ego holds
sway we'll accept nothing less than full
appreciation
a dangerous attitude because when
someone works on a project whether it's
a book or a business or otherwise at a
certain point that thing leaves their
hands and enters the realm of the world
it is judged received and acted on by
other people
it stops being something he controls
and depends on them
belisarius could win his battles he
could lead his men
he could determine his personal ethics
he could not control whether his work
was appreciated or whether it aroused
suspicion he had no ability to control
whether a powerful dictator would treat
him well
this reality rings essentially true for
everyone in every kind of life
what was so special about belisarius was
that he accepted the bargain
doing the right thing was enough serving
his country his god doing his duty
faithfully was all that mattered
any adversity could be endured and any
rewards were considered extra
which is good because not only was he
often not rewarded for the good he did
he was punished
that seems galling at first indignation
is the reaction we'd have if it happened
to us or someone we know
what was his alternative should he have
done the wrong thing instead we are all
faced with the same challenge in the
pursuit of our own goals will we work
hard for something that can be taken
away from us
will we invest time and energy if an
outcome is not guaranteed
with the right motives we're willing to
proceed with ego we're not
we have only minimal control over the
rewards for our work and effort other
people's validations recognition rewards
so what are we going to do
not be kind not work hard not produce
because there is a chance it wouldn't be
reciprocated come on
think of all the activists who will find
that they can only advance their cause
so far
the leaders who are assassinated before
their work is done
the inventors whose ideas languish ahead
of their time
according to society's main metrics
these people were not rewarded for their
work
should they have not done it
yet an ego every one of us has
considered doing precisely that
if that is your attitude how do you
intend to endure tough times
what if you're ahead of the times what
if the market favors some bogus trend
what if your boss or your clients don't
understand
it's far better when doing good work is
sufficient in other words the less
attached we are to outcomes the better
when fulfilling our own standards is
what fills us with pride and
self-respect when the effort not the
results good or bad is enough
with ego this is not nearly sufficient
no we need to be recognized we need to
be compensated especially problematic is
the fact that often we get that we are
praised we are paid we start to assume
that the two things always go together
the expectation hangover inevitably
ensues
there was an unusual encounter between
alexander the great and the famous cynic
philosopher diogenes
allegedly alexander approached diogenes
who was laying down enjoying the summer
air stood over him and asked what he the
most powerful man in the world might be
able to do for this notoriously poor man
diogenes could have asked for anything
what he requested was epic
stop blocking my son
even two thousand years later we can
feel exactly where in the solar plexus
that must have hit alexander a man who
always wanted to prove how important he
was
as the author robert louis stevenson
later observed about this meeting it is
a sore thing to have labored along and
scaled arduous hilltops and when all is
done find humanity indifferent to your
achievement
well get ready for it it will happen
maybe your parents will never be
impressed maybe your girlfriend won't
care maybe the investor won't see the
numbers maybe the audience won't clap
but we have to be able to push through
we can't let that be what motivates us
belisarius had one last run he was found
innocent of the charges and his honors
restored just in time to save the empire
as a white-haired old man
except no life is not a fairy tale he
was again wrongly suspected of plotting
against the emperor in the famous
longfellow poem about our poor general
at the end of his life he is
impoverished and disabled
yet he concludes with great strength
this too can bear i still am belisarius
you will be unappreciated you will be
sabotaged you will experience surprising
failures
your expectations will not be met you
will lose you will fail
how do you carry on then
how do you take pride in yourself and
your work
john wooden's advice to his player says
it changed the definition of success as
he put it success is peace of mind which
is a direct result of self-satisfaction
in knowing you made the effort to do
your best to become the best that you
are capable of becoming
ambition marcus aurelius reminded
himself means tying your well-being to
what other people say or do
sanity means tying to your own actions
do your work do it well
then let go and let god that's all there
needs to be
recognition and rewards those are just
extra
rejection that's on them not on us
john kennedy tools great book a
confederacy of dunces was universally
turned down by publishers news that so
broke his heart he later committed
suicide in his car on an empty road in
biloxi mississippi
after his death his mother discovered
the book advocated on its behalf until
it was published and eventually won a
pulitzer prize
think about that for a second
what changed between those submissions
nothing the book was the same
it was equally great when tool had it in
manuscript form and had fought with
editors about it as it was when the book
was published sold copies and won awards
if only he could have realized this it
would have saved him so much heartbreak
he couldn't but from his painful example
we can at least see how arbitrary many
of the breaks in life are
this is why we can't let externals
determine whether something was worth it
or not it's on us
the world is after all indifferent to
what we humans want if we persist in
wanting in needing we are simply setting
ourselves up for resentment or worse
doing the work is enough
[Music]
fight club moments
if you shut up truth and bury it under
the ground
it will but grow and gather to itself
such explosive power
that the day it bursts through it will
blow up everything in its way
emile zola
there is hardly the space to list all
the successful people who have hit rock
bottom
the notion everyone experiences jarring
perspective altering moments is almost a
cliche
that doesn't mean it isn't true
jk rowling finds herself seven years
after college with a failed marriage no
job single parent
kid she can barely feed and approaching
homelessness
a teenage charlie parker thinks he's
tearing it up on stage right in the
pocket with the rest of the crew
until joe jones throws a symbol at him
and chases him away in humiliation
a young lyndon johnson is beaten to a
pulp by a hill country farm boy over a
girl finally shattering his picture of
himself as [ __ ] of the walk
there are many ways to hit bottom
almost everyone does it in their own way
at some point
in the novel fight club the character
jack's apartment is blown up
all of his possessions every stick of
furniture which he pathetically loved
were lost
later it turns out that jack blew it up
himself he had multiple personalities
and tyler durden orchestrated the
explosion to shock jack from the sad
stupor he was afraid to do anything
about
the result was a journey into an
entirely different and rather dark part
of his life
in greek mythology characters often
experience catabasis or going down
they're forced to retreat the experience
of depression or in some cases literally
descend into the underworld
when they emerge it's with heightened
knowledge and understanding
today we'd call that hell
and on occasion we all spend some time
there
we surround ourselves with [ __ ] with
distractions with lies about what makes
us happy and what's important we become
people we shouldn't become and engage in
destructive awful behaviors
this unhealthy and ego derived state
hardens and becomes almost permanent
until catabasis forces us to face it
duras dura fragontour
hard things are broken by hard things
the bigger the ego the harder the fall
it would be nice if it didn't have to be
this way
if we could nicely be nudged to correct
our ways if a quiet admonishment was
what it took to shoo away illusions if
we could manage to circumvent ego on our
own
but it is just not so
the reverend william a sutton observed
some 120 years ago that we cannot be
humble except by enduring humiliations
how much better it would be to spare
ourselves these experiences
but sometimes it's the only way the
blind can be made to see
in fact many significant life changes
come from moments in which we are
thoroughly demolished in which
everything we thought we knew about the
world is rendered false
we might call these fight club moments
sometimes they are self-inflicted
sometimes inflicted on us but whatever
the cause they can be catalyst for
changes we were petrified to make
pick a time in your life or perhaps it's
a moment you're experiencing now a
boss's eviscerating critique of you in
front of the entire staff
that sit down with the person you loved
the google alert that delivered the
article you'd hoped would never be
written
the call from the creditor
the news that threw you back in your
chair speechless and dumbfounded
it was in those moments
when the break exposes something unseen
before that you were forced to make eye
contact with a thing called truth
no longer could you hide or pretend
such a moment raises many questions
how do i make sense of this
how do i move onward and upward
is this the bottom or is there more to
come
someone told me my problem so how do i
fix them how did i let this happen
how can it never happen again
a look at history finds that these
events seem to be defined by three
traits
one they almost always came at the hands
of some outside force or person
two they often involved things we
already knew about ourselves but were
too scared to admit three from the ruin
came the opportunity for great progress
and improvement
does everyone take advantage of that
opportunity of course not
ego often causes the crash and then
blocks us from improving was the 2008
financial crisis not a moment in which
everything was laid bare for many people
the lack of accountability the over
leveraged lifestyles the greed the
dishonesty
the trends that could not possibly
continue
for some this was a wake-up call
others just a few years later are back
exactly where they were
for them it will be worse the next time
hemingway had his own rock bottom
realizations as a young man
the understanding he took from them is
expressed timelessly in his book a
farewell to arms
he wrote the world breaks everyone and
afterward many are strong at the broken
places but those that will not break it
kills
the world can show you the truth but no
one can force you to accept it
in 12-step groups almost all the steps
are about suppressing the ego and
clearing out the entitlements and
baggage and wreckage that has been
accumulated so that you might see what's
left when all of that is stripped away
and the real you is left
it's always so tempting to turn to that
old friend denial which is your ego
refusing to believe that which you don't
like could be true
psychologists often say that threatened
egotism is one of the most dangerous
forces on earth
the gang member whose honor is impugned
the narcissist who is rejected the bully
who was made to feel shame the impostor
who was exposed the plagiarist or the
embellisher whose story stops adding up
these are not people who you want to be
near when they are cornered
nor is it a corner you want to back
yourself into
that's where you think how can these
people talk to me this way who do they
think they are i'll make them all pay
sometimes because we can't face what's
been said or what's been done we do the
unthinkable in response to the
unbearable
we escalate
this is ego in its purest and most toxic
form
look at lance armstrong he cheated but
so did a lot of people
it was when this cheating was made
public and he was forced to see if only
for a second that he was a cheater that
things got really bad
he insisted on denying it despite all
the evidence he insisted on ruining
other people's lives
we're so afraid to lose our own esteem
or god forbid the esteem of others that
we contemplate doing terrible things
as the bible verse goes everyone who
does wicked things hates the light and
does not come to the light lest his
works should be exposed
big and small this is what we do
getting hit with that spotlight doesn't
feel good
whether we're talking about the exposure
of ordinary self-deception or true evil
but turning away only delays the
reckoning for how long no one can say
face the symptoms cure the disease
ego makes it so hard it's easier to
delay to double down to deliberately
avoid seeing the changes we need to make
in our lives
but change begins by hearing the
criticism in the words of the people
around you
even if those words are mean-spirited
angry or hurtful it means weighing them
discarding the ones that don't matter
and reflecting on the ones that do
in fight club the character has to fire
bomb his own apartment to finally break
through
our expectations and exaggerations and
lack of restraint made such moments
inevitable
ensuring that it would be painful
now it's here
what will you make of it you can change
or you can deny
vince lombardi said this once a team
like men must be brought to its knees
before it can rise again so yes hitting
bottom is as brutal as it sounds
but the feeling after is one of the most
powerful perspectives in the world
president obama described it as he
neared the end of his tumultuous trying
terms i've been in the barrel tumbling
down niagara falls and i emerged and i
lived and that's such a liberating
feeling
if we could help it it would be better
if we never suffered illusions at all
it'd be better if we never had to kneel
or go over the edge
that's what we spent so much time
talking about so far in this book
if that fight is lost we end up here
in the end the only way you can
appreciate your progress is to stand on
the edge of the hole you dug for
yourself
look down inside it and smile fondly at
the bloody claw prince that marked your
journey up the walls
[Music]
draw the line
it can ruin your life only if it ruins
your character
marcus aurelius
delorean ran his car company into the
ground with a mix of outsized ambition
negligence narcissism greed and
mismanagement
as the bad news began to pile up and the
picture was made clear and public how do
you think he responded
was it with resigned acceptance
did he acknowledge the errors his
disgruntled employees were speaking out
about for the first time was he able to
reflect even slightly on the mistakes
and decisions that had brought him his
investors and his employees so much
trouble
of course not
instead he put into motion a series of
events that would end in a 60 million
dollar drug deal and his subsequent
arrest
that's right after his company began to
fail
failure almost exclusively tied to his
unprofessional management style he
figured the best way to save it all
would be to secure financing through an
illegal shipment of 220 pounds of
cocaine
sure after his publicized and very
embarrassing arrest delorean was
eventually acquitted on the charges on
the rather implausible argument of
entrapment
except he is on video holding up a
baggie of cocaine saying with giddy
excitement this stuff is as good as gold
there's no question about who caused
john delorean's disintegration
there's also no question about who made
it so much worse the answer is him
he found himself in a hole and kept
digging until he made it all the way to
hell
if only he'd stop
if at any point he'd said is this the
person i want to be people make mistakes
all the time they start companies they
think they can manage they have grand
and bold visions that were a little too
grandiose
this is all perfectly fine
it's what being an entrepreneur or a
creative or even a business executive is
all about
we take risks we mess up
the problem is when we get our identity
tied up in our work we worry that any
kind of failure will then say something
bad about us as a person
it's a fear of taking responsibility of
admitting that we might have messed up
it's the sunk cost fallacy and so we
throw good money and good life after bad
and end up making everything so much
worse
let's say the walls feel like they're
closing in
it might feel as if you've been betrayed
or your life's work is being stolen
but these are not rational good emotions
that will lead to rational good actions
ego asks why is this happening to me how
do i save this and prove to everyone i'm
as great as they think
it's the animal fear of even the
slightest sign of weakness
you've seen this you've done this
fighting desperately for something we're
only making worse
it is not a path to great things
take steve jobs he was a hundred percent
responsible for his firing from apple
due to his later success apple's
decision to fire him seems like an
example of poor leadership but he was at
the time unmanageable
his ego was unequivocally out of control
if you were john scully and the ceo of
apple you'd have fired that version of
steve jobs too and been right to do so
now steve jobs response to his firing
was understandable he cried he fought
when he lost he sold all but a single
share of his stock in apple and swore
never to think of the place again
but then he started a new company and
threw his whole life into it he tried to
learn as best he could from the
management mistakes at the root of his
first failure
he started another company after that
too called pixar
steve jobs the famous egomaniac who
parked in handicapped parking spaces
just because he could responded in this
critical moment in a surprisingly humble
way
humble for ceos convinced of their own
genius anyway
he worked until he'd not only proven
himself again but significantly resolved
the flaws that had caused his downfall
to begin with
it's not often that successful or
powerful people are able to do this
not when they experience heart-rending
failure
american apparel's founder jeff charney
is an example
after losses of some 300 million and
numerous scandals the company offered
him a choice
step aside as ceo and guide the company
as a creative consultant for a large
salary or be fired
he rejected both options and picked
something much worse
after filing a lawsuit in protest he
gambled his entire ownership in the
company to initiate a hostile takeover
with a hedge fund and insisted that his
conduct be investigated and judged
it was and he was not vindicated
his personal life was splashed across
the headlines and embarrassing details
revealed
the lawyer he chose to represent him in
his lawsuits happened to be the same one
who'd already sued charney close to half
a dozen times for sexual harassment and
financial irregularities
in the past charney had accused this man
of shaking him down and making bogus
legal claims now they were working
together
american apparel spent more than 10
million dollars it didn't have to fight
him off a judge issued a restraining
order sales slumped
finally the company began laying off
factory workers and long-time employees
the exact people he claimed to be
fighting for just to stay afloat
a year later they were bankrupt and he
was out of money too
i was there i saw all of it it broke my
heart
it's like the disgraced statesman and
general alcibiades in the peloponnesian
war he fought first for his home country
and greatest love athens
then driven out for a drunken crime he
may or may not have committed he
defected to sparta athens sworn enemy
then running afoul of the spartans he
defected to persia the sworn enemy of
both
finally he was recalled to athens where
his ambitious plans to invade sicily
drove the athenians to their ultimate
ruin
ego kills what we love
sometimes it comes close to killing us
too
it is interesting that alexander
hamilton who of all the founding fathers
met the most tragic and unnecessary end
would have wise words on this topic
but indeed he does if only he could have
remembered his own advice before
fighting his fatal duel
act with fortitude and honor he wrote to
a distraught friend in serious financial
and legal trouble of the man's own
making
if you cannot reasonably hope for a
favorable extrication do not plunge
deeper have the courage to make a full
stop
a full stop
it's not that these folks should have
quit everything it's that a fighter who
can't tap out or a boxer who can't
recognize when it's time to retire gets
hurt
seriously so
you have to be able to see the bigger
picture
but when ego is in control who can
let's say you failed and let's even say
it was your fault
[ __ ] happens and as they say
sometimes [ __ ] happens in public
it's not fun
the questions remain are you going to
make it worse are you going to emerge
from this with your dignity and
character intact
are you going to live to fight another
day
when a team looks like they're going to
lose a game the coach doesn't call them
all over and lie to them
instead he or she reminds them who they
are and what they're capable of and
urges them to go back out there and
embody that
with winning our miracles off their mind
a good team does its best to complete
the game at the highest standard
possible and share the playing time with
other players who don't regularly play
and sometimes they even come back and
win
most trouble is temporary unless you
make that not so
recovery is not grand it's one step in
front of the other
unless your cure is more of the disease
only ego thinks embarrassment or failure
are more than what they are
history is full of people who suffered
abject humiliations yet recovered to
have long and impressive careers
politicians who lost elections or lost
offices due to indiscretions but came
back to lead after time had passed
actors whose movies bombed authors who
got writer's block celebrities who made
gaffes parents who made mistakes
entrepreneurs with faltering companies
executives who got fired
athletes who were cut
people who live too well at the top of
the market
all of these folks felt the hard edge of
failure just like we have when we lose
we have a choice
are we going to make this a lose-lose
situation for ourselves and everyone
involved or will this be a lose
and then when
because you will lose in life
it's a fact
a doctor has to call time of death at
some point they just do
ego says we're the immovable object the
unstoppable force this delusion causes
the problems it meets failure and
adversity with rule breaking
betting everything on some crazy scheme
doubling down on behind the scenes
machinations or unlikely hail mary's
even though that's what got you to this
pain point in the first place
at any given time in the circle of life
we may be aspiring succeeding or failing
though right now we're failing with
wisdom we understand that these
positions are transitory not statements
about your value as a human being
when success begins to slip from your
fingers for whatever reason the response
isn't to grip and claw so hard that you
shatter it to pieces
it's to understand that you must work
yourself back to the aspirational phase
you must get back to first principles
and best practices
he who fears death will never do
anything worthy of a living man seneca
once said
alter that he who will do anything to
avoid failure will almost certainly do
something worthy of failure
the only real failure is abandoning your
principles
killing what you love because you can't
bear to part from it is selfish and
stupid
if your reputation can't absorb a few
blows it wasn't worth anything in the
first place
[Music]
maintain your own scorecard
i never look back
except to find out about mistakes
i only see danger in thinking back about
things you are proud of
elizabeth noel neumann
on april 16 2000 the new england
patriots drafted an extra quarterback
out of the university of michigan
they'd scouted him thoroughly and had
their eye on him for some time
seeing that he was still available they
took him it was the sixth round and the
199th pick of the draft
the young quarterback's name was tom
brady
he was fourth string at the beginning of
his rookie season by his second season
he was a starter new england won the
super bowl that year brady was named mvp
in terms of return on investment it's
probably the single greatest draft pick
in the history of football
four super bowl rings out of six
appearances
14 starting seasons
172 wins
428 touchdowns three super bowl mvps
58 000 yards 10 pro bowls and more
division titles than any quarterback in
history it's not even finished paying
dividends brady may still have many more
seasons left in him so you'd think that
the patriots front office would be
ecstatic with how it turned out and
indeed they were they were also
disappointed deeply so in themselves
brady's surprising abilities meant that
the patriots scouting reports were way
off
for all their evaluations of players
they'd somehow missed or miscalculated
all of his intangible attributes they'd
let this gem wait until the sixth round
someone else could have drafted him
more than that they didn't even know
they were right about brady until
injuries knocked out drew bledsoe their
prize starter and forced them to realize
his potential
so even though their bets paid off the
patriots honed in on the specific
intelligence failure that could have
prevented the pick from happening in the
first place
not that they were nitpicking or
indulging in perfectionism they had
higher standards of performance to
adhere to
for gear scott pioli director of
personnel for the patriots kept a photo
on his desk of dave stachelski a player
the team had drafted in the fifth round
but had never made it through training
camp
it was a reminder you're not as good as
you think you don't have it all figured
out
stay focused do better
coach john wooden was very clear about
this too
the scoreboard was not the judge of
whether he or the team had achieved
success that wasn't what constituted
winning
bo jackson wouldn't get impressed when
he hit a home run or ran for a touchdown
because he knew he hadn't done it
perfect
in fact he didn't ask for the ball after
his first hit in major league baseball
for that reason to him it was just a
ground ball up the middle
this is characteristic of how great
people think
it's not that they find failure in every
success they just hold themselves to a
standard that exceeds what society might
consider to be objective success
because of that they don't much care
what other people think they care
whether they meet their own standards
and these standards are much much higher
than everyone else's
the patriots saw the brady pick as being
more lucky than smart
and though some people are fine giving
themselves credit for luck they weren't
no one would say that the patriots or
any team in the nfl are without ego
but in this instance instead of
celebrating or congratulating themselves
they put their heads back down and
focused on how to get even better
that's what makes humility such a
powerful force
organizationally personally
professionally this isn't necessarily
fun by the way can feel like
self-inflicted torture sometimes
but it does force you to always keep
going and always improve
ego can't see both sides of the issue
it can't get better because it only sees
the validation
remember vain men never hear anything
but praise
it can only see what's going well
not what isn't
it's why you might see egomaniacs with
temporary leads but rarely lasting runs
of it
for us the scoreboard can't be the only
scoreboard
warren buffett has said the same thing
making a distinction between the inner
score card and the external one your
potential the absolute best you're
capable of
that's the metric to measure yourself
against your standards are winning is
not enough people can get lucky and win
people can be [ __ ] and win anyone
can win but not everyone is the best
possible version of themselves
harsh
yes
the flip side of that is it means
honestly being able to be proud and
strong during the occasional defeat as
well
when you take ego out of the equation
other people's opinions and external
markers don't matter as much
that's more difficult but ultimately a
formula for resilience
the economist and philosopher adam smith
had a theory for how wise and good
people evaluate their actions
he said there are two different
occasions upon which we examine our own
conduct and endeavor to view it in the
light in which the impartial spectator
would view it
first when we are about to act and
secondly after we have acted
our views are apt to be very partial in
both cases but they are apt to be most
partial when it is of the most
importance that they should be otherwise
when we are about to act the eagerness
of passion will seldom allow us to
consider what we are doing with the
candor of an indifferent person when the
action is over indeed and the passions
which prompted it have subsided we can
enter more cruelly into the sentiments
of the indifferent spectator
this indifferent spectator is a sort of
guide with which we can judge our
behavior as opposed to the groundless
applause that society so often gives out
not that it's just about validation
though
think of all the people who excuse their
behavior politicians powerful ceos and
the like as not technically illegal
think of the times you've excused your
own with no one will know
this is the moral gray area that our ego
loves to exploit
holding your ego against the standard
inner or indifferent or whatever you
want to call it makes it less and less
likely that excess or wrongdoing is
going to be tolerated by you
because it's not about what you can get
away with it's about what you should or
shouldn't do
it's a harder road at first but one that
ultimately makes us less selfish and
self-absorbed a person who judges
himself based on his own standards
doesn't crave the spotlight the same way
as someone who lets applause dictate
success
a person who can think long term doesn't
pity herself during short-term setbacks
a person who values the team can share
credit and subsume his own interests in
a way that most others can't
reflecting on what went well or how
amazing we are doesn't get us anywhere
except maybe to where we are right now
but we want to improve we want more we
want to continue to improve
ego blocks that so we subsume it and
smash it with continually higher
standards
not that we are endlessly pursuing more
as if we are racked with greed but
instead we're inching our way towards
real improvement with discipline rather
than disposition
[Music]
always love
and why should we feel anger at the
world as if the world would notice
euripides
in 1939 a young prodigy named orson
welles was given one of the most unheard
of deals in hollywood history he could
write act and direct in two films of his
choosing for rko
a major movie studio
for his first picture he decided to tell
the story of a mysterious newspaper
baron who became a prisoner of his
enormous empire and lifestyle
william randolph hurst the infamous
media magnate decided that this movie
was based on his life and more
importantly that it did so offensively
he then began and initially succeeded in
an all-consuming campaign to destroy one
of the greatest films of all time
here's what's so interesting about this
first hearst most likely never even saw
the film so he had no idea what was
actually in it
second it wasn't intended to be about
him or at least solely about him as far
as we know the character charles foster
kane was an amalgam of several
historical figures including samuel
insell and robert mccormick the movie
was also inspired by two similar
portraits of power by charlie chaplin
and aldous huxley and it wasn't supposed
to vilify but to humanize
third
hearst was one of the richest men in the
world at the time and at 78 near the end
of his life
why would he spend so much time on
something as inconsequential as a
fictional movie by a first time director
fourth it was his campaign to stop it
that secured the movie's place in
popular lore and made it clear the
extent to which his drive to control and
manipulate would go
ironically he cemented his own legacy as
a reviled american figure far more than
any critic ever could have
thus the paradox of hate and bitterness
it accomplishes almost exactly the
opposite of what we hope it does
in the internet age we call this the
streisand effect named after a similar
attempt by the singer and actress
barbara streisand who tried to legally
remove a photo of her home from the web
her actions backfired and far more
people saw it than would have when she
left the issue alone
attempting to destroy something out of
hate or ego often ensures that it will
be preserved and disseminated forever
the lengths that hearst went to were
absurd
he sent his most influential and
powerful gossip columnist luella parsons
to the studio to demand a screening
based on her feedback he decided that he
would do everything in his power to
block it from being made public he
issued a directive that none of his
newspapers were to make any mention of
any rko film the company producing
citizen kane period
more than a decade later this ban still
applied to wells for all hearse papers
hearst papers began exploring negative
stories about wells in his private life
his gossip columnist threatened to do
the same to each of rko's board members
hearst also made threats to the movie
industry as a whole as a way of turning
other studio heads against the picture
an eight hundred thousand dollar offer
was made for the rights of the film so
that it might be burned or destroyed
most theater chains were pressured into
refusing to show it and no ads for it
were allowed in any hearst owned
properties
her sympathizers began reporting rumors
about wells to various authorities and
in 1941
j edgar hoover's fbi opened a file on
him
the result was that the movie failed
commercially it took years for it to
find its place in the culture
only at great expense and with great
exertion was hearst able to hold it back
we all have stuff that pisses us off the
more successful or powerful we are
the more there will be that we think we
need to protect in terms of our legacy
image and influence
if we're not careful however we can end
up wasting an incredible amount of time
trying to keep the world from
displeasing or disrespecting us
it is a sobering thought to consider for
a moment all the needless death and
needless waste inflicted over the eons
by angry men or aggrieved women on other
people on society and on themselves over
what
reasons that can hardly be remembered
you know what is a better response to an
attack or a slight or something you
don't like
love
that's right love
for the neighbor who won't turn down the
music for the parent that let you down
for the bureaucrat who lost your
paperwork for the group that rejects you
for the critic who attacks you the
former partner who stole your business
idea the [ __ ] or the bastard who
cheated on you love
because as the song lyrics go
hate will get you every time
okay maybe love is too much to ask for
whatever it is that you've had done to
you
you could at the very least try to let
it go
you could try to shake your head and
laugh about it
otherwise the world will witness another
example of a timeless and sad pattern
rich powerful person becomes so isolated
and delusional that when something
happens contrary to his wishes he
becomes consumed by it
the same drive that made him great is
suddenly a great weakness he turns a
minor inconvenience into a massive sore
the wound festers becomes infected and
can even kill him
this is what propelled nixon forward and
then sadly downward
reflecting on his own exile he later
acknowledged that his lifelong image of
himself is a scrappy fighter battling a
hostile world was his undoing
he'd surrounded himself with other such
tough guys
people forget that nixon was re-elected
by a landslide after watergate broke
he just couldn't help himself he kept
fighting he persecuted reporters and he
lashed out at everyone he felt had
slighted or doubted him it's what
continued to feed the story and
ultimately sank him
like many such people he ended up doing
more damage to himself than anyone else
could
the root of it was his hatefulness and
his anger
and even being the most powerful leader
in the free world couldn't change it
it doesn't need to be like that
booker t washington tells an anecdote
told to him by frederick douglass about
a time he was traveling and asked to
move and ride in the baggage car because
of his race
a white supporter rushed up to him to
apologize for this horrible offense
i'm sorry mr douglas that you have been
degraded in this manner the person said
douglas would have none of that he
wasn't angry he wasn't hurt he replied
with great fervor they cannot degrade
frederick douglass the soul that is
within me no man can degrade i am not
the one that is being degraded on
account of this treatment but those who
are inflicting it upon me
certainly this is an incredibly
difficult attitude to maintain it's far
easier to hate it's natural to lash out
yet we find what defines great leaders
like douglas is that instead of hating
their enemies they feel a sort of pity
and empathy for them
think of barbara jordan at the 1992
democratic national convention proposing
an agenda of love
love
love love
think of martin luther king jr over and
over again preaching that hate was a
burden and love was freedom
love was transformational hate was
debilitating
in one of his most famous sermons he
took it further he said we begin to love
our enemies and love those persons that
hate us whether in collective life or
individual life by looking at ourselves
we must strip ourselves of the ego that
protects and suffocates us because as he
said
hate at any point is a cancer that gnaws
away at the very vital center of your
life in your existence
it is like eroding acid that eats away
the best in the objective center of your
life
take inventory for a second
what do you dislike
whose name fills you with reversion and
rage now ask
have these strong feelings really helped
you accomplish anything
take an even wider inventory
where has hatred and rage ever really
gotten anyone
especially because almost universally
the traits or behaviors that have pissed
us off in other people their dishonesty
their selfishness their laziness
are hardly going to work out well for
them in the end
their ego and short-sightedness contains
its own punishment
the question we must ask ourselves is
are we going to be miserable just
because other people are
consider how orson welles responded to
the multi-decade campaign by hearst
according to his own account he bumped
into hearst in an elevator on the night
of the movie's premiere the very one
that hearst had deployed massive
resources to prevent and destroy
do you know what he did
he invited hearst to come
when hearst declined wells joked that
charles foster kane surely would have
accepted
it took a very long time for wells's
genius in that movie to finally be
acknowledged by the rest of the world
no matter whales soldiered on making
other movies and producing other
fantastic art by all accounts he lived a
fulfilling and happy life
eventually citizen kane secured its
place in the forefront of cinematic
history
70 years after the movie's debut was
finally played at hearst castle at san
simeon which is now a state park
the events he endured weren't exactly
fair but at least he didn't let it ruin
his life as well as his girlfriend of
20-plus years sat in his eulogy
referring not just to hearse but to
every slight he ever received in his
long career in a notoriously ruthless
industry
i promise you it didn't make him bitter
in other words he never became like
hearst
not everyone is capable of responding
that way
at various points in our lives we seem
to have different capacities for
forgiveness and understanding and even
when some people are able to carry on
they carry with them a needless load of
resentment
remember kirk hammett who suddenly
became the guitarist in metallica
the man they kicked out to make room for
him dave mustain went on to form another
band megadeth even amidst his own
unbelievable success he was eaten up
with rage and hatred over the way he'd
been treated those many years before
it drove him to addiction and could have
killed him
it was 18 years until he was able to
begin to process it
and said it still felt like yesterday
that he'd been hurt and rejected
when you hear him tell it as he did once
on camera to his former band mates
it sounds like he ended up living under
a bridge
in reality the man sold millions of
records produced great music and live
the life of a rock star
we've all felt this pain and to quote
his lyrics smiled its black tooth grin
this obsession with the past was
something that someone did or how things
should have been as much as it hurts is
ego embodied
everyone else has moved on but you can't
because you can't see anything but your
own way
you can't conceive of accepting that
someone could hurt you deliberately or
otherwise
so you hate
in failure or adversity it's so easy to
hate
hate defers blame it makes someone else
responsible it's a distraction too
we don't do much else when we're busy
getting revenge or investigating the
wrongs that have supposedly been done to
us
does this get us any closer to where we
want to be
no
it just keeps us where we are or worse
arrests our development entirely
if we are already successful as hearst
was it tarnishes our legacy and turns
sour what should be our golden years
meanwhile love is right there
egoless open positive vulnerable
peaceful and productive
[Music]
for all that comes next ego is the enemy
i don't like work no man does but i like
what is in the work the chance to find
yourself
joseph conrad
in william manchester's epic biography
of the life of winston churchill the
middle volume a third of the set is
titled alone
for a full eight years churchill stood
more or less by himself against his
short-sighted peers against the rising
threat of fascism even among the west
but eventually he triumphed again and
faced adversity again and was vindicated
again
catherine graham stood alone as she took
over her family's newspaper empire her
son donald graham must have felt similar
pressure as he sought to preserve the
company during the dramatic declines of
the industry in the mid-2000s
both made it through
so can you there is no way around it we
will experience difficulty we will feel
the touch of failure
as benjamin franklin observed those who
drink to the bottom of the cup must
expect to meet with some of the dregs
but what if the dregs weren't so bad
as harold genon put it
people learn from their failures
seldom do they learn anything from
success
it's why the old celtic saying tells us
see much study much suffer much
that is the path to wisdom
what you face right now could should and
can be such a path
wisdom or ignorance
ego is the swing vote
aspiration leads to success and
adversity
success creates its own adversity and
hopefully new ambitions
and adversity leads to aspiration and
more success
it's an endless loop
all of us exist on this continuum
we occupy different places on it at
various points in our lives
but when we do fail it sucks no question
whatever is next for us we can be sure
of one thing we'll want to avoid
ego
it makes all the steps hard but failure
is the one it will make permanent
unless we learn right here and right now
from our mistakes
unless we use this moment as an
opportunity to understand ourselves and
our own mind better
ego will seek out failure like true
north
all great men and women went through
difficulties to get to where they are
all of them made mistakes they found
within those experiences some benefit
even if it was simply the realization
that they are not infallible and that
things would not always go their way
they found that self-awareness was the
way out and through
if they hadn't they wouldn't have gotten
better and they wouldn't have been able
to rise again
which is why we have their mantra to
guide us so that we can survive and
thrive in every phase of our journey
it is simple though as always never easy
not to aspire or seek out of ego
to have success without ego
to push through failure with strength
not ego
[Music]
epilogue
there is something of a civil war going
on within all of our lives
there is a recalcitrant south of our
soul revolting against the north of our
soul
and there is this continual struggle
within the very structure of every
individual life
martin luther king jr
if you're listening to this right now
then you've made it through this book
i was afraid some people might not
to be perfectly honest i wasn't sure i'd
ever get here myself
how do you feel tired confused free
it's no easy task to go head to head
with one's ego
to accept first that ego may be there
then to subject it to scrutiny and
criticism
most of us can't handle uncomfortable
self-examination
it's easier to do just about anything
else
in fact some of the world's most
unbelievable accomplishments are
undoubtedly a result of a desire to
avoid facing the darkness of ego
in any case just by making it to this
point you've struck a serious blow
against it
it's not all you need to do
but it is a start
my friend the philosopher and martial
artist daniele bolelli once gave me a
helpful metaphor
he explained that training was like
sweeping the floor
just because we've done it once doesn't
mean the floor is clean forever
every day the dust comes back every day
we must sweep
the same is true for ego
you would be stunned at what kind of
damage dust and dirt can do over time
and how quickly it accumulates and
becomes utterly unmanageable
a few days after being fired by the
american apparel board of directors dove
charney called me at 3 am
he was alternately despondent and angry
genuinely believing himself to be
totally blameless for his situation
i asked him what are you going to do are
you going to pull a steve jobs and start
a new company
are you going to make a comeback
he got quiet and said to me with an
earnestness i could feel through the
phone and in my bones
ryan steve jobs died
to him in this adult state this failure
this blow was somehow the same as death
that was one of the last times we ever
spoke
i watched with horror in the months that
followed as he wreaked havoc on the
company he had put everything into
building
it was a sad moment and one that has
stayed with me
but for the grace of god go i but for
the grace of god that could be any of us
we all experience success in failure in
our own way
struggling to write this book i went
through four hard-fought but rejected
drafts of the proposal and dozens of
drafts of the manuscript
in my earlier projects i'm sure the
strain would have broken me
maybe i would have quit or tried to work
with someone else
maybe i would have dug in my heels to
get my way and irreparably damaged the
book
at some point during the process i came
up with a therapeutic device
after each draft i would tear up the
pages and feed the paper to a worm
compost that kept in my garage
a few months later those painful pages
were dirt that nourished my yard which i
could walk on with bare feet
it was a real intangible connection to
that larger immensity
i like to remind myself that the same
process is going to happen to me when
i'm done when i die and nature tears me
up
one of the most freeing realizations
came to me while i was writing and
thinking about the ideas and the pages
you've just listened to
it occurred to me what a damaging
delusion this notion that our lives are
grand monuments set to last for all time
really is
any ambitious person knows that feeling
that you must do great things that you
must get your way and that if you don't
that you're a worthless failure and the
world is conspiring against you
there's so much pressure that eventually
we all break under it or are broken by
it
of course that is not true
yes we all have potential within us we
all have goals and accomplishments that
we know we can achieve whether it's
starting a company finishing a creative
work making a run at a championship or
getting to the top of your respective
field
these are worthy aims a broken person
will not get there
the problem is when ego intrudes on
these pursuits corrupting them and
undermining us as we set out to achieve
and accomplish
whispering lies as we embark on that
journey and whispering lies as we
succeed in it and worse whispering
painful lies when we stumble along the
way
ego like any drug might be indulged at
first in the misguided attempt to get an
edge or to take one off
the problem is how quickly it becomes an
end unto itself
which is how one finds themselves in
surreal moments like the one i
experienced on the phone with dove or in
any of the cautionary tales in this book
in the course of my work and my life i
found that most of the consequences of
ego are not quite so calamitous
many of the people in your life and in
our world who have given over to their
ego will not get what they deserve in
the sense of karmic justice that we're
taught to believe in as kids
i wish it were so simple
instead the consequences are closer to
the ending of one of my favorite books
what makes sammy run by bud schulberg a
novel whose famous character is based on
the real lives of entertainment
entrepreneurs like samuel goldwyn and
david l selznick
in the book the narrator is called to
the palatial mansion of a calculating
ruthless egotistical hollywood mogul
whose precipitous rise he has followed
with a mix of admiration and confusion
and eventually discussed
in this moment of vulnerability the
narrator catches a true glimpse into the
man's life his lonely empty marriage his
fear his insecurity his inability to be
still even for a second
he realizes that the vengeance the bad
karma he'd hoped for for all the rules
the man had broken
all the cheating ways he had gotten
ahead wasn't coming
because it was already there
as he writes
i had expected something conclusive and
fatal and now i realize that what was
coming to him was not a sudden payoff
but a process
a disease that he had caught in the
epidemic that swept over his birthplace
like a plague
a cancer that was slowly eating him away
the symptoms developing and intensifying
success loneliness fear
fear of all the bright young men the
newer fresher sammy glicks that would
spring up to harass him to threaten him
and finally overtake him
that's how ego manifests itself
and isn't that what we're desperately
afraid of becoming
i'll reveal one last thing i hope will
make this come full circle
i first read that passage when i was 19
years old
it was reading a sign by a seasoned
mentor who had found as i would early
success in the entertainment business
the book was influential and informative
for me just as he'd known it would be
yet over the next few years i worked
myself into a nearly identical situation
as the characters in the book
not just summon to the palatial home to
watch the expected and unavoidable
dissolution of a person i admired but to
find myself dangerously close to my own
shortly thereafter
i know the passage struck me because
when i went to type it up for this
epilogue i found in my original copy
pages covered in my own handwriting
written years before
detailing my reaction right before i had
set out into the world
clearly i had understood schulberg's
words intellectually
even emotionally but i had made the
wrong choices anyway i had swept once
and thought it was enough
ten years after first reading it and
writing down my thoughts i was ready
once more
those lessons came home to me in exactly
the way i needed them to
there's a quote from bismarck that says
in effect any fool can learn from
experience
the trick is to learn from other
people's experience
this book started around the latter idea
and to my surprise ended with a painful
amount of the former as well
i set out to study ego and came crashing
into my own
and to those of the people i had long
since looked up to
it may be that you'll need to experience
some of that on your own too
perhaps it is like plutarch's reflection
that we
don't so much gain the knowledge of
things by the words as words by the
experience we have of things
in any case i want to conclude this book
with the idea that has underpinned all
of what you've just heard
that it's admirable to want to be better
businessmen or business women better
athletes better conquerors
we should want to be better informed
better off financially we should want as
i've said a few times in this audio book
to do great things
i know that i do
but no less impressive in accomplishment
being better people
being happier people
being balanced people
being content people
being humble and selfless people
or better yet all of these traits
together
and what is most obvious but most
ignored is that perfecting the personal
regularly leads to success as a
professional but rarely the other way
around
working to refine our habitual thoughts
working to clamp down on destructive
impulses these are not simply the moral
requirements of any decent person
they will make us more successful they
will help us navigate the treacherous
waters that ambition will require us to
travel
and they are also their own reward
so here you are at the end of this book
about ego having seen as much as one can
be shown about the problems of ego
from other people's experiences in my
own
what is left
your choices
what will you do with this information
not just now but going forward
every day for the rest of your life you
will find yourself at one of three
phases aspiration success failure
you will battle the ego in each of them
you will make mistakes in each of them
you must sweep the floor every minute of
every day
and then sweep again
[Music]
you